[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the world's oldest civilization was born
here thousands of years later it is one
of the world's chess powerhouses
for most of the past 30 years China has
held the most prestigious title in
women's chess the legacy of the Women's
World Championship is Rich menchik got
prindashvili and chipper donitza
kasteniak season and ho Irfan
now three-time world champion Juan Jun
is defending her title once more
after vanquishing the likes of Katarina
lagno and Alexander goriashkiner another
rival awaits
Challenger Lei TJ had to defeat three
grand Masters in matches herself to get
it in the first two rounds of the
candidates shooter consists Maria and
Anna music and one
then in the final she beat former world
champion
the winner of the 2023 honeydead finals
will Jew and June defend or will we have
a first time Champion Lei Ting Jay
half the match is in Jews hometown of
Shanghai half the match in Chongqing
where lay hails from
who will win and claim their share of
the 500 000 Euro price fund
welcome to the official broadcast of the
2023 v-day women's Chess Championship
hello everyone and we are back in
Chongqing for the moment we have all
been waiting for it's been 17 days two
locations 11 games of classical chairs
and today in the 12th and final game we
could see who will be crowned women's
world champion nothing separates women's
world champion Juan Jun from Lei Ting
Jay the Challenger well but a decisive
result today we'll see dreams being made
and broken will this match end today or
will tie breaks tomorrow decide the
crown well we will find out I for sure
am excited and I'm your host
International Mastery van gerhauska and
it is a great pleasure and honor to be
commentating alongside one of the most
iconic and also Innovative voices in
women's chess and in chess in general
today she's us two-time Champion she's
also written many best sellers chess
play like a girl and of course the
new one chess queens and oh my God I'm
just so pumped for today's action again
I am commentating alongside the one and
only woman grandma said Jennifer had a
I am so excited job no matter what
happens today is going to be thrilling
that's what I love we're either going to
have a world champion reigning Champion
Jew and June will extend her Legacy or
Layton Chase gonna take it down
um creating an 18th Champion or the
tension is gonna Mount even more and we
get to see Playhouse tomorrow so it's
like win-win-win oh wow for the women uh
it's it's more of a zero-sum game but
for us as viewers
um it really is
um all rows lead to thrilling chess and
I just can't wait to um see it get going
Jody do you have any predictions
yourself about the opening today
oh I I think this one is so tough
because we can see you know as you said
this is the 12th and final game if
someone makes a mistake they could walk
away with nothing yes okay you know
second place is not that bad and there
are some perks to it but ultimately the
dream is to either retain becoming
women's world champion or becoming the
18th new women's world champion in the
case of letting Jay and this match has
been so hard for it it's been untense at
times and there we can see the
scoreboard the games one to six was
played in Shanghai and it's been very
close a lot of fighting draws they've
been played to The Bitter End but in
game five it was late TJ that broke
through but when it comes to Game 7 to
12 that was played in Chongqing and this
time it was all about Jew wenju and she
leveled up she understood she needed to
change up her strategy and she struck
back in game eight and that's how it
stands we have like 11 games each player
has won one game each and now 12th game
this is it and I am so pumped for this I
mean like you say I whoever whoever wins
it's going to be a victory for chess
overall and there we see Juwan Jun
reigning women's world champion
she has the white pieces I predict that
we're going to see something very safe
very stable and if lateing Jane knows
what she's doing I think the game will
fizzle out pretty quickly into a draw
and I think it's going to be operation
reset and all systems go for tomorrow
and the tie breaks but
these two players they promised us
Fighting Chess and they have delivered
on that front of every level and there
we can see on the camera lating J with
the black pieces what do you expect for
lateing Jay she's come so well prepared
oh that's true and I think it's all
about well let's see what the first move
of the game is for her says I see
there's a poll actually in our twitch
chat is it going to be D4 E4 or
something else well E4 would be a real
shocker because we haven't seen that yet
but hey prepare to be surprised uh but I
had noticed that Juan Jun has been
playing this cagey night move Knight to
F3 for the last few games where she had
the white pieces including the game that
you want so I suspect we're gonna see
that again
I suspect that we might see something
like that again
but then again you know letting Jay
again she always tells us you know she's
well prepared she plays the opening very
quickly she's very she's full of
expressions and what are we seeing we
sing ah what do you want Jun is
indicating that she intends to open up
with the Queen's pawn and here we've
seen uh late in Jay also indicate that
she intends to follow suit so could we
see a repeat of the first round where do
you want Jun played tarash or could we
see like a Vienna and Argentine
variation
oh this is exciting and uh late in J
turns and gives a smile to the audience
this is going to reveal the player's
strategies especially June
is she gonna try to nurture Advantage
set the pace of the game or will she say
no today it's all about resting playing
a quick game that ends peacefully and
then tomorrow
the action Begins for real
well we haven't seen a quick draw yet in
this event and uh technically
um not uh part of the rules but there is
of course ways where you could repeat or
you could just play a position that is
less exciting and you make it to move
forward but there's just little risk for
both sides we could see that but I you
know prepare to be surprised you know I
I also wouldn't be shocked if somehow
this game ends up blowing up and we see
the world championship end today so I
mean yesterday the position really blew
up out of nowhere and Juan June got I
think a sizable Advantage with a lot of
pressure on lighting today but if we see
it this is what it's going to look like
the tie break format first it's going to
be the best of four rapid games that's
25 minutes plus a 10 second increment
and that's going to be an epic battle I
mean hours of thrilling chess if that's
still deadlocked 2-2 we go go to Blitz
game mini matches best of two and
finally they keep swapping colors and
continue until there's a decisive result
I do like these tybreak rules but I will
say something it is very grueling this
is not a quick tiebreak uh it's way more
grueling yeah yeah so that that is
probably one of the reasons where
um a lot of people are predicting a draw
today not only because they're great
players great Defenders but with that
intense and exhausting tiebreak looming
they are going to need a lot of energy
for tomorrow if we have it tomorrow
yeah absolutely and just to kind of just
pull up that's time controls you need
normally when it comes to the rapid you
play at a time Patrol 15 minutes plus 10
seconds here it's 25 minutes plus 10
seconds so yeah this is a way longer
time control than most people are used
to but
before those tie breaks can even occur
where we have a 12 game and the players
will be playing at a very standard fide
classical time control over 90 minutes
for 40 moves and once they reach move 40
they will get a half hour time bonus but
as always there is a Time increment more
from move one of 30 seconds and the
tension is rising the excitement is just
pumping through my veins Jen I can't
wait for this moment and we can see the
players they're looking around
and again letting Jay does not know what
to expect from June she does not know
whether Jew and Joan wants to push for
that win
or she is content with a quick draw or a
draw and move it to tomorrow for some
tie breaks
what do you predict Jen
well I do predict that uh it's gonna be
um a safe game but I think that the
players uh have not made any drill draws
so far so I think it's just going to be
one of those games where
it's pretty safe but if due when June
finds an opportunity she will pounce and
there we have it D4 D5
yep um Knight of three on the board so
Juan Jen delaying with pushing the C
pawn two squares
and are we going to see
okay which is late in J so far copies
and is the bishop gonna come out at F4
E3 played
oh okay not the most ambitious move and
in fact
employed something very similar when she
played Lei teen Jay in their match for
the candidate in the candidates finals
and uh well we can see from the camera
that's letting Jay not surprised at all
and immediately playing her favorite
move when she has this Pawn structure C5
yeah I mean when your opponent plays
more in the passively side Let's uh
let's go get some all right let's go get
some Center control
um plays E6 the idea of retooing that
pawn with the bishop
right here and where it looks like we're
getting those moves now
okay B4 holding on to it
well that's a very committal idea
actually to play B4 let me
check before okay very much in the realm
of theory a favorite
a favorite of uh Liam actually of top
Vietnamese Grandmaster very strong he's
played a few times he's played it
against uh aronian also against Wesley
so and obviously white does have a pawn
Advantage but of course it's gonna get
destabilized and I say that and there I
see that uh lateing day has played A5
which is the main move and we're
expecting do you want Jun to hold on to
that pawn with C3
you mentioned Liam lay he's uh well
known here in the United States as he is
a a Webster grad and he's also the
director of their program actually is
Grandmaster Susan Polgar retired from
coaching the chess club Dynasty and uh
Liam way has taken over
and uh we see Fontes Bono played and
pawn takes porn and I'm expecting a B6
and there we see
B6 plate I mean black Smooths are very
straightforward white has won a pawn is
trying to hold on to it and black is
like no no no you can't kind of get that
pawn and uh well okay some big mousse
here and we can also see players and
people in chats are having their fingers
crossed for a decisive result yes that
would be definitely something that we
all want to see why why I would wake up
in the middle of the night again
tomorrow to see all the playoffs Joe you
know I can go either way but again a
win-win for us it's it's good either way
uh but let's see what happens so after
this move B6 this is all about attacking
um the pawn chain right because yeah
white is still underdeveloped so you
can't just take on B6 because there's
Bishop takes B4 check
um little in between move before we
recapture on uh B6 uh instead it looks
like
uh Bishop B5 check has already been
played and we've got a few more moves on
the board don't we no okay I'm sorry
excuse me after Bishop B5 check now just
now Bishop D7 I believe was played
and so far again checking the databases
very much Theory Liam lay as you
mentioned uh Webster graduate also in
charge of the Webster training program
he has played this against a video and
so and also I see a long list of players
like kramnik blue balm and Bishop takes
Bishop played again the main move and
it is it does appear that June has
chosen a very forcing variation Knight
vd7 and here after this move the top
idea is to play A4 and just to get this
poor majority there on the queen side
wait what this is
A4 let's let me try to understand that
move because it's uh Knight p87 I
understand A4 is Theory but it let's try
to understand why we're playing it so if
we play C6 in this position again
there's Bishop B4 Jack and I guess
that's annoying
um suppose if we play Bishop D2 even
that line though I I am a little curious
if C6
well they are playing moves fast and
furious so I guess we can keep up with
them um and I'll philosophize about the
opening later but we have A4
and so many fast moves here Jovi B takes
C5 B5 okay so that's part of the idea of
this A4 that we can play this move B5
and queen A5 check doesn't win the pawn
back okay now I understand yeah and uh
this is really really dangerous
variation for both sides black of course
has this a well overwhelming porn Santa
there in the middle of the board but in
the end game if it gets to an end game
these pawns A4 and B5 are gonna be
Killers those are no hiding that so big
decision here for letting Jay I'm just
again looking at the database and saying
the most popular move is the most
natural move to go Bishop D6 and in
order to support an E5 and obviously get
the king to safety C4 is another idea
that has been played to lengthen this
dark squared Bishop's diagonal and even
and get this one I will I wouldn't be
surprised to see Leighton J play this G5
has been played whoa that's that's now
if if she plays that move we might have
to adjust our prediction and the game is
going to be quiet drawlish because G5
bang I and I presume the idea is that if
Knight takes pawners Rook G8 and we um
are eyeing that uh G Pawn because white
hasn't castled yet so kind of punishing
this uh very very uh focused Queen side
um expansion here and after work GA and
I guess you would uh be in a bit of
trouble actually because
um you know moving the Knight and
allowing us to crash through Rook takes
G2 can't be very good for why
no exactly it's not going to be it's not
going to end well I mean after all just
take a look at White's King safety you
know something that I bang on about like
so many times the king is nervous King
you always have to justify your
placement or the pieces and this King
just doesn't have a home so yes in
theory
these guys are very good in the end game
but before the end game as uh Alexandra
castaniak's father reminded us the
Godzilla plays the middle game and yeah
if this one survives it will be a
miracle and so I'm not expecting
Knight takes G5 if G5 does make an
appearance but certainly this is a
really forcing let's go back to the game
position because later has taken a pause
so this is a really forcing variation
and it's certainly caught lateing J
unawares
it's very sharp something that you
ranjin hasn't been doing straight out of
the opening she's been especially these
last two games with the white pieces
she's just been playing very natural
positions just trying to get a game that
she can then outplay lating J from here
This Is War immediately from the
beginning
it is and I you know I really am kind of
surprised I expected something more
um balanced today instead it's uh
there's just so much going on you know
in Whiteside what do we have going for
us well we got this beautiful Pawn on B5
right so uh that's definitely something
to write home about if we can
consolidate the position and start
pressuring black and pushing those
connected path pawns forward you know we
could win the game in a tremendous
fashion making an extra Queen to become
the the next uh women's world champion
and chess Queen uh but on the other hand
black is going to as you mentioned play
for that middle game and that Center
control and look at this she's playing
the move Queen t7
um I don't think that was one of the
main moves that you suggested was it no
it wasn't and again I'm looking at the
database I can see that 94 had been
played Rook A7 had even been tried and
this one is way down on list Queen sees
oven and I'm kind of curious as to why
it wasn't so popular maybe the queen
didn't necessarily belong on C7 maybe if
you'd backed it up with Bishop D6 the
queen might find herself wanting to be
on E7 or maybe even on B6 at some point
but uh okay Queen C7 it is and now it is
due when June's turn to unpack and I'm
sure her her main preparation would have
centered either on G5 which is again the
most active thrust in the position or
she would have like looked at how to
play after Bishop D6 and I'm kind of
curious
so I'm looking at what was White's plan
after the most natural move and it was
to go after Bishop D6 the plan was
simply to go
Okay so
wise plan so instead of the queen C7
because the reason I'm talking about
this is because often you do comparisons
in your mind so Bishop D6 was the main
move and that white was wanting to fight
for control over E5 by playing Bishop B2
ironically enough even G5 has been
played in this position but okay let's
say black plays very naturally and then
the plan is simply to go Knight to bd2
and then
Queen C7 is a move
and then castles
was is played
and Black's main plan is to go C4 so
this we might just see a simple
transposition
and yeah
I see so C4 with running the C3 and then
Queen C2 prevents it and
okay so again there's that tension where
black has beautiful Center control and
the more trades I think that are in this
position the more it will end up
favoring white right so black wants to
keep that potential for complication I
see this idea of like Knight C5 to B3
which looks really nagging
um of course there is a knight on F6
that the bishop on F6 could take to
change the pawn structure not a move
that I'd be super Keen to make unless I
had a good follow-up but definitely
something to keep on us on our toes uh
Bishop D6 hasn't been played yet right
so it's White's move here and after
Queen C7 we're expecting either castles
or maybe a bishop B2 before castling
before
um officially reviewing the address of
the king
right so yeah it could be Queen C2 it
could be Bishop B2 uh and uh we have
Cartier tank telling us that G5 is a key
move in many of many of these positions
and uh that's very good to know because
I I must admit G5 is not something I
would instinctively play and there we
see Lei teen J opt for Bishop to D6
is very important that the Knight comes
to detail oops not like that the Knight
comes to D2 if you put the Knight on C3
it just blocks in this bishop on B2
which Jennifer has highlighted is such a
beautiful piece in us on a wonderfully
long diagonal and there we see castles
from Juan Jun so it looks like we are
heading into one of the main positions
and that's why the players are playing
really quickly
that's right well Bishop to B2 uh very
uh discouraging for your idea to play G5
right with that luscious diagonal from
A1 to Aha kind of staring back at you so
this move I like Bishop D6 and it looks
like we also have castles on the board
we we do which is interesting because
okay so I'm looking over at the computer
suggestion and you would never guess
what the computer's main suggestion is
G5
even even with our Bishop on B2 we
really I really thought I I get you to
stop playing that but apparently not so
wait wait wait what's going on so I get
the main thing that I can't take on G5
because you take a even more important
Pawn from my uh my king shelter with
Bishop takes H2 Chad
so right and then meanwhile you're
threatening G4 yourself with the same
idea
totally so okay Bishop takes but maybe
Juan June by playing Super quickly
because you saw in the other lines that
white was waiting so say for instance we
saw that white was playing Knight D2
first
and not castling so quickly so in this
position this was the main move
and then meeting C4 with Queen C2
but jiwan Jun in playing castles does
allow this G5 idea and now I'm seeing
here that this position has been reached
four times in my database and everyone
and I mean everyone
has played G5
so and it hasn't black has a good score
three points out of four last game was
in 2020 so I hope your chat is also
going all all roads point to G5 but then
I also saw a point earlier from someone
in chat that said you know do you want
to play G5 in the final game of the
Women's World Championship and some
people are praying for it saying please
please please please please please give
us some fireworks we want that last
Hazard you know but
I don't know whether I would have the
guts to play G5 and uh again
wow it feels really committal right I
think it's all about how much use
prepared it or how much he's looked at
this exact type of position before
because if so uh yeah let's go but uh
you know to kind of like conjure it and
go for it when it's due in June who's
who's surprised her
um seems like uh a risk she might not
want to take you might just want to
Castle which of course would then
eliminate the possibility of playing G5
right once you Castle G5 is off the
table so big moment here for Lei Ting
Che um any other moves besides castles
and G5 when you ask me guess what the
computer move is you know I thought you
were going to say something like King E7
that's a really CARICOM movie did you
ever play the caracon Jen only only by
accident like when I was trying to play
C5 and went out too late the night
before you know
seven is something it's something that
you could see very nicely in the caracon
in the main lines you put your king in
East salmon you move your Rook over and
he's like and then the king runs all the
way to Epic um yeah no but uh I I I like
the idea in the king E7 is bold
and there's nice to see a comment on
from chat this is like there's been like
two games where it hasn't sacrificed a
pawn and that is true that is super true
about lay you know we've seen her time
and time again she's not afraid to
sacrifice material she wants activity
and the fact that she's taken a pause
here and hasn't instinctively reached
for that King and castled suggests to me
that she knows about the idea of G5 and
she is thinking about it
what about this event certainly consider
it E5 could be another option again G5
or E5 E5 yeah let's let's have a look E5
looks good right after all
I mean five sets up there's a beautiful
Center I mean who can resist the Allure
of that one well not only that but I
mean like the same idea of G5 in that I
can uh play destabilize your knight on
F3 and take on H2 it has some of the
benefits of G5 but it doesn't
irreparably weaken your diagonals so
yeah this this move certainly like kind
of jumps out uh but it does weaken that
pawn on D5 and that square on D5 with
your king in the center so I know you
were hoping to put that b night on D2 or
that Queensland on D2 but now the move
Knight C3 does really hop out at me
because uh just hitting that pawn on D5
yeah totally and I'm thinking first of
all you have to deal with the idea of E4
so maybe you go H3 and G5 G5 at the same
time sorry E5 at the same time does
Block in these what is wrong with my
arrows today things do not move like now
it's not Ambitions do not move like that
um but anyhow so this Pawn on E5 it does
have the consequence of just jamming up
the queen and the bishop so you can make
moves like H3 and you do rule out G5 for
the rest of all days but I mean yeah
like you suggested you know once you've
dealt with a threat maybe Knight C3 and
this is the question like maybe I could
play an 83 right away and then if E4 or
Knight takes D5
oh you want to go oh okay okay yeah oh
I I forget you're super tactical
I remember playing Dan many years ago
and yeah she just demolished me it was
like oh that was aggressive and yeah so
if
E4 yeah yeah Knight takes D5 very good
that is a killer because if Pawn takes
F3 and Knight takes C7 and if Knight
takes D5 there's Queen um there is a
just that a queen takes a D5 and The
Rook on A8 is hanging see this is why
you gotta play castles or King E7
to avoid uh this type of variation where
you're just losing The Rook on A8 right
uh yeah okay so Knight T3 uh Knight T3
looks pretty good then what do you do
here
okay D4 again I see all right and and if
and if I take you taking back what the E
Pawn looks very risky with your king
honey
so what do you what are you gonna do if
I just say yes yeah you have to go see
takes
and even then
this is a complicated position I I I
mean it's complicated regardless but
this one is wild it's like where do you
put the Knight do you put the Knight on
E2 and try to kind of go to G3 and maybe
look at F5 or do you just kind of take a
step back go Knight B1 go Knight D2 and
then try and put your knight on C4
and both sides are following the policy
of restraint you know white needs to
restrain these Pawns in the Santa black
also needs to respond restrain these two
on the queen side
but it does feel for the time being
black will have the initiative
because when you control the center you
just control more squares and also you
have greater flexibility for the pieces
and I had a quote I was given a quote by
someone and I've been waiting for the
right time to say it and this might
actually be a type of position to say it
goes this is so complicated like running
through a dynamite factory with a
burning match
that is this type of position
wow again not the sedate gain that we
expected in Game 12 they are coming to
play and we love to see it I you know
it's funny I'm just trying I I'm looking
at this position this analysis position
we have up here and I'm like I wish I
could make B6 work because like if you
play if I play B6 and you play Knight B6
I have Knight B5 and that looks like
really good
um but because I'm gonna take on D6 and
then take on E5 and your King on E8 is
going to be so sad that they're not
Castle yet right
you can be a huge party pooper by in the
initial position when I played B6 simply
taking with the queen and I just don't
have any sort of follow-up
yeah keeping keeping an eye on D7 and
keeping the bishop on D6 just to stop
any Bishop A3 ideas yeah but these ideas
are very much on the board because they
would work if that night wasn't on D7 so
it's definitely an idea to have in mind
for the future
is
wild and
yeah so going back to the position this
is it this is the moment that Lei TJ is
thinking about
it's not the Quick Draw that we were
expecting this is not a stable secure
position for either side and I both
sides really do have to play really
aggressively really actively and we're
anticipating either E5 or if Latin J
knows her Theory she's played this
position a few times there is also this
really instructive G7 G5 idea
if letting J doesn't quite trust these
porn advances she can of course also
castle kingside and the game will resume
against just down those World trodden
opening moves what do you predict in G5
or writing my wife you
you get that sorry I just saw that
question I know him he's not he's not
married don't worry
ah okay okay okay
E5 I I feel like E5 because I don't like
I don't like the line when I look at the
most concrete line after black plays E5
Knight C3
um D4 and I I didn't really find
anything too exciting there for a while
it looks quite good for plaque so if I
can't play an ic3 and I just have to
develop with like Knight D2 then you
know hello Center uh why not why not
play an aggressive move that doesn't
have quite as much
um devastating risk to our position is
G5 well of course if your analyzing
position extremely extensively G5 uh
might be your selection but E5 just
looks so compelling grabbing the full
Center you can't even try to to hit me
back with much success so that's my
prediction now what if we just Castle
first uh the difference there is that
maybe after Castle I now night
C3 is playable he's stopping you or you
still want to play Knight D2 okay you're
probably gonna go Knight D2 and I guess
after C4 you got your queen c2s kind of
ideas or if you want to keep everything
flexible actually one of the advantages
I was thinking about this because you
can use this idea
and the against the blooming field I saw
this uh recommendation that was
basically of the E5 you can play E4
and that you just got to meet them in
the center and after porn tastes born
their ideas you ruined your Center my
friend and you've got ideas like Knight
C4 you've also got my ideas like Knight
G5 in the air don't want that and if you
provoke that that pawn to come forward
oops how did I get there I don't know
but I did I didn't we haven't even seen
this line
sorry I I have no idea what happened
there there I must have been a bit
trigger happy with my mouse okay so
after Pawn takes porn
no no after E4 what I don't want to say
is after D4 you concede the C4 Square
for the Knight to jump and these pawns
they're very impressive but they can't
move and slowly but surely you can kind
of see a world where A5 comes your way
and then B6 and these two pawns on the
queen side start marching up the board
so look at that is one concrete idea of
Knight D2
look at this or don't look at this as
LinkedIn Jay is actually covering her
face right now and I believe she's on
move as uh this seems to be an
expression that says I am trying to
remember what I looked at in this
position what do you think what is it or
is it just a reset like a brain reset
what is that expression or what is that
what is that
yeah I think I think that is I am
desperately trying to remember my theory
remember my plans and also not not quite
peekaboo strategy
sorry chat is too funny today I might be
clumsy with my mouse like coming up with
all sorts of positions but chat is on
point and I just uh yeah just a simple
just uh just trying to remember and just
trying to not let the tension the
pressure get to her
and I think it's a good it's a good
strategy when you're feeling nervous
because I'm sure the players are both
feeling the tension
just cover your face and kind of like
take some deep breaths and just calm
yourself down and just fill yourself
with that quiet confidence that says you
can handle these type of positions and
big moment here G5 E5 castles yeah King
E7 I mean there's so many options Jovi
and that's why the great players are so
good at sensing those critical positions
and we see that latency has been
thinking for quite a while right now
um I I think over 10 minutes on this in
this move and it makes sense because
this is it and I know the chat is very
excited about G5 they said I hope she
wins if she plays G5 I have to say
you're you're Knight D2 E4 line um Jovi
was really making me a little less
excited about E5 because the the thing
with Pawn to E5 is that if my Bishop is
then stuck behind a lot of Pawns on dark
squares uh it could be very unpleasant
position to play so if after E5 Knight
D2 there's I mean no way for me to wait
what was the line you were showing again
was it because E5
H3 yeah so if E5 has the gray uh if you
do it now it has the great point that uh
E4 is coming your way so you can't make
this very quiet move because oh E4 and
whoopsa Daisy this move the knights and
your Bishop on H2 has dropped and that
would be a tragic end for lady for Jew
manjun in the Women's World Championship
so she does have to take the time out to
go
um
let me head back after Knight bd2 me one
more one move back
to play it does have to take the time to
get H3 G3
um something and defend this H2 point
and now
and now you know after castles I guess
you have to put your knight on C3 it
doesn't make any sense to go Knight D2
because you're not ready anyhow to to
push your Pawn to E4
right right
Castle exactly so that this is now the
only time to play E5 but because if your
Castle you take the time out for
development and white does get the time
to go Knight D2
um
um hang on the castle castle and
right makes sense Knight D2 and now you
try to go E5 this probably is an
inaccuracy because it allows white to
hit back with E4
very very instructive okay so it's funny
how like normally castling is a great
move because of the flexibility but here
we're seeing that castling might
actually hurt your flexibility because
this is a very nice positional
um kind of setup for white I I mean it's
not like it's winning for white but
those lines you were showing was like
taking on A4 or D4 looked really bad I I
think I would actually on D4 E4 is just
bad
maybe we could try C4 something more
combative with the the C3 set yeah but I
I although I'm not totally sure what
happens on
okay Pawn takes D5 C3 Rook C1
um there is a knight takes D5 Maybe
yeah and I imagine that you just go
Knight to E4 yeah okay good for white
pile on the pressure on D5 so I mean but
this is definitely an idea that will be
running through both players minds and
yep castles castles Knight D2 keep the
flexibility
and maybe don't play E5 you can play
Rook fc8 you can also go C4 as well
again lots of options for black and I
would say that this position
by the way we do see we do see castles
after in almost 20 minute think
so uh oh very long and a lot of people
have been promising on chat to leave
their wives to leave
to leave everything if G5 is not played
no no no no no no never never promised
like that I remember once during the
world championship match and then we do
see Knight Beauty 2 played that Simon
promised that if
um was it napomnia found some backward
queen move that Simon would dress up as
a Teletubby and I kid you not Nepali
actually had this long thing for like 45
minutes after we could just feel Simon
go
easy gonna find this back with green
move is he gonna actually play it and
then the possibility of of Simon
appearing live on the show and a
Teletubby costume and was like oh Simon
you ready so never make any promises
not like this anyhow and uh Knight
Beauty 2 played and again we are
transposing into the Realms of the main
line and again looking on the database I
can see main move is C4 it's also
possible for black to play let me just
refresh the board and get to the
position it's also possible for black to
play Rick fc8 E5 has been played twice
and another move is Rook F to B8 but
that one I'm not so keen on because it
just feels like you're on the defensive
but lay keeping things flexible with
Rook fc8 okay so she uh does not play C4
threading to fork and said she just
plays Rook fc8
um okay all right just adding more
pressure but it's quite clear that her
intent is to Ram that c Pawn down the
board right that has got to be the idea
yeah definitely one idea yeah so what
you do here is why uh you mentioned
Queen C2 if C4 right away uh but if
Queen C2 now uh also eyeing that E4 idea
which you've had so much success with in
this analysis Joby is White's gotten a
lot of really nice positions after that
so how about Queen C2 here
yeah Queen C2 has been played twice and
interesting in love
um top move has been C4 but uh only two
games in database it's been either C4 or
E5
and it's a it's gonna get wild because
after E5 you can go like I was
indicating E4
this is the point and you don't want to
be playing D4 by the way because D4
again you can see the C4 square and
squares you gotta care about the square
and C4 is too precious to just simply
abandon so instead
no D4 don't let your pawns get placated
see for themselves threatening this idea
of C3 and now you have to take some time
out to do something about it
um things should be the effort because
you need the a work to support these two
cheerleaders there who are gonna be the
pride and joy maybe 20 moves down the
line and this position is just
still very very complicated
black is determined to force through C3
yeah yeah it is it is quite complicated
and uh very imbalanced you know I I was
expecting something so different from
today's game
um so it's really exciting to see this
so finally it looks like June June's
basically in her first think of the game
right I mean she's been playing
incredibly quickly uh but now she's
she's sinking down the thing I mean
queen C2 certainly comes to mind
I I don't see a whole lot of other
Supernatural moves Supernatural
that's what you need right now is super
an Actron but uh like what about is is
it worthwhile to make a move like H3
anticipating that E4 is going to be a
threat at some point
um wow the pawns don't move that way not
we're not playing torpedo chat maybe
let's have a look but let's have a have
a look because you know maybe
jiwanjin's position is already balancing
on that knife edge it's so sharp
remember and if she doesn't have time to
make these luxury type moves that I mean
for instance what will be the answer
after you say let's go E5
I guess you go E4
and now I'll go C4
okay so it's only then that's C3 idea
and remember in analysis earlier I was
trying taking on D5 with the idea that
if you play C3 I have Rook C1
um let's see how that works now
definitely apparently badly investigate
and and the power oh Queen A5 yeah okay
is the point because this dude is under
attack oh yeah and Knight B3 you you
probably just have Queen before I mean
you could take on it you could take on
April but Queen before it looks even
stronger because now we're continuing to
protect that C3 Pawn which is a real
goodie right
okay so this is this is the point of
roxier that you're gonna have extra
protection for that
um that pawn that is barreling away at
White's position so we whoa if we can't
play a quiet move like age three
um we can understand now why the move
Queen C2
is mandatory
okay and it's it's super you absolutely
have to play Quincy too or get the queen
out of the way in order for The Rook to
do some defensive duties on the c-line
so you know
what a position where her every move
counts every move will matter from now
on and we couldn't have asked for a
better start to the 12th and final game
in the women's world championship match
remember this is the class last
classical game and we are like 40
minutes in and this is looking like it's
gonna be Dynamite so you don't want to
go away as we return in a few minutes to
see the how these two players handle
these complications see you off to the
break chess kid is fun chess is great
for the brain but it's also fun to play
and chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlsen and vichyana
this course is
generally about examples like this
common knowledge that's used on on the
highest level
intuition comes from knowing a lot of
examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but under
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way having debated it so that's more
or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
[Music]
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
Benji the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chessboard watch
out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
honchick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian
he has never lost to another dog at
chess and certainly won't lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the place where it is all happening it
is here where the Women's World
Championship Crown will be decided
either today or tomorrow and we couldn't
have asked for a more dramatic start
June choosing a really sharp aggressive
opening and now we have the ultimate
battle on the board it's going to be
about initiative against those long-term
prospects and both players are gonna
walk that tightrope in order to navigate
the complexities of this position and
Jen I know super early in the morning
for you but this was worth waiting for
wasn't it oh it was worth waking up in
the middle of the night for no doubt in
fact my uh my six-year-old son who loves
jazz is actually on the couch right now
he's sleeping but he's gonna wake up
here and there you know so yeah oh he's
got we they got us in the big screen
downstairs so you know it's a uh it's an
all-nighter here in Philadelphia
we watched the Women's World
Championship look at this queen C2 very
accurate now Jovi if you were in this
situation playing for such a prestigious
title I think in in UK you guys say
prestigious right we say prestigious
usually but um yeah you make everything
sound cool so I I used your word
so if you were playing for such a
prestigious title what would you prefer
would you be wanting to play the white
pieces or the black pieces here
oh that's such a tough question because
this position is so complicated
um I think I would prefer to be white
because I'm a long-term girl at hearts
and I I draw comfort from the fact that
the end game is going to be super bad
for black but then on the other hand I
really am concerned because Lei Ting Jay
loves these type of positions and she is
gonna know how to fight here and I can
predict you know she's either gonna be
C4 and try to force through C3 or she's
gonna play your move E5 it really fits
in with what we've seen from her
um
you mentioned earlier you're a long-term
player you love that Advantage I just
like some of that dynamism we've been
looking at in Black's position it really
appeals to me so this is a a stylistic
battle I do like the extra 12 minutes
for June and June doesn't seem like a
knot a lot now but what it indicates to
me is more concerning
um it indicates to me that Jew in June
has prepared these types of positions
knows the plans even if she's not
um in theory for that much longer
perhaps still there's something about
looking at a lot of these positions so
that does give her a bit of an edge but
from a pure position point of view I
I'll take black and you'll take white
and well let's let's see as the game
progresses
I take
this is a big question right what does
everyone prefer
um
I
I I've kind of faced I think I played
this once and I felt that this was very
scary no I analyzed this position once
many many moons ago because I was
considering playing something like this
on the black side and yeah these two
pawns were just very very scary for me
so
it's it's really really tough but I I
tell you what doesn't fill me with
confidence though
and it's something that you mentioned
that lady Jay is thinking she's it feels
like she's seen this position perhaps
for the first time and she's having to
come up on the flight with all these
ideas but then for Jew and Jun to also
take some time out just to come up with
this very natural move Queen C2 which
had been played before which is the main
move in the position also suggests to me
that she's not entirely familiar and
she's simply reacting so
yeah I think we are going to see two
players who just wanted a game a very
sharp game and they're just freewheeling
as they go along and yeah this is gonna
be an epic battle
for sure
I gotta I gotta give a shout out to um
twitch chat because there's a great
comment here um it really made my
morning from a border hop unlimited he
says Jen reminds me of a female Willy
Wonka that has a chess Factory instead
of chocolate
laughs
have a writer strike going on right here
in United States but otherwise I mean I
would just go running with that idea
um I gotta get those those six golden
tickets
yes six golden tickets so there's only
one golden ticket oh for grabs here by
the way that was they were great books
um Roald Dahl Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory Charlie and the Great Glass
Elevator and those aliens that spelled
scram wonder whether we will have a
moment where one king will need to scram
yep absolutely excellent book and movie
and decision time for later
she has to play actively no room for
error she can't just mess around and go
age six because actually
I was just looking at H6 and uh White
might need to start breaking out in the
center with E4 and
again
if you can see the C5 C4 Square then the
Knight will drop jump into that square
and just do bad things so the time is
probably now chess is timing as they say
oh so many things aren't they I mean I
think that uh that is uh that is what
certainly one of the big life lessons of
chess the the time management and the
the kind of tension between long-term
strategy and tactics and knowing when
you have the time to chill and develop
your pieces luxuriously and when you
don't
it's a huge skill in chess that these
two women playing for the ultimate Crown
are
clearly uh Elite at but hey one of them
still has to go down
hmm
yes
also secret to jokes timing
true and it wasn't there there was a
British Grandmaster wrote a book about
like uh how chess and jokes are similar
um I can't remember who it is was it
Levitt
or maybe anyway
yeah there is some something in the air
but secret to great chess timing yeah
yeah oh and Jonathan Rosen wrote about
that quite quite a lot in his book Seven
Deadly chessions where uh he felt like a
great chess move it's also a bit like a
joke I feel like that's especially True
by the way in this tactics wishing Zoo
where you know you see this this punch
line that that is unexpected and that
your opponent didn't see it's just kind
of like you were looking at this move
and that move and suddenly they're just
like well okay but you didn't see this
one
um you didn't see that coming
yeah I I thought uh Gary has a chessable
course on it on timing and chess or I
think he means an opening
oh Bigfoot our producer says how my
opening repertoire and jokes are similar
yeah I think a lot of us feel that way
about her opening more of a drawer
yeah yes
um well okay we do see Lei teen Jay
pause this is a big moment for her she
has to probably play very aggressively
and I was waiting for this jerk to come
along you know my game's always jokes
because I was thinking about them myself
yeah
I don't do chess opening jokes because
I've seen enough of them played on the
chessboard
okay anyway and that's my that's my
contribution I actually borrowed that
one from the mayor of London sneaker
Khan
oh man don't get me started Jen
um it's early in the morning it's just
uh coming up to 10 a.m
um oh yeah it's a beautiful day
it's 3am where you are 4 A.M
the Sun is far from up the sun is not up
yeah oh we got we got some great
comments coming in from the chat and
they are slowing down here so so keep
that coming
um well
somebody mentioned uh Joby that they
want you to write another fiction book
is that in the cards
um maybe it took the thing is though
when I write it takes me a long time so
whether it's like you know being
involved in in a fiction book and that
project took about seven years and this
return writing chess books as well took
me two years and I was just like I kind
of
I cannot do that I mean I first of all I
mean yes I love doing it yes it was a
process but at the same time I just
don't have the time and I was a quite a
frustrating experience especially when
it came to writing uh chess books and
also writing the fiction because you
write something and then and or you're
involved in writing something and then
you realize that actually no it wasn't
good it doesn't work and then you have
to just scrap that one and then you have
to just go back to the drawing board
again and then if something's too long
and sometimes too short things don't
work and it's too complicated and I I
you off you often wonder like was the
whole process worth the time and
yeah and at the minute I'm pretty pretty
busy but one day one day maybe I will
feel that urge to write something again
but I'm gonna rule out writing chess
books on for time being because the last
Cara book you know it took me two and a
half years to write and I would I was
working it through to through the early
morning hours and my most most chess
writers I think they just put up their
game the analysis on an engine and they
understand but I because I was writing
my books aimed at 1800 Max I what I was
doing is I was looking at them with my
engine and then I was putting them up on
a board and seeing if I liked the
position with the black pieces and if I
liked it then I would just drag my
husband who who's his rating he's
watching I know he is Hello uh his
rating is like 2100 and he and then I
would drag him and I would force him to
play on the black side of the position
and if he didn't like it Then I then I
was the scrap that line a second it's
not good enough and then I I would uh
and that's how I wrote that's how I
wrote the book and too long
to well I'm sure sure you've written
many books you understand the
frustrations and also the relations too
oh yeah yeah I mean it's a it's really
an incredible process but it is it is
quite draining but I mean that's a great
advertisement for your book Joby because
I think that
um readers certainly appreciate the
effort you know well not always they
don't always know about it but it is
really interesting to hear the process
and you know I I never thought I would
um you know play the carocon but I do
often mouth flip when I'm playing online
Blitz and accidentally played C6 so I'm
gonna have to to check out I I think I
do have a copy of it somewhere actually
um so I'm gonna have to break that out
and start doing the uh the sacrilegious
uh Carey con overview just because that
was a really compelling description
and but I but you're also writing a book
yourself you know you've written many
good books and you're always like
looking at Innovative innovative ways to
develop the game but you mentioned uh
yesterday that you you have a new book
in the pipeline train Like A Champion
can you tell us what it's about oh it's
called play Like A Champion actually
it's a tactics it's a tactic it's a
puzzle book actually um you you've got a
couple positions and it might actually
Joey I I saw a couple by you so it's a
it's a I love chess tactics I love chess
puzzles so this one is
um really it's got some some stuff in
common with play like a girl because it
features great games by women but as a
boy mom so I'm the mom of a six-year-old
boy one thing I noticed is that too
often content about women's games is
explicitly geared towards women and I
don't think that's the way it should be
so shout out to all the uh the men and
the women in the chat I think that
whether whatever your gender is you
should also be enjoying like the great
games of women players so this one is
really geared toward everyone and the
level is a bit higher than play like a
girl so it's a little bit of a sequel
but it's also a different angle on
feminism which has been informed by
becoming a mom and seeing the way that
it's so important for our culture for
everybody to respect women you know so
this idea of women's empowerment being
just for women
um that's not it for everyone totally so
I mean totally I love that angle that it
should be very inclusive and and that's
something that I have a bug bear with as
well like sometimes women's tournaments
and women's things are just aimed at
women and it should be inclusive and I I
was watching a tournament I think there
was a woman's Grandmaster Norm event and
they had Men playing which I thought was
fabulous
yeah that is just a great idea you know
okay you have a tournament which is
predominantly women but have some men
playing as well and I am dying yeah I
mean I one of my ideas was to have like
women's event where all the top women
players are there but then have a Top
Male player there as well you know but
they're just in the minority I just want
to have like that kind of balance and we
we will see him I also whilst I'm there
whilst I'm on my soapbox you know what I
want to see I really really really want
to see I want the Olympians to merge I
don't want it to be a women's Olympiad I
wanted to be just one big Olympiad one
team and the whole point is that each
team has four men four women playing one
team and have one reserved forward and
isn't that going to be cool and of
course they can play interchangeably
like not bite interchangeably I mean
like say for instance the top women
player is stronger than the bottom
um a male play and the open Team then
have that woman player paying a higher
board I just want this whole mixture and
I think this way it will force
federations to actually field
teams of women players because often I
see this complaint too much that there
aren't enough women playing in a country
and I'm like seriously you cannot find
Four Women to play chess
I love that idea I mean it would be bad
for the United States I think because I
think it would be really good for China
and I'd definitely be great for China
right because they have so many women's
world champions and they also have a
great open Squad of course
um having one
um on the open side as well so they
would be like the heavy favorites
probably well along with maybe Ukraine
Russia but I think that it doesn't
affect the top teams by any any shop
because I mean they have a very strong
chess culture and then nurturing both
teams but there's a lot of a lot of
countries where there's a big imbalance
they're very strong open Team not so
strong women's team maybe they don't
even send a women's team because they're
like oh too difficult but this way no no
no you you invest you invest on every
single level you invest in the women you
invest in juniors I'm a big fan of not
just investing in one side you invest
everything and not just a new Elite but
you're in also invest in having a good
structure and pathway for people who
want to play chess as a hobby chat as a
sport and chess is a profession and
yeah
yeah I I think it's a great idea because
it also forces everybody to work
together well it doesn't Force but it
compels it encourages I would say uh by
the way another Deep thing for Lei
tinche he's now in the tank for 15
minutes there's been a point earlier in
this game where she was in the tank for
20 minutes uh the jacket is on
um as we see that uh well she was
wearing this uh this rust this kind of
brownish gold uh shirt and now she's got
the blue jacket on as she is hammering
down in this position what to do
um what do you think's on her mind why
has she been thinking here for so long
um what are some of the candidates uh C4
E5 what else is on Deck
yeah and well we're actually seeing that
white with her last move Queen C2 has a
very strong position idea of playing E4
so that means that actually her choices
late King James choices are actually
super limited she has to decide between
playing E5 or C4 with the idea of going
C3 and let's have a look at C4 which is
pretty committal and actually I can just
well I just saw that the bar shot up and
C4 apparently is really not the best
move because white has this idea and
hang on a second I I need to explore
this because the computer it's like
spouting this really complicated line
Bishop C3
and after E5 and you're thinking that
black is doing fine right but you can
just simply go age three
and after Knight C5 Knight C5 it gets
really complicated but white actually
achieves A5
right oh yeah that pawn is able to run
away thanks to the bishop on C3 and then
these pawns are just jammed they can't
move forward
right because I play E4 you capture the
beautiful D4 square and
um that just sound looks uh like
positional positionally absolutely
um bankrupt right position on bankruptcy
here is the Night Comes to D4 and um
there is really no attack for black so
if we can't do that and we can't do D4 I
agree
um it's very problematic okay so so
Bishop C4 so sorry C4 will be met by
Bishop C3 and blockade so that's that's
why it's big idea and then that means
that after E5
you play E4
I'm just wondering whether you have to
go E4 but then maybe we can take that
decision after C4 of course you can't go
Bishop C3 as you could in the previous
one because
D4 is coming your way like there's no
tomorrow and yeah this one you can see
it will actually be curtains for
white and C for played by Layton J
whoa C4 and you had mentioned here that
uh Bishop C3 will be strong right and
look at that there's a question mark on
the move and you're oh no and there it
is it's he played instantly she's still
in she's still in her prep or like oh oh
no
forcing
yes forcing Bishop C3 because otherwise
C3 was coming and now late in J in
strategical trouble because A5 is coming
and there we see Knight to C5
A5
A5 and look at those pawns go
and see little Queens run yeah and as
you mentioned the little Queen just
stealing the crown right Rick f2b1 A5
oh
but which one of them is going to steal
the crown the a pawn or the B Pawn
probably the B Pawn right
yeah which which I don't know yeah okay
let's have a have a look okay so let's
say you get A5 let's go you know direct
chess and what can black play like
Knight to E4
yeah let's think about this how do we
try to avoid immediate disaster this is
so unpleasant right a question about
Knight B3
um
looking to attack the pawn on A5 and
with the idea that if Knight B3 there's
Pawn B3 winning uh the bishop on C3
right put that up so how's this move
looking
so yeah this this this this would be
winning for for black so after Knight B3
you're I guess you're forced to move the
Rook
or could you play uh keep an eye on this
one I just
put it on A2 just to
please
but I am attacking it more times but you
have Rook A1 that's a problem right so
if Knight A5 or K1
yeah you are talking yeah yeah Rook A1
um
I say ah yikes yikes yikes okay so
Knight B3 doesn't work I wonder if after
Knight B3 you also oh okay my first
thought with Knight B3 I didn't see Rick
A2 I thought that maybe we had to
calculate B6 but the move B6 uh probably
fails to Knight takes A1 right now we
can play Knight takes A1 and we have
that zwishin Zug as your queen on C2 is
attacked so you don't have time to take
on C7 and win
okay
yeah yeah
so um that Rick A2 move yikes that
spoils my fun
and I guess not you're not but what else
to do so after Knight C5
I mean well after A5 after A5 what else
can we do it looks like such an
unpleasant position
what else can black do after this A5 oh
I'm struggling
um
you can't play maybe we don't like
Knight B3 okay and you tried E5 right
did you try it okay no we haven't tried
E5 let's go for E5 and let's see how far
the pawns go Advance
similar to this and you just played H3 I
think right thinking that like we've
just got everything under control but I
think I've B6 now this was so okay so
you want to start with B6 and then play
H3 okay because yeah well then maybe you
don't even need it maybe I I don't need
to play H3 and then the question is how
far will these pawns go it's like how
low will you go how far will they go
um and now I guess Rook have to be one
is what but is Rook F to be won a good
move
we have to be one that's how I I would
naturally play it
I say I say okay
blockade
I mean it looks it looks pretty hard for
black yeah I mean you know here you have
a protective passport two squares away
from queening
and Chad is saying lay has maneuvered
herself out of
similar situations but still this is if
white manages to get a B6 Pawn then
that's two squares away from queening
it's protected it's such a thorn and
black side
yeah this is uh okay it might not
immediately be winning but definitely
these pawns can't move and these ones
are just giving white all the time in
the world so
Knight C5 let's let's go back to the
game position and let's have a look
because do
is pausing I mean is she considering
Rook F to B1
she's looking at going Knight to E4
stress a factor
um well is stress a factor
I would say yes
absolutely it's the 12th and final game
I mean you don't you don't even know
what's been happening behind the scenes
I mean this is the thing with the chess
match we're just seeing two people play
chess behind the scenes that there's
probably been sleepless nights there's
been a lot of emotions when it comes to
those missed opportunities
also again the stress constantly there's
also been a change in location and
traveling does make one tired and let's
not also forget that there have been
also a lot of preparations before this
match as well probably physical training
mental preparation and a lot of time and
energy spent on memorizing the opening
so definitely it has been said that
a lot of people when they prepare for
World Championship matches they're over
prepare they absolutely do that and
they're just and they leave themselves
with no energy and and when it comes to
the end they just crack
well these players both have been
showing great nerves so far but this is
very unpleasant
for Lei ching chang on both the board
and on the clock she's down over 20
minutes due in June taking uh only a
really second think of the game but
she's got a pretty Pleasant Choice here
um just push right away with a five
or
um potentially stick that Rook on B1 to
get things rolling play H3 looks a
little bit
I'm safe that move
um
and we have a question from Lee Chan tpd
who says how do you work on resilience
and not mentally giving in during the
game and that is really pertinent
questions Jen do you have any advice
well I I got this uh question a lot
about nerves and um confidence I get it
a lot from my uh Girls Club that I teach
uh as part of my work with us chess and
um I I say one thing is that you don't
want to be nervous about being nervous
so embrace the nerves embrace the fear I
think that's a good way like you can't
always run away from your emotions but
you can learn
um to embrace them and make the most of
them because almost every emotion that
you have has a positive side to it
definitely and on that subject you know
we had um we actually had um advice
um given to us by the England team's
performance coach Benjamin Porto who you
know Benji who's a great guy and he one
of the things that he says is that often
you kind of reframe nerves as excitement
because physiologically they are the
same so if you're just instead of saying
I'm nervous you just say I'm excited and
your body can't tell and your mind can't
tell the difference and one one of the
thing that Benji also taught us is that
you can control your body by your
breathing you might not be able to
control your mind but your body you
certainly can so say for instance you do
a little weather check and we see A5
being played immediately by Juan Jun and
by a weather check you just ask yourself
how am I feeling and if you're feeling
nervous if you're feeling excited you
can actually calm yourself down by
taking longer exhalations and the body
has to behave right and if you're
feeling lethargic tiredness don't
identify with the tiredness just go oh
I'm such a tired person I'm so tired I
didn't sleep blah blah blah you're
identifying with it what you've got to
do is you're going to say there's
tiredness there and you use your breath
by having
um longer inhalations this time and you
can actually just pump up the adrenaline
in your body and that was a really neat
trick you just like most things have to
remember to do it and the only way you
can do that is uh practice and also I
just want to say one thing a lot of
having conversations with a lot of top
guys some of them are really into cold
water exposure
oh yeah I've been doing I I did that
recently it's pretty cool yeah that it's
funny how poker and chess are kind of
converging because poker players have
been into this like a mindset coaching
for quite a while and uh yeah I'm a
friend of Benji's and I think my
increaser is uh where you can find some
of his work I think that uh all of these
things are just so important I mean
psychology is so much of Chess
performance and people are starting to
recognize it and get mindset coaches to
travel with them and it's really
something to say
and what do you think about a lot of
mindset stuff that I've noticed in poker
too is for some people who aren't
naturally confident or naturally Thrive
Under Pressure it's very hard for them
to relate it's like when it's easy for
you it's just kind of like well you just
do it right but obviously it's not that
easy for everyone
no it's it's really not that easy and
often you feel like you're fighting two
battles like for instance one at the
board and one with your own mind and
it's it's time consuming and energy
draining to have those two things and
also also what I think with women
especially there's a lot of talk um
especially now about women really
feeling like their imposters and that
they have this imposter syndrome going
on and I've uh definitely listened to a
lot of podcasts to help help me deal
with this on a personal level and I can
recommend this podcast how to own the
room if anyone is just uh feeling a
little stuff less self-confident I would
say well one of the things that we do in
Our Girls Clubs is that we ban negative
soft talk so you know you can't say like
I so often uh you see you hear women or
girl players saying like well I'm not
really that good in this position but I
think that maybe this move could be okay
game of course it's like a winning move
I'm like no you cut everything that came
before the move right yeah um so just
trying trying to get away from that kind
of negativity I think is really
important now speaking of mindset one
thing that's always really compelled me
is that
um you know it's something I've written
about in chess Clans and I'm always
following the games and the careers of
the top women players is that you really
feel like Chinese women have even over
performed when it comes to World
Championship matches right so obviously
they have a fantastic team but they
really dominated World Championships
even more than they dominated the
overall rankings like they've won even
more than I think you would expect
statistically
um so what's behind that like there's
something with their mindset coaching
and matches which is really working well
for them there's actually an old book I
think it's about 15 years old or maybe
even 20 years old called the Chinese
School of Chess and it gives some
insights into it but one of the things
that I remember from it is uh the idea
that the women's chassis is really
respected by everyone and that the male
the top male players would also invest
in these
um top women and that they would analyze
together and that that was like one of
the secrets to success
you know I I think that is a fundamental
secret to success that if you start from
the top and you have a federation that
respects that is there and doesn't argue
too much about the biological
differences or whatever the rating
differences you just accept that it's
there and you're just okay we're going
to put a lot of energy into developing
nurturing this part of the game and you
know they've been able to put a lot of
resources in and one of the things I did
notice especially not so much now I
would say but before when how your fan
was was world champion was that they was
that the Chinese Federation would always
send a delegation so there was always
like friends around where they could
hang about they could just play chess
together and you could always see this
very nice social network and that I
think is really inspiring and very
helpful for people to maintain the game
and let's not forget forget that uh in
countries such as China Georgia Jess is
a viable career option because they've
made it that way so they don't have that
battle that you do in the west it's like
what's the point in playing chess if
it's not very secure not very stable and
you might not even get there and you
have nothing to show for it whereas in
some countries they're like
okay your top performer like Uzbekistan
you know when uh when um
Abdus won the world rapid Championship
he got a flat the government is like
yeah here you go have a flat and then
it's like have a car
have these like Financial bonuses and
then it becomes very very attractive and
you see this boom in Norway as well
because everyone is realizing that jazz
can be a career chess is something that
does make the headlines and it is quite
an aspirational game
oh yeah I mean it's just it really is
incredible how how chess has has boomed
and allowed for so many more
opportunities both in the the content
the popularization but of course the
play and the play is the thing here as
we've got the Women's World Championship
down to the Rye or game 12. we thought
that there might oh and this move might
be three which Jovi This was so
appealing to me because I also just
wanted to tactically solve my problems
but you showed me that after work A2 my
problems were really only increasing
here I wasn't really helping very much
because uh Rook A2 Knight A5 Rook A1 and
I'd even have to resign I think I mean
just uh losing a piece here
so a knight B3 Rook A2 what do you think
uh latinche has upper sleeve after this
what's her plan she definitely
um has seen her K2 and knows not to take
on A5 right so yeah what does she want
to do with that
but how easy is it to fight first of all
we have to establish how easy is to find
Rick A2 because we have the engine
helping us and also the evaluation bar
telling us what
what is the best move and I'm just
wondering whether you know Rick A2 to me
also makes a lot of sense because
following the Modern Day rules of Chess
you don't put your pieces on loose
squares so Rook A4 okay
yeah could they also have to go wrong
Knight takes night remember was a huge
howler you do not want to play that and
I'm pretty sure that Jew engine will not
make that move because after the capture
there's too much pressure on the c-line
and the bishop will fall off so
what why is uh in B6 we went over is it
looks compelling at first because it
protects the pawn on A5 well it you know
it interferes with one of the attackers
of the Pawn on A5 but Knight takes A1 uh
really saved today because Pawn takes C7
allows and I take C2 now I could play
Rook A1 and just sacrifice upon on I
mean sacrifice The Exchange and I mean
there's probably some Merit in that as
well but you know why sacrifice when you
could have the same position without
sacking right
so uh I think that uh I I think that the
move you mentioned though we're K4 that
actually that's a great question because
that also looks good why is 4k4 not good
Rook A4 uh same is it because well you
know what you could go back to C5 right
but then Rook A2 and that's an
improvement for that's a definite
Improvement for white right so what's
the deal was this should be good too
right
yeah this this looks like it should be
good but I mean what is what is black
gonna play
Knight C5 I I also don't like because
again we're okay too and it feels like
although we did see we did see the ideas
of going E5 right E5
is this Rick better placed on A2
I I think the work has got to be better
in A2 than A1 right I mean I think I
don't think she'll play even day back to
C5
so E5 B6 was something that we looked at
and then the queen moves to E7 and how
is this I mean there is a blockade
happening I mean obviously the point of
B6 is really really dangerous and really
really scary but uh if we just pretend
that it's not there and focus on the
center I mean
why
I mean is this so bad
gonna do
wow it does look I mean it looks like
the problem is it's just like such a
permanent
um you know rock two rocks in your
throat right that A5 and B6 uh
constellation just is it's not like I
have an immediate win to make you resign
but boy does it look very unpleasant
right
I mean unless you have some and it's
like every move I'm trying to figure out
how oh can I can I consolidate can I
play like Knight B3 can I play D4 can I
play E4 because it's like I'm panicking
here for black because I don't have a
lot of exciting moves now of course like
you can check great defender is probably
going to be calmer than the vast
majority of players here you know that's
why she's in this spot so she's not
gonna just like start shaking and like
being like Oh my God my those pawns
right
yeah uh but it is objectively
um scary and then it's also subjectively
scary
I think it's totally scary so I mean
like for instance you could see
something like this happen you know with
the idea of B7 A6 and B7 just pushed
through but when we saw that after Rick
A6 you don't want to be going Knight A6
because Knight A6 is moving away
from a good Square so we're k6 and then
you can kind of see that yes this is
ugly chess it's not pretty but on the
other hand
where's the Breakthrough
so and well where is the Breakthrough
indeed
optically
this is a great position for white but
at the minute do wanjun we can see her
sitting there at the board she has to
navigate what to do now is she gonna
stop The Rook up to A2 is she going to
move it to A4 is she perhaps going to
fall into one of those sneaky traps that
Leighton Jay has set off for her well we
are gonna take a quick break and you'll
find out after the break what exactly
has has happened and there we leave you
with the beautiful scenics of Chongqing
see you in a few minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
have a friend or family member who loves
chess give them a chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level
choose a gold platinum or Diamond
membership for one month or one year
want your gift to arrive on your
friend's birthday or on a holiday gifts
can be scheduled to arrive up to 90 days
in the future
all premium plans include an ad-free
experience unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
[Music]
I was here as I was lost oh okay well
hey
I got 14. we beat it let's go no 15
unreal no first try eight in a row nine
in a row baby let's go
let's go I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
now
come on
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
team and hopefully we can play our best
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and we are back in Chongqing and there
we see women's world champion Juan Jun
with a big decision to make of the
chessboard and it is a critical moment
it does look like Jew and June is on the
verge of securing a big Advantage but
of course there are some pitfalls that
she must not fall into and jam we left
everyone on a cliffhanger but Juan John
has not made her move just yet she just
has over one hour on the clock and still
deep in thought good decision to take
her time
well I you know I think that we were
looking at Rook A2
um we thought it was pretty easy like oh
yeah that looks like a good move but
then you know you pointed out well what
about Rook A4 and then
um you know I started thinking about it
a little more and
no it there is these ideas of black to
play Knight takes D2 and if Knight takes
D2 there's Bishop a takes H2 check
um if Queen D2 there's 94 and you do
lose that beautiful Bishop on C3 so okay
maybe I was too quick to reject this
idea of B6 and sacrificing The Exchange
I'm like okay let's go here first okay
so suppose I play
I guess I could just play Bishop takes
D2 though but that allows C3 which
interferes with my protection of that
pawn
um and I I have the in-between move B6
but things are looking so loosey-goosey
right now I mean if see if B oh B6
uh Queen C6 what do you think what's
going on here this is getting Wild
there is there is Knight D4 here hmm
yeah 90s always is coming and
it's good for right right
I mean it's so it's so complicated it's
hard to say but I'm like I
if Bishop C3 there's 94 okay so I don't
want to do that right
but even then that
yeah it's like you just don't know for
instance like for instance you could go
somehow you don't want to be going
Bishop C1 because you want that Rook
already to come to A1
but this is really really tense and but
can I just go back to the night being
sorry and see the same thing A2 can you
do the same thing like Knight takes
night is this any different like for
instance so Bishop takes you've got C3
coming and yeah that one looks like oh
could yeah now you don't want to be
going Bishop takes C3 because of Knight
to E4 and too much pressure
and maybe there's a V6 coming but still
E6 but now there's even Queen C4 which
well there's B7 though right there's B7
Yeah
well yeah Queen control
yeah Queen B7 okay and still though this
is annoying because after a queen B7 now
what okay so you don't you don't want to
do that so you don't really want to take
with the bishop which is logical or not
uh you want to take with like after
Knight D2 take with the queen maybe
two then that one which might not be the
be all an end or to be honest
let's avoid let's avoid that one because
I don't like giving up material and
maybe June doesn't like giving up
material either so let's uh let's have a
look at Queen takes then just by process
of elimination and Knight comes to E4
okay so that was something that I was
thinking and the queen just moves
I don't know where she will move to but
maybe Queen B2 just so that she can line
herself up right I like that I like
Queen Bee too
night takes and I'm thinking Queen takes
C3
but oh there's always always
intermediate moves should I be looking
at B6 or should just go Queen takes C3
probably
Queen takes C3 just
yeah it seems fine I mean queen C3 and
why is this just looks great for white
right so I don't know
yeah the queen does a great job the
Knight looks beautiful here when we get
to play I mean and wow the main dishes
of course are ponds I mean those are
dazzling unless you have something like
forcing here
I don't see it and this just looks
devastatingly beautiful position for
white
okay but something else happened I think
I I saw a move it just it doesn't look
like it was the move we expected I think
she might have played B6
but that's uh it's been given okay it's
been downgraded at first it was given a
double question mark which is a
critically bad move okay and that's not
been given a double question mark
instead just one question mark which
just means a missed opportunity it made
the position worse so okay well I I I
guess I first I first glance I was
thinking I
but then Bishop A1 and you get um two
pieces
both pawns probably because B5 might
fall too
whoa that's it though let's take a look
so 91 Bishop A1
um what do we take with on A5 do we take
with the queen or the rock the queen
queen was probably more aggressive yeah
and now if if you play Rook to be one to
hold on to your Pawn on B5 system oh
maybe I can go C3 but uh
because this reminds me of um
I had this line prepared and the Once
Upon a Time
I employed not a semislav or Queen's
camera decline I I was encouraged to
adopt a benko variation and one of the
lines that I had on the Banco was
basically giving up two pieces for The
Rook but I had the Rook
but I had like um
but in return you know white had this
like bad Bishop on F1 which wasn't
actually doing anything and I see the
same thing here that if you trade off
Queens
these nights have got no space whereas
these guys have a lot of Mobility
but maybe imagine being optimistic maybe
maybe no I I mean I like the idea but I
couldn't stop you by playing Queen C3
and thread and Checkmate it's funny that
you you're the first thing you look at
is Queen A2 and the first thing I look
at is Queen takes A1 it's like I gotta
check it right okay yeah yeah this is
Let's uh let's get flashy I like this it
doesn't roll the analysis we can yeah it
doesn't looks back it doesn't look like
the computer likes it but you got this
is the thing I I mentioned it yesterday
you don't have to play 4cmos but you
have to look at them this is something
I'm trying to instill in my son because
there also becomes a point where people
do too many 4C moves right that they are
they suddenly do every check every
capture every forcing line
um but it's not that you have to do it
you gotta look at it because I was just
thinking okay so Knight F1 and I know
I've lost a lot of material but I do
have some really strong pawns right and
strong rocks so it's worth looking at
yeah definitely and these nights are not
great pieces as you pointed out I guess
are you gonna are you rounding up the B
Pawn or are you pushing your own porn
yeah I know there's so many options am I
trying to play rookie eight and play
Rook A2 am I trying to play C3 uh but
yeah it seems like maybe it's a bit it's
a bit much this is a kind of variation
that you would play if you had nothing
else
yeah I really like it there's this kind
of idea and it reminds me of a story
where I'm Shaq mamajarov
during the Champions Chester he sacked
his Queen
and we were like oh he's blundered his
Queen and we were like this is a
terrible move this is because we were
Guided by the evaluation bar I feel like
this is terrible and and the evaluation
bar was saying yeah it was terrible and
but you know Shaq didn't know that he
was just like yeah I'll stacked this
queen look at this P look at the
activity I got it was against Duda and
after he he wins the game he turns
around to his his second and he's like
wasn't that a great game and the second
looks at him goes like no
uh oh all right well yeah this this is
definitely something where black has a
lot of compensation but let's go back to
other possible moves in this long line
because uh there's other more intuitive
ones there's your queen A2 right and I
mentioned that
so this is night takes work
and we were looking at Bishop takes A1
otherwise black captures this is forced
and then Queen takes A5 and
[Music]
so we have Queen A2 we have Rick C B8
rounding up this one and we had we
looked at Queen takes bishop and I guess
there's also C3
oh yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to
train myself checks captures threats CCT
CCT at all times and I'm hoping that one
test stage it will be automatic
so for those of you in the chat you
thought that once you were an
international Master you saw everything
but guess what
still looking at all those characters
and tags yes everybody has to do it
doesn't matter how good you get at chess
you still have to play good chess right
so no matter how good you are in your
reading and your accomplishments you
still have to come to the board and play
you still have to to make it all happen
again huh so let's let's uh see here it
seems like the engine about loves this
position for black maybe they just think
that if the pawn on B5 Falls it's it's a
a terrible position for why is that that
must be it right
right and I'm just thinking actually if
you go C3 if you just
just force that pawn and then you back
it up with Queen A2 or even your queen
A1 idea suddenly
right that is it's like if you know your
knight F F1 and even like now
it's so tempting to go Queen takes
or now Point yeah for sure but now I
mean because we need to dislodge the
queen because when you play Queen A2
before I had Queen C3 which was turning
Checkmate and you know also uh stop your
evil plans um for just a move but really
important move uh but the insertion of
C3 looks like um a big problem for June
June is it looks like the evaluation
could have flipped now this is not the
real board if we see the game position
note that after Bishop F6 Legend Jay is
still thinking are there other moves
besides Knight takes A1 what if she just
recaptures the bishop straight away
she could recapture the bishop but then
but then you're left you're left back
with the scenario where this
what a horrible moment right when
yeah this this looks bad because Knight
takes but then this might take you three
right yeah and then after Han takes B3
well what's well so let's let's see
what's going on I think the problem is
Pawn B3 there's Queen B3 Rook a five B6
is that why
this is so terrible I think so work A5
B6
yeah
oh
the variation continues huh
so we play B7 right away or do we take
on A5 first
um it should be noted that white isn't
even down any material here so it's true
yeah and we've got that gorgeous
yeah and then and then be and then I
don't know B7 is what I was thinking B7
and then yes just hold on yeah it's not
like there's amazing one there's not
even a maid it's just we've got
everything going for us safe safer King
and
um a much stronger Bond like this if we
had a less safe King we still might be
better here right because of this
beautiful Pawn on V7 but you know we get
what do they say about having uh having
compensation for the extra material okay
we have compensation for our Advanced
fun
hahaha yeah someone said that about my
position they asked they asked for an
assessment and they're like okay she's
she's got the extra pawn and the
compensation
and that's it let's move on
yeah yeah so now yeah this is this is
bad this is super bad you do not in any
Planet want this Pawn on B7 and all the
players well to White
so Knight takes Bishop sorry Knight
takes Rook played attacking the queen
um
very nice very nicely spotted
um know that time could become a factor
in this game she's got under 40 minutes
um Bishop takes A1 quickly uh replied
because uh I guess Rook takes A1 would
just lose the piece on F6 so she
obviously wanted to switch back and keep
that extra piece at least on the board
Queen A5 immediately
um played by Lei Ting Che and now we've
got this moment where White
has to show something I mean normally
when you're playing with the pieces
right you want to get some kind of
middle game
um tactics going on like you know
threaten Checkmate what about something
like Knight to G5 here is running
um mate well it doesn't even really
threaten a mate but
essentially it does right you're going
to lose yourself yeah
yeah black is threatening C3 and just to
overrun white on the king queen side it
makes loads of sense let's go on the
king side after all you want to attack
you've got extra pieces so G6 is what I
would play
um unless I can get yeah because after
F5 then
bad things happening my yeah yeah F4 E6
is hanging it feels like there's too
much yeah yeah and E6 is hanging and
then this is going it's a G6 G6 forced
or or wait
could we just try just a humor me can we
also try uh H C3 ourselves after Knight
G5 just to block your bishop and just
give up age seven
oh wow oh I can't do that wait you can
see you can see I wasn't using a
computer for them actually no no no but
I mean it definitely need to need to
look so the first move is consequences
Queen taste porn king goes to f8 and the
first move I'm thinking about is Queen
h8 check
and then I read I CNN and then you have
to move I guess you have to move yeah
if I take that's a problem yeah puzzle
Rush
um
solution there
and that's is that Checkmate yes it is
checkmate
yeah my first thought I was looking at
it
um
I wanted see I wanted to get another
piece into the game your mate was faster
but my meat brought the bishop on A1
into the game so I say it's just as good
yeah but uh but I would get that accent
puzzle wrench you got to go the fastest
okay so this just loses because of that
nice nice yeah I was just hoping that
maybe
um I would be attacking the Knight on D2
and your queen and I would have
something here but no I can't I can't
afford it but but the reason I just get
a little scared about doing six because
you've weakened this diagonal but I
guess what you're saying is that I don't
have time to get on the diagonal because
Queen B2 or C3 right
this is the question right so so so
moves are kind of like immediately come
to mind and say first of all what
happens if I try and trade off Queens I
don't know why it might be a bad
decision but we are analyzing and so we
definitely need to investigate it and
then other maybe you know like you
suggest I try to use
the dark squares and somehow others like
if only we could transplant the queen to
H6 then it would be like I know over
well that is the question we need I mean
we need to avoid the queen tray when you
said Queen trade it when I'm playing
white here I I uh I shiver at the
thought oh no don't don't take the
Queens off as you went Jane hopes to
retain her chest Queen Title Here the
Women's World Championship because
generally the Rooks are very strong in
the end game and generally the minor
pieces are way better at it attacking an
enemy King
as a general rule the queen trade here
will be really really good for black
also note the King on G8 much much
weaker King than the King on G1
especially after this good move G6
um but it's also a weakening mode so
let's say I play Bishop C3 how about if
I play this is C3 and then if you're
taking that okay and now I I have to get
my queen into the game somehow yeah
that's what I was thinking like you you
Queen
yeah Queen D1 get together over there
yeah hang on a second so Queen D1 we
come
um we're in for our party right if the
queen gets to F6 so yeah this is still
dangerous so how to how to fight this
well maybe you could have tried to
instead of just grab that pawn right
away maybe because I I don't know
obviously they're still there's still
juice in this but I'm just
looking at other possibilities because
is there a way for black to be more
insistent and try to like force a trade
of planes because I honestly think black
will have a huge Edge if she can force
her trade of Queens even if she doesn't
win B5 right away
um but I guess the problem is Queen A2
doesn't really force it you can still go
queen queen yeah
it seems to come closer because now I
can't play Queen D1
um but I could play like Queen
um
or queen B2 if I play Queen B2 I guess
your idea was to play Queen A2 right
but I'm still gonna try to get my queen
into the game it's going to be a little
bit more
uh long-winded
but by the same token you did not take
the pawn on B5 so you were playing more
long-winded too and I might if you don't
take on B5 don't forget I might play B6
myself and kind of distract some of your
Majors from
um the
the arena
um yeah okay this is very strategically
Rich Toby I mean we couldn't
have been more wrong when we predicted
that this game would be kind of not just
us I think a lot of people I saw in
YouTube chat they were like this one's
gonna be so safe and so balanced and it
might last four hours but there's
there's gonna be like a very very high
chance of draw right yeah wow well no I
I honestly thought that this game would
be finished in two hours with a very
safe draw and then tomorrow we will see
fireworks on the board but here we did
see Juan Jun she chose an aggressive
opening very committal very direct and
here I mean like you mentioned it's a
big big battle this is intense because
if white is able to transfer the queen
over to the king side Jew is gonna win
if the Queens come off then lay will be
the one who wins because she has all the
possibility just first of all to round
up the B5 pawn and then secondly just to
creep forward with her Pawns in the
middle and these guys just don't have
any stable
positions at all so anything can happen
all three results very much on the table
and see due engine thinking
she has to though first question first
thing she has to spot is that as we've
come to the conclusion C3
is a big big threat for black you gotta
stop it
whether it's by going Knight to G5 and
go and then going Bishop C3 you have to
stop this bishop being no just locked in
on the corner what if we start with
Bishop C3 by the way how does that
change matters
I mean I think it's bad because now
can we still
okay then it's just poses right because
then you can go Knight to five G6 and
and then move the queen but we haven't
even stopped and looked at this position
like what on Earth is happening here
because
I don't know because I was like okay so
if you chase us away I mean how is this
for size
yeah good good question I mean this
looks like some fun and games for sure
uh oh and don't forget wait a second did
you did you have did you have D4 in some
positions
is this maybe maybe maybe okay hang on
Sir because I was just like racing oh
this is awesome grab material like I
said Queen td1 and
why don't we have D4 winning
um there's some tactic here
uh what is it 90 is it 94.
this is the move that gives a smaller
yeah just to White okay okay but why is
this
I don't know but then let's have a look
this night apparently is not so good
because of
because of Pawn C3 maybe yeah
Knight Knight takes D6 and uh
huh this is just so complicated okay so
hang on okay so let me
not g E4
Bishop takes H2 check King takes ah okay
oops no no no no not D3 that was me
being takes on D3 ah and then Queen H5
checks in the air which is what our
which is our Dream to get that uh those
Queens off the board right yeah okay
um and you're right take care
right Queen E5 Jack okay
oh what what what lines you know what
what Thrills and spells and I think that
only at move 20 now Jovi and uh with so
many complications on the board this is
going to be a major time factor in this
game
I do I know it I know it's still a
little ways away you know we still die
and you know well over an hour total on
the clock right but I I tell you it's
looming it couldn't get really dicey
um looking at the time control I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if we really go
down to the wire on the clocks in this
game just because there is so much to
think about
yeah that is certainly a lot to think
about and priority number one as you
mentioned for geo engine stop black from
playing C3 and then following up with
Queen A2 or just getting the Queens off
that board because the C Pawn is just
too powerful it needs to be blockaded
and Jew has a choice Bishop C3 Knight to
G5 either one will do
but she has to find those two moves she
maybe she can also play B6 with the same
idea but I I prefer
I prefer Bishop C3 oh yeah B6 B6
followed by like what queen C3 or
something after B6
oh and what about yeah or what about
Queen B2 and B6 that's when we haven't
looked oh there's C3 right away the C3
so B6 so B6 first and then
um Queen B6 Queen C3 we haven't looked
at that one I was wondering yeah Queen
B6 and then Queen C3 but I'm guessing
that you just go Bishop f8 I was gonna
have Bishop f8 so you can block it with
F6 yeah and there's no and there's no
real weakness induced that's why it was
so important to induce that weakness
with Knight T5 threaten Checkmate right
such a such a critical idea and whilst
Juan Jun is thinking let's just Deep
dive into that position once more
because that is the one we have to break
down so let's go Knight to G5
threatening checkmates getting all our
pulses up and racing and okay you have
to defend G6 this as a consequence
whoops that was a weird diagonal that
weakens the long diagonal maximizes the
power of this then we have to stop C3
that is a must
C3
Queen takes porn there's just I don't
know maybe maybe other moves are
possible but so Queen to D1 with the
idea of Queen F3 we saw that D4
and now and now this is a super
important point that Knight to D E4
is the only way for white to get an
advantage because after
of the bishop takes
it's not so I guess it's not so
important to
Bishop yeah
and then here and I would just ignore
this pawn and I would just use
the queen to come to D4 and then just
start looking at these holes
now this is this one would be losing for
lateing Jay
so she can't do that she can't go Bishop
takes H2
yeah that means that she has she won't
play D4 I don't think she'll play oh I
don't think she'll play D4 it do we have
to play D4 yeah no you don't no we don't
so the move that I was looking at and I
was only fixated on one line was age six
just to kick away that night because
these are my principles right the night
on G5 is on black side of the board you
want to kick away those pieces and then
I was thinking what happens if white
doesn't Retreat the Knight and goes
for mate immediately right
let's do it Queen at three times in G5
and queen X6 and then I was I got here
and I thought
wow what happened to the king just runs
as it goes to King f8
um yeah that is a question that's
exactly the same question I had when you
had this position up earlier
um why is this so good for white how do
we
how do we do this so because Queen ahh
had King E7 that cold blood and maybe we
just go back to F6 and you can't go to
D7 because the queen has seven but I
think you can get him right you do so
triangulation right so you can get King
to seven yeah and now we're down in
exchange we're down in exchange and I
don't think we have got a whole lot to
show for it anymore okay so what was the
better way to deal with this variation
so it might be that Queen F3 is is not
correct it's just too uh too ambitious
so instead of Queen F3 Maybe
let's go back to
H6 it might be that you just I just you
know white has to be a bit more careful
a bit more tempered here and go night so
H6 was the move maybe Knight F7 instead
maybe just take on our seven
go
wow what a move didn't even didn't even
enter my radar just in case the king
king takes well then Queen pudding is in
the eating queen of three and then I
don't know where I'm going my pieces
King Tea I don't I don't want to head to
G8 because I feel like
I'm gonna get obliviated that on the
king side so I'm gonna go King E8 at
least now the question you have to be a
Defender yeah that's true and then so
basically this is similar to your old
line except now we took your critical
Pawn on S7 which kind of held the rest
of the position together so even though
we're down in exchange we're actually
getting some some of the the little guys
uh and boy are they important because
once one goes they all go yeah so this
is I was wondering
is there a checkmates of the queen 37
like for instance if you check yeah
Bishop fate yeah because if you go King
to E7 well then there's a maze there's a
bishop comes in
Queen G8 and you still have that Bishop
f8 that that move stopping it from being
totally me and if it's not me we end up
losing because if you're a beautiful
Pawn on C4 so there's a lot at stake
here it's not like oh we don't mates we
can pick a Perpetual it's like no
you're done yeah it's busted right so
okay so goodness me so we're without
Okay so
we're down a lot by the way we are you
can see the live board I'm here on the
right of the screen and right now we we
suspect you and June is thinking about
all of our different options here
obviously 95 threatening
um well not quite mate but threatening
um devastating uh distraction to the
black king we're thinking maybe bishop
C3 and of course other types of moves
that one might look at like Rook to be
one
um with the idea of playing B6 holding
on to your Pawn on B5 uh but uh this is
a long line that arose out of the 95
idea uh as we are finding ourselves in a
very strategic Battle Battle of ideas as
Jew and June is going to be hunting down
Leighton Chase King and lake is going to
be hunting down making another queen
with that c Pawn I mean wow how the
tables have turned Jovi
uh-huh yeah and and uh yeah and I can
see that uh I'll produce a Bic was
sending through the lines I didn't
didn't actually read that I was just
like looking at your nights I was going
well goodness me what a wild position
um but I think Jew engine has to do this
and we've highlighted time and time
again like the route coming to B1 might
be a natural move defending the B5 Pawn
but actually the most important thing is
to stop black from playing this C3 move
which just completely just kills the
position because it ruins the
scope of this bishop on A1 C3 is such a
big threat and
yeah and
my goodness me if this game ends in a
draw then fair play to the players I
mean what can we say I mean it's been
actually I would prefer I'll be honest
with you that this this game ends in a
draw because then we'll have more fun
and action tomorrow and it feels kind of
appropriate that they've played such
aggressive chess very tense it's been
full of Thrills and spells and yep I
want to prolong the match but if someone
wins it it does feel a bit heartbreaking
right for the other one because once
again there's been twists and turns
because in this opening it looked like
late TJ maybe had a good opportunity
just to push forward with her initiative
she played incorrectly and then Jew and
Jun had the upper hand with the
possibility of getting B6 but she
mishandled the position and now we find
ourselves in this really tense game
where it's all gonna depend on whether
Drew and Jun can whip up an attack as
compensation against these chain of
Pawns there's four in a row not uh just
three
and she can only do that by whipping up
a counter play against this King that is
all alone if you can do this
then she probably is going to be worse
okay and we see Queen C3 played and this
was something I was instinctively going
for but I know you did not like it at
all and I also noticed that the computer
hated it and it was just simply to do
with the fact that when you judge this
type of position you've got to look at
how mobile the pieces are especially the
Rooks and the Rooks already primed for
the action this Pawn on B5 is just going
to get corralled
and all the Dual engine does have the
worth of a draw
well it is a 20 minute thing and you
know yeah of course I was just hoping to
drum up some Checkmate because you know
the thing about these nights is that
they're nice or notoriously bad at
protecting against Advanced pawns right
but they're notoriously good
um at checkmating and participating
injectivating attacks so just from like
a logical point of view it was like oh I
want to keep the Queens on the board but
I do think this is a concrete thing for
Drew and June I think she probably
looked at a lot of those lines that we
looked at wasn't sure she had enough and
believe she can hold this
I them I because I mean obviously she's
fought for 20 minutes so she was clearly
examining those permutations and if she
thinks she can pull this don't forget
she gets to play that rapid play off so
uh true what it what is the evaluation
is this and remember the end games that
would result if she kind of hung on and
like wiggle back her Queen would have
been even worse because then she would
end up giving up more ground so I think
her idea is if I'm gonna do an end game
I'm gonna do it this way
um of course it would have been really
fun to see that crazy middle game versus
um you know past Pawn action but you
know that wasn't in in the cars and this
decision does make logical sense if she
didn't think that was going to work out
in her favor
um do it now not after uh late and Chase
already taking your beep on and she's
already moved her teeth on for her then
it's gonna be too late you're just gonna
be dead in the end game here is she dead
no by all means she's not dead I mean my
big question is what about Rook A3
um can we like
like
bolster no sorry and I'm trying to boot
that Bishop on um C3 out because if we
can it's gonna be really bad but I think
Juan June must believe that you can just
hold tight with move like Works C1
yeah Rick C1 is is one idea
that said certainly you can hold tight
the question though is how are you going
to Define this B Pawn because that's
going to get rounded up rook B8
and I guess you can you hold on to it
well can you play Nate D4 and then if E5
at least we get to win the e-pawn or
play Knight F5 we get to really
complicated issue here
you think uh this must be the type of
variation she was looking at
Casa E5 A5 Knight C6 and and this one
feels like white is
five might have been even stronger
because then um wow if you play Bishop
C7 we have 97 check and we just get that
juicy d-pawn I think yeah
yeah things are kind of falling apart on
you
that's true that's very true so yeah
Knight F5 classy move attacking the
bishop and also destabilizing the
defense of the E5 Pawn yep that's a
killer move so no E5 so that means that
you have to keep everything
but at the same time you've got moves
like is
no Bishop E5 you might fall down to
Knight C6 so I want to play Bishop C5
I want that pawn I I'm so greedy you get
a one track mind here don't you
um well maybe you can do the same thing
right night night just hold on night all
right just hold tight because now you
don't have E5 right
um and I am
my background is currently weak but it
doesn't seem like you can take advantage
of it at this exact moment if you play
Rook a a do know the the sneaky little
threat would be Rook take C3 right so if
white were to do something like I don't
know can you make a bad move Knight C6
I'm not sure
you watch that engine Bar Fall to the
floor it's Rick take C3 would end up
picking up a piece and this is one that
it doesn't matter how old how long
you've been playing she has I know
you've fallen for this at some point
right
there's no shame in it it happens
it happens it certainly does and uh
there's no Escape Square for the king to
run to on the second row so this is the
back ranked mate or as kids call it the
bank rank mate
and yeah so
okay so Queen C3 Queen TC3 Bishop takes
you oh well and I just noticed but I was
flicking through that Queen takes you
through because it was played so quickly
by Lady Jay was awarded a a question
mark but wait but wait wait what but how
I mean I guess it's just saying go
bishop f8 or F6
don't play Bishop B4 don't play Bishop
B4 because then you get made in one move
on G7 right the bishop and the queen
they're lined up it's got a battery for
a reason and uh Queen takes D7 would be
a big uh-oh moment
that's crazy okay show me again Joby why
is Queen C3 question mark because of
Bishop f8 or because of F6
um okay so I was thinking Bishop buffet
or F6 so let's go Bishop of Fate do you
want to keep the pawn structure kind of
relatively solid and why is this so bad
I mean can you not do the same kind of
things with
Knight to D4
yeah I don't get it I I I I feel I feel
like this one is uh hang on a second
this is Bishop will come to B4 ah okay
so again back to D4
um what if you just play like a regular
move like H3 or something
um yeah just because yeah okay
and now why would this be something no
no no it wants to actually switch back I
I think it wants to switch back to like
taking on B5 or something maybe yeah
yeah but that's very I think it's very
human to want to just go for the end
game because you know there is this
principle that um with the the Rooks you
should have a really nice position
whereas uh it's true black has no
weaknesses unlike the other variation
where you know you played Knight T5 and
it induced G6 there is no weaknesses
here so even though we have the queen I
can understand why the computer thinks
that like black can just take on B5 and
Cold Blood
but uh I also very understandable why um
late just traded right away
yeah I thought
I thought a very understandable decision
but the speed at which she did it was
maybe questionable and well going back
we see that after the queen takes Queen
Bishop takes Queen
Rick's cb8 so late engine not hiding her
intention she wants the B5 pawn and now
200 has to defend it you have to go
Knight to D4 I guess or or a rugby one
right a rugby one but you want to choose
if Rook people there's okay three now
because I was using my I was using my
work to play Rook C1 and now I'm afraid
that Rook C3 maybe Rook A3 destabilizes
me in that key point
yeah
and if the bishop moves let's say
okay so let's say I'm I'm really
provocative I'm gonna go like this and
you see the animation book go all the
way down I'm guessing it's because C3
yeah probably gonna be a big killer
right C3
and uh okay and where did you go the
light has to move
so she's actually gone for the simple
approach which is just to defend that uh
I like that better night way way better
and we saw that E5 was actually being a
mistake from late teen J if she played
it because of this Knight to F5 idea and
you just cannot hold on to the defense
of E5
I like this way better because yeah
I like this way better because uh now we
can keep the Rook on F1 for C1 I mean
obviously we're not thrilled about our
work being relegated our strongest piece
in this position to be relegated to
defense but the key thing is like
letting that pawn on C4 go has such a
deleterious effect on our position
because it's like it's not just the pawn
going forward it also attacks on it on
D2 it boots our Bishop away and it
allows your Bishop on D6 sometimes to
get more play so it's just like it's
really holding our position together
that we have this bishop on C Rock Lake
blockading so even at the risk of
relegating our most powerful piece left
we are gonna do it you know sometimes
you have to do things you don't want to
do for the sake of the greater good of
the position and I think that's the case
here with the The Rock
um poised for C1
yeah we've seen it we've seen it so many
variations where if this bishop is
removed from the board then C3 C2 is
just going to be too powerful so I
completely agree with you ugly chess is
sometimes necessary and yeah we do have
a big moment here for late teen Jay how
is she gonna destabilize this night is
she going to be playing Bishop C5
just again to ask do you want how are
you going to defend the B5 Pawn
or is she gonna make moves like G6 to
take away the F5 Square from the Knight
big decisions to be made and so say she
goes very forceful so she goes G6 and
now this G6 move I wouldn't necessarily
recommend I would be in fact very
hesitant about playing such a move
myself because you can really see the
position going wrong for white for black
sorry if you manage to get that Knight
to F6 or maybe even a bishop to F6 and
somehow other
white has that extra piece to coordinate
and attack with and
yeah I agree black and white do what
Bill black has a concrete idea of
playing
true but at the moment
um E5 we still would have 96 well what
about E4
um because you mentioned now you've made
a weakness maybe I can I can try to get
my own thing going and if you play E5
I've got Knight C6 I mean the position
is it might be an end game but that
doesn't mean the position can't blow up
right
yeah you're right I mean if the Knight
jumps into E4 then this is going to be
just horrible on the dark squares for
black now I'm gonna use my power of take
back and oh
don't quit yet what about E5 and 96 and
sacrifice in exchange with D4
I gotta check that out I mean that could
be kind of fun right
apparently not fun considering the
computer doesn't like my move maybe
because of Knight takes C4 though but
you see what my idea was that yeah uh
yeah it looks like this this could be
the the killer
um but yeah I I was just trying to get
some action going with the Pawns
oh wow what what a game Jovi as we see
late in K puzzle over what to do does
she want to play for Bishop C5 did you
want to play for Rook 83 but I'll tell
you one thing
um the chances of a draw I feel like are
a lot higher now than they were uh you
know 10 minutes ago before the queen
tray we were looking at those wild
variations with Knight G5
so that's good though in a way because
we're more likely to see a playoff which
will be really exciting and I almost
feel like to me it almost feels more
fair because the I know a lot of people
think that classical chess is more fair
because uh you know there's more time
not to make a mistake I feel like in
this match because it's been so tightly
contested because both women came with
such great form and are playing so
awesome the idea that you have to win in
a Four game match to win the the title
rather than just in one game is kind of
appealing to me so you know
and it's still quite exciting I mean
anything can still happen but you can
kind of Imagine certain fortresses where
it's hard for either side to make
progress right especially with like
white already kind of setting up a
position like that where
you see everything like for instance
each other
like you could see like Rook A3 Rook C1
and maybe bishop C5 attacking this
Knight you see Knight coming to
F3 and then here you can kind of see
that maybe there's like no room for
improvement maybe is E4 an idea I don't
know I'm just thinking H6 and yeah you
don't want to be going E4 because Pawn
takes Pawn is now possible and what is
inside your H3 and then what like both
sides have got the optimal setup
um it's difficult so say for instance
you try to go Rook A8 but there's still
no threat there's no way for the Ricks
to come to A1 and make that trade
and there's no target remember these
nights are just so effective at
controlling all the squares there's just
simply no way through so you can kind of
almost see like this type of position
that the black Rook would be like going
Rook B7 Rook B8 and white would be
waiting and we've seen you and didn't do
this right she's gone she's not afraid
of just going making moves like kingish
to King G1 and just
asking the question what to do I mean
maybe white does have a brand new
Improvement if you just go Rook B7 maybe
in your key F1
and say black just like yeah I'm gonna
wait
true I Gotta Wait again and then but
where where else oh maybe
It's All Seasons maybe yeah and then
drive it back
and come back up again
I see what you mean about this potential
for Fortress I mean if I were black I'd
be
if you're looking for any kind of active
play for black although I see people in
the chat or saying they actually like
White's position I would think about if
I were to get my king to E7 could I
arrange some kind of F6 E5 idea okay
let's try that so so this was just like
waiting so black waiting and white
trying for something but even so that
white wasn't wasn't necessarily possible
for white to actively improve the
position that much but let's have a look
at whether black can do it so Knight to
D4 Rook A3 Rick C1 Bishop C5 Knight here
and now let's move the king to f8
um oh what
she's playing D5 you thought it was a
bad move
it is a bad move 95.
it is about the roof okay isn't it
it looks like a bad move I mean what do
you do after Knight to F5 well the
computer hates it maybe she's thinking
Knight F5 Bishop goes to C5 and then
after Bishop E5 Rook B5
maybe she's because of course Bishop C7
is terrible right because that 97 second
Knight takes D5 maybe she's just
thinking Bishop C5 here Bishop B5 Rook
B5 but then you lose F G7 no no you'd
use G7 so you have to hold on to you
have to hold on to fa um
leaving the bishop f8
so Bishop buffet and then Bishop E5 work
B5 how's that look
or is there another move here can you
wow no I doubt it because you don't want
us to play F6 right you gotta take seize
your moment right Bishop takes C5
and talking about seeds in the moment
I'm gonna leave everyone hanging because
we are gonna take a very short break and
we do see Juan Jun play Knight F5 oh my
goodness this is huge and you don't want
to go away because we'll see you in a
few minutes
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resides
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Gasser
would say it as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajaba
here white plays the move B5 5x Glam
which highlights again it's not how many
pawns you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the past
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a pass
Pawn being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
rooms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
Grand Masters can lose 10 pounds and
burn 6 000 calories just by sitting yeah
so I've actually been spending a lot of
time getting in shape wow that's great
what are you doing mostly like Rook
lifts oh I've never heard of that it's a
thing don't look it up
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
come on
[Music]
foreign
and we come back to fully fledged
excitement on the board there we see you
when June her posture has changed she
knows that there's upper hand has been
passed to her because we just left you
with a big Cliffhanger Layton Jay she's
an active player she likes to play Fast
she'd also likes to play clinical moves
she just said no there was no defending
for her whatsoever she broke out with E5
but according to the evaluation bar and
also according to the engine and
according to everyone E5 is an
inaccurate move because it allows white
to win the E5 pawn and just get greater
flexibility for the position so after
Knight F5 as played by Juan Jun Latin
Jay was forced to defend the G7 pawn and
here we are and it is now Juan Jin's
move she's thinking before or she can
take this uh Pawn she can of course play
it but as Jennifer during the break you
also mentioned that it is possible for
Jun to play another move perhaps this
move F4
right F4 and uh yeah you can see the
evaluation things sign
I'm under caffeinated here in the middle
of the night in Philadelphia but okay my
idea is simple
um I'm hoping to actually finally get
that work onto the game
um on F1 and for instance if you take on
F4
um and I play like let's just do a
fantasy variation politics F4 Rook takes
F4 Rook B5
um just humor me here
um now uh I do have this idea of Knight
H6 Jack
and if you play Pawn takes H6 Rook G4
check although I mean even there I guess
the story is not completely over because
uh well it's not me
no because the king can run to yeah but
still
this does look dangerous for black after
Rook tease H7 and rook h8 in the air I
can see the attraction in that and I can
see why do you wanjun has taken a pause
whether she whether she should capture
the pawn or she should introduce the
Rook into the game and yeah it is true
that Lei Ting Jay just played E5 in
order to win the B5 Pawn but there were
consequences to that and let's have a
look at Juan jun's most natural move
which is simply to capture the pawn in
the middle of the board I think I would
play this without even thinking but
that perhaps would not be the best
strategy it's always good to take a
pause and consider all your options and
now this is the position and one of the
things you do immediately notice is that
wise pieces have a lot more freedom than
before so for instance the bishop can
come to C3 The Rook can come to C1 and
the Knights can just maneuver around
they now now have very comfortable posts
so
um what move kind of appeals to you it's
white to play
C3 is not a threat
at the minute so you do have a spare
move
well C3 is not a threat but what about
like block heating that swear and
stopping me from blockading it like uh
something like I'm I'm worried that if I
well what like suppose I tried to play
F4 and get my Rook into the game in this
crude way like I was doing before
um and now you play Rook to A3 or
something like that right just looking
to play C3 yourself eyeing the uh now
weekend E3 Pawn some kind of printable
battle like this is is interesting and
yeah you Rooks you wanna
a move that we've been looking at in the
course of this end game sacrificing the
activity of that Rook for the greater
good of the position to stop you from
unleashing everything with C3
uh but again like this does look like
um black is
exerting at least enough pressure to
avoid complete disaster
right now what if I tried Rook F3
instead Jovi can we can we check that
one again
sure so instead of perks C1
okay so Rook F3
yeah I know you Brave you Brave okay I'm
gonna see three so now C3 and again the
problem is that Knight H6 check Pawn
takes H6 Rook G7 Bishop G7 showing me
that it's not a checkmate
and uh unfortunately I'm going to be
left with many problems with the dust
settles if Bishop takes G7
um the pawn takes D2 and I I can I can
get all these wait
then I'd have a draw though right
so yeah then you can take on H6 right
yeah I'd have a draw you don't want to
get here so how would you stop and draw
here when you play Rook uh B6 or
something or F6 uh F6 okay and then
after King takes Pawn you go here and
you still have the same problems of uh
the pawn on C3 running through
so no still still the same things apply
but
I guess what is the big problem for
relating J in this position is if we get
to go back to Bishop takes E5 I will put
it up there on the board and after root
takes B5 it's just you know it's true so
say you were to sit with the bishop on
C3 The Rook to C1 and then do you
remember that plan of improvement that I
was talking about with bringing the king
into E2
I mean there really is nothing that
black can pin their hopes on I mean
these this Knight is not tied down on F5
it's just Rogue who's before in the if
we were to do a direct comparison to the
other line where we saw like this here
this Knight on D4 is completely saddled
to the protection of the B5
porn and when we compare it to the game
where we're going to see it in action
this Knight is just running free and it
can of course allow the king also to
approach the position also once The Rook
is relieved of its duties of protecting
the bishop everything can pounce on this
Pawn on D5 and that's what I'm afraid of
yeah absolutely that makes a lot of
sense and by the way what do we see here
we see Bishop E5 Rook B5 G4
okay a G4 played okay oh
what a move
well I think maybe maybe there is a
tactical uh question of D4 followed by
F6 so she wanted to bolster that night
if you if let's show what I mean there
yeah like let's say that say you played
H3 so hang on let's just say yeah you
wanted to you weren't paying attention
and H3 was the move and then this is a
nice idea as you pointed out and
so if you play e-takes you go F6 yeah I
feel like there might be some tactical
way to avoid total disaster just it
feels like justice
um like Knight D6 or something maybe uh
does that avoid total disaster or do you
have Rook D5
pelvic T5 but um maybe you can just go
like this and say yeah it was yeah it
was disaster but I do get some forms in
return for the exchange but uh G4 I I
also really like the move G4
also you're you're threatening to go age
four age five in the long run and try to
weaken the dark squares and the white
King has that plan of improvement every
piece now has a plan of improvement
before great move G4 it's a very typical
uh Grandmaster move in the end game
uh to just get that space you mentioned
due to polkar's move a lot of times for
Judith it was in the middle game to uh
to slash and burn your opponent's king
but no even in the end game this move
has a lot of value and you'll see people
sometimes playing H5 to avoid it right
because it gives Wyatt this beautiful
space
yeah
certainly does and wow do you know to do
what even with what we thought were some
blunders played
these two players still have some
ridiculously high accuracy scores so
June
95.8 percent accurate and late injury is
94.5 percent
wow wow yeah it's another great game I
mean and yesterday was even more
accurate but keep in mind that the
opening was more unusual so the more
unusual the opening
um the accuracy score is bound to go
down right because the positions are
very unusual
um maybe the book is a little bit ends a
little bit sooner than other openings so
it doesn't make sense to me that even
though it's been a great game not quite
as accurate as yesterday
um and uh I did I always think that when
you play very sharp positions the
accuracy levels goes down because
there's just so many things to calculate
so many possibilities to go wrong
whereas when you have a simple
strategical game
well then I think there's the just the
moves a little bit more clear-cut okay
once you know everyone is talking about
this like centiporn loss I mean the
lower the centiporn loss the kind of the
more accurate you are and I remember
once I played a game I beat a
Grandmaster and then I my friend checked
the Scentsy porn loss and I was like oh
what is it is it like 25 30s which is
still quite quite a good thing and he
goes no you got eight and I was like
what
it is like means I was ridiculously
accurate wow I I was just like okay but
then like I started thinking about the
type of position I had it was
strategical and it was just all about
improving moves so there wasn't that
much margin for me to go wrong we were
in the opening that we saw you know with
hang on let me just go back pull it back
up to like
like moments like this I mean here
anything can happen this position is
wild you know you have the big battle
between these two past pawns and then of
course
this Phalanx of Pawns you know is coming
in the center so anything can happen and
it did
so I can't blame the players for not
being as precise as we saw yesterday
what a beautiful position for Ryan
though it does seem like why it's gonna
pose some problems for black uh our
producer was pointing out that if the
bishop on f8 was a raw and if black
played G6 the Knight 86 would be
checkbook so
you gotta always always fantasize about
those checkmates right exactly and uh
yeah and that mate actually does have a
name so it would be Checkmate on H6 and
it would be Checkmate on Esa E7 and
that's kind of Suffocation mate I think
it's just a night it's smothered mate
when it's a bishop and Knight
suffocation
okay wow important distinction there
this mother may being the one where it's
just the Knight on S7 with the rock so
here he's got a partner
um with the the 25 okay but G6 was
played by the way so so good good I
think although thankfully that Bishop on
f8 is not a rock
so why it will will be able to uh
well black will will be able to
potentially even try to trade off the
dark squared Bishops like for instance
the Knight now doesn't want to go to D6
or D4 or G3 where does the night with a
retreat to
but it does allow rugby to gaining a
temple of Our Own
right let's let's have a deep dive into
this position because you you kind of
hit the nail on the head because if you
are not clever with your retreat then
Bishop G7 is coming your way and we've
seen it time and time again right so you
go Knight G3 Bishop G7 done this Pawn on
C4 it's gonna be a nuisance it's gonna
go drive down to C2 and I would say
maybe black has really good practical
chances of winning obviously I think
White's position is defensible but at
this point it's just so annoying a lot
of danger there for white
um so if you gain some time by attacking
The Rook where are you gonna put the
wreck that's the question number one
well how about rugby two Ruby two
uh you are on the same line as this I
know I know immediately immediately I'm
like thinking what can I do what can I
do your Tactical antenna has gone up for
sure
but I had it I don't see anything
as of yet
I really want to attack this is the
point that I really want to do I need to
somehow other I need to blockade the C3
square that is like the key setup and
then from the C3 Square I can hit D5 so
so
good point good point so you're trying
to figure out a way to
to get that Knight to C3 well what about
nape you want
is there Rick A1
yeah there could be okay one and then
there's like Knights comes to C3 anyway
yeah it does doesn't really matter all
right your idea still to stand strong
I remember actually reading I think I
think it was an adult rescue book that
they said that the the great late
trainer
um Mark doveretsky wrote
um a series of wonderful books but this
idea that when you have that black Pawn
on C4 it's all about getting a white
knight on C3
give up everything
and you did you gave up a lot but you
got what you wanted and your position's
great now I mean this is
I don't know whether it's that wonderful
because I do feel that this blockade
could be broken down but I mean the
pressing thing is that this Knight on C3
is both an attacker and Defender right
and it's it's targeting D5 and at the
same time stopping this pesky Pawn
and yeah so I said G6 Knight to D4 so
maybe you don't go
maybe you don't go Rigby too because
that will drive the Knight
to where it wants to go maybe you put it
somewhere else but where I honestly
can't tell you where like rugby seven
huh yeah
um so you're saying no Rook B2 because
our Rook is going to be exposed there
later and just like drop or look back to
B7 or B6 let's just put it
maybe B6 so that we can play F6 at some
point but oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's a better one so
that's uh
1994 work to B6 and she's done it yeah
she has that Knight to D4 so we're gonna
see uh where like decides to drop that
rock there's so many options I mean B7
B2 B2 being one of the most logical ones
because it attacks the night but also
illogical and she's played quickly she
did do Rook B2 so this move is both
logical and illogical at the same time
right
and the big question here oh it's been
given a question mark they do say that
mistakes don't come alone they usually
come in pairs and there you can see the
explanation of what is a mistake made
the position worse
why did it make the position worse
your wife is so bad
because okay I thought about Knight B1
to go Knight C3 blockade the pawned on
C4 because that pawn was just super
annoying I mean what else can you do I
guess you could also Retreat a knight
and go back to F3
and still blockade the pawn
ah could you could you be doing
stuff like that and then just going if
four let me just count so
people and they're just chats are saying
maybe three but if Knight B3 we can just
take it right and then we're we win two
nights three like this yeah we just take
it right
just take it with a rock uh well
wouldn't we take it with the root yeah
take a look yeah can we just get to we
just get uh two pieces for this is just
this is just great now we're on top I
mean I guess it'll probably be a draw
right but we it this is a huge relief
for uh yeah for black a huge relief so
you can't you you can't play Knight B3
to try to trap the The Rook that would
not be enough I I loved your idea of 91
to C3 honestly I think that was great
yeah so um is there is there something
better though is there another night
Retreat that is even better like with
um
what does she do did she do your move I
think she did she'll be good call I see
that night it might be one nice
beautiful well spotted
nice E3 no I love backward Night Moves
it's quite funny because back when light
moves I feel like a my specialty they
don't slip me apart slip Me by but I
tell you backward Bishop moves I'm back
with Queen moves I don't see at all
this is a beautiful strategic idea
though good job good job
exactly this is like so many holes and
do you feel that if you're able to get
Knight C3 and even if you trade off dark
Square Bishops you can put a knight on
B5 you can put the Rook on D1
utilize the king and wise pieces have so
much Harmony and it's so simple just
Target the D5 Pawn okay maybe
objectively it's a draw
but still it will be due engine that is
pressing and they are on move 27
and in terms of clock times I think both
sides have plenty of time left and
especially for Jew engine because her
position has now simplified she has a
very clear-cut plan it's for Layton Jay
it's a lot harder I'm afraid she will
have to think whether she her best
chances lie in counter-attack or in just
holding the D5 pawn and she also has big
questions to answer should she trade off
Rex should she not
hmm those are the things that gonna burn
time on the clock
yeah so how about you please I thought
you anticipates that you're gonna put
that Bishop you're gonna put that Knight
on T3 so she plays like Rook A5
um trying to add support to the D5 Bond
how's Ella mm-hmm
oh yeah I think there's Knight C6 oh oh
oh oh sorry yeah yeah okay I can't do
that yeah but that's the kind of that's
the kind of danger there is when you're
facing these uh three minor excuses a
nice and crafty
yeah yeah yeah we gotta we gotta do
something now that we're not threatening
I take we're fixed you too and that is a
problem right the thing about Rook B2 is
that it was a a moment of pleasure to
attack your life but now we have to deal
with the fact that there was a huge
negative with that move that there was a
discovery and then I8 on D4 uh
discovering an attack on The Rook on B2
big problem
so what to do
what to do now should we just move that
work away
but we should just move that Rook away
but where Rook B6 you mentioned it
earlier it's a very stressful position
very stressful position for black
totally stressful I mean I I I don't
know I mean I'm also thinking about
Bishop G7 but is that a good trade
it might not be a good trade because it
simply allows so say for instance here
just take take and then Knight C3 and
then you can just see after Rook A5 your
move
that you know they can just probably go
Rook to D1
and this Knight on C3 is just
Untouchable and again you have that
horrible plan that's coming your way of
going to King
F3 pushing the pawn slowly slowly
improving the position
and even 92 Knight to F4
um
wow Bishop G7 not a good trade what a
Master Class by June June so far though
Jovi I mean like if you just look at
these last two moves G4
and well I guess they're not technically
the last two moves because you also
threw in uh Nike for it but if you look
at the moves G4 and Knight B1 it's
really marvelous to see how June has
handled this two very instructive moves
right this I know a lot of people
watching this are probably trying to
improve their tactics they're trying to
improve their openings but what do these
moves G4 and Knight V1 have to do with
openings or with tactics nothing really
and so this is the type of takeaways you
should be trying to get when you watch
commentary because it's not something
that you can easily get other places G
for beautiful space gaming multi-purpose
as Jovi said and the the absolute
stunning night we want to say guess what
we've been dealing with this idea of C3
all game and suddenly returning the
tables and we're making it a strength we
get to put the best blockader on the C3
square and make your Pawn on D5 cry so
this has been like really the strength
of Lei Ching chae's position for so long
that black Pawn on C4 now June turning
the tables oh it's miserable position to
defend it'll be fantastic if late does
it but she's got a defensive task on her
hands and only 18 minutes to go until
the time control can she do it Joby what
do you think
this is a really big uh ask actually
because I I do feel that there will be a
time scramble but I don't think it will
be from Jun because her position is so
simple to play she has one target the
pawn on D5 and that's it whereas Lei
Ting Jay has to constantly think does
she go on the defensive does what pieces
does she trade is the move Rook to be
six is a move that you highlighted with
the idea of F6 and then does does she
Swap this bishop for the night I mean
these are the questions that she has to
answer and if she takes an incorrect
Choice well she's just gonna lose
there's no kind of beating around the
bush here because once the D5 Pawn Falls
maybe the C4 Pawn is also a Target that
can be corralled and then before you
know it it's gonna be a rook versus a
bishop at night and white will have four
pawns and this beautiful structure and
black will only have three and that is
insufficient
yeah I mean I'm really I'm really
strapped in for this and I you can see
the stress on Layton Chase face
I mean she's made a lot of Expressions
she's really you know gained so many new
fans with her chess and her a kind of
like ability to to show her emotions at
the board which is always really fun for
the fans right
um but right now I just see pure stress
Jody what do you see
stress as well and also by the fact that
she keeps looking at the clock suggests
that she doesn't quite know what to do
on the board and usually this translates
to you looking at the clock and going no
I still don't know what I'm going to
want to do and like you say I also
detect stress but to do wanjun looking
very calm sitting back and she looks
like she is in control
and 16 minutes on the clock for lateing
Jay as she tries to find the best
defense against Jew and June's plan of
putting an eye on C3
and then targeting the weak D5 Pawn
yeah very uh very briefly played as June
June hunts down her fourth title
and if she manages it
there are only a few women who've
actually been a full-time women's world
champion so start from the beginning
very romantic I I love the romantic and
the story so much I do feel like almost
a movie should be made or a documentary
should be made about her and I think the
only trouble is is that there's no
footage of her it would be there would
be something if someone could find some
camera roll then you definitely need
because this lady was remarkable and
then you had Nona capunders really of
course and then Maya tiburonatsu
and then finally ho yifan
wins this game
she will join those big names
that is esteemed company to be in isn't
it
um in incredible indeed as a Jewish
hunts down this title
um and what a game she's playing to try
to season and what a moment to do it in
game 12. she has drawn so many of the
games with white but knowing that this
is the moment to pressure her opponent
maybe Latin Jay also thought that it
would be
um an easier game today I doubt it
because she certainly came playing the
fight as well but still it's just really
tough when you don't have a chance to
hit back Jovi Because this is the last
game of the match
wow
it's the worst time it totally is the
worst time to make a blunder but it is
just kind of symbiotic of what's
happened before you know there's been so
much tension so much pressure I mean one
of them was bound to crack and it's just
very unfortunate that if late in J loses
it's because of this E5 move on move 22
and it's just because she just could not
resist her urge to just break open the
position and remove the B5 Pawn but now
for sure she's regretting it because
what a change if that porn had been on
E6 I mean white doesn't have a clear-cut
palette at all but
you can't take back the past what it's
done is done and uh late in Jay has to
focus on the future has to find a really
good way of Defense I'm just wondering I
mean should she trade off Rooks do you
think that that is a good idea
ah maybe yeah yeah like Rook A1 night
the problem is I would love to trade off
rocks in theory but in practice aren't I
just losing the Deep line right away
because I think in theory I would like
to because then um I have a rook type
piece and you don't have a rook type
piece hi it's as simple as that right
that that I think they did do some
database analysis on two works first one
rook and on average it's good to trade
the rock because then we're the only
person who has a piece that moves like a
rough which allows for some some ideas
and tricks but
um she played she tried to trade the
Bishops but I think the problem was
working one Knight C3 Rook F1 King F1
and the d-pawn goes jewelry so
um couldn't do it King G7 you mentioned
it here in Knight C3 and now that pawn
on D5 Under Fire right away oh and look
at that eval bar it hates this line but
I gotta tell you it's so human like I
would want to get rid of the dark
squared Bishops too so why is this so
bad
after I just think she's not able to
defend the pawn on D5 eventually so
what's gonna happen yeah we looked at
this line The Rook comes to A5 be
careful don't make moves like Knight B5
because well late in J will immediately
take that night off the ward and
suddenly it is due and Jin who has
spoiled the game completely and this is
just a win
so Rook A5 defunding the pawn is on the
board but what's going to happen is that
simply Juan Jun and she is excellent at
positional chess she really is so she's
just gonna pay rookie she's got her
Target in mind once I've stopped
highlighting every single Pawn there is
and I'm gonna say good morning to the
world when I make mistakes like that The
Rook will come to D1
and uh there's a big threat already of
just reinforcing the position I'm a big
fan of that you don't need to hurry in
end games the D5 Pawn isn't going to go
away and then once you've solidified
your position maybe put your King on G2
King and F3 H3 then you can just Round
Up This Pawn
and you have to remember this Italian
expression that I I heard it says uh
it's a make haste but don't rush
it was about just life in general my
taste but just don't rush through life
and I think it just explains how it
should be in engage or alternatively you
can be cheesy and cringy like me and say
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
all right hey I mean it might be cheesy
but it's memorable so yeah let's go with
it I I am in in shock here and you know
I think it you know this move
that caused so many trials and
tribulations relating to hey I think it
was just a misevaluation I just don't
believe it's not like I she missed
Bishop E5 or anything like that you know
I think she just didn't think that white
would have as much as white has and this
is where the experience and the
positional class of June June is really
showing I mean it's beautiful to see
it's beautiful to see this this champion
this uh a great Grandmaster in her
element right now she
squeezes her edge here
yeah and I was gonna say just to
piggyback on your point I think she
lashed out with E5 because a is it's
stylistically letting Jay she likes
activities she likes to determine things
but also I feel like she got too nervous
and she couldn't hold her nerves because
what she needed to do was just grit her
teeth and maintain the tension as for as
long as possible it's a fact this was
going to be a challenging thing for Juan
Jun to do as well
and as a result we see late in J playing
this position
and this one we can see the evaluation
bar tells us is plus
2.46 that is not a good evaluation for
late in J's chances
and the question the problem is is that
what can she do she's just has to resort
to maybe
moving the king
there's no target
well does she have maybe more practical
chances than that because I okay
sometimes the evaluation bar doesn't
really represent reality so let's look
at like maybe Rook to A3 let's see what
if I work A3 I'm just saying if I get
greedy let's let's look at these moves
like greed is good because it's tempting
right
and then maybe you can come
to A2 could that be something no because
the Night Comes
um I suppose yeah yeah yeah so I was
more thinking about Rook D3 or C3 okay
so let's let's try Rook D3
and I need to keep control on this Pawn
so go here and how am I meeting now
we're doing 52.
how am I meeting that I how is every
position good for Riot I'm like they
don't have it on sense like I feel like
I'm getting so I just have to get Rick
F1 and say
Ah that's that that's uh you can't you
can't ever go see three
that night coming into being able to
guard T3 has just been the the
combination of the night on D4 and the
Knight on D5 or just this like
unbelievably strong defense against all
of my ideas it's it's quite frustrating
to be honest
totally frustrating on this try let's
try like let's let's not lose hope and
let's have a look at some practical so
Roots do one Rook A3 I think is a good
choice what happens after 19 spawn you
just goes to see you three okay the most
natural just play C3 right away yeah
sure but then afterwards
I just lose the pawn right away
yeah that's the problem you just lose
the pawn straight away these these nines
I mean this is a pattern I mean I don't
usually see Knights like this Knight D4
I think it's a combination of a knight
D4 which is like protected by the pawn
so it's an outpost and it kind of like
by proxy it helps its friend on D5
because a lot of the squares that would
destabilize D5 are taken by the Knight
on D4 it's it's really annoying those
nights are the bane of elegante's
existence right now that's for sure
um she's trying something different she
did not try any kind of Rook A3 business
she slid her work back to B6 okay
um and she's just trying to go for
Passive defense if you
um attack my Pawn on D5 again Rook D6
yeah so maybe her idea is that when the
king
walks to because I'm expecting Jew
engine to take it easy you know enjoy
life
she has all the time in the world now so
I'm expecting her to do either moves
like root D2 or King to G2 H3 King to F3
and King to E2 and then just
enjoy and then when she's ready and only
when she's ready and got perfect control
and there we see night to eat you okay
no Jewel engine is immediately going for
the pawn on
day five consequences
she she can win it right I mean if you
play Rook 36
uh Knight F4 is on the board right and
you just can't defend it enough times
we're just attacking it three times and
you're defending it twice I mean hey
that that's one of the things about
having three pieces where you only have
two
and can you somehow break this down so
for instance can I Tamp you with
material so after here
and
what do we really
rugby three is her choice so now so
what's the idea here that you're getting
some counter play if I take on D5 uh
with this well let's take with the
Knight right ah but then Rook 33 Maybe
okay finally
so Knight takes D5 would be a big
mistake because of this beautiful Rook
D3 move
yeah I've been trying remember I was
trying Rook D3 earlier but then you had
a knight on D4 so it wasn't very good
now my knight on D5 is not actually
protected so it works actually I mean at
first glance you think white might
actually be losing because if Rook D3
upon D3 I am attacking both Knights at
once and my my Pawn is encroaching on
your position but okay okay apparently
White
can at least avoid total disaster but
this is uh a lot lot better for black
than the positions we're looking at so
Knight D5 currently Untouchable you also
don't want to take with a rook right
in the position here
so let's uh let's have a look so Rook B3
it's sneaky move there from Lady Jay and
if you take with the Rook I'm guessing
it's the same
idea you
I guess you go Rook D3
and after
the the thing is though if the knights
are protecting themselves and this Pawn
is restraining them
and then there could be some weird
equilibrium equilibrium where
you know white can't improve and neither
can black like this Knight can't move
and this Knight probably can't move
either
but this one seems to me look like it's
okay like it's good wow but I mean this
should be winning somehow for right
right I think it does feel like that way
your work is stopping us from getting to
the um obviously if we could get our
King to C5 or something we win easily
because the pond Falls and then we win
uh but in this position like once we get
our King up to E4 uh the question is how
do we improve our position right
do we do something with one of our we do
have four verse three
so I would think that we could do
something with that but I don't know huh
okay so this is a concept this is a
drawing concept for Lei Ting Chen I'm
not saying it draws I'm saying it's a
very very valid attentive trying to draw
the game right exactly and uh yeah you
can see the situation where life is
difficult for Juwan Jun and I really
like the Practical
problems that Rook B3 does prevent
present and
yeah and the thing is though the pawn on
D5 is not going to go away so I would be
tempted not to win it just now and just
kind of focus on my king jeans I'm
obsessed with this plant King G2 H3 King
F3
build build and then when you're ready
put the Rook on D2 or something you know
when you're ready for Rook D3 then you
can take on D5
yeah I think that's a great point
because if our King is super
um centralized when we take that pawn on
D5 it might really change those
variations
um in a way that allows us to get the
key Tempo so for instance if we get a
king on e4 after we take on B5 it gives
us a lot more options
um that might make the game totally
winning for white rather than the the
really tense position you're just
showing okay exactly what we had on the
board earlier it's like The Rook was on
D3 and there was like you mentioned so
this this is the position that we were
looking at like this okay yeah this is
winning but it's not as easily one
because the King still has a job to do
and you know you feel that these nights
are not working to their best if the
king were involved here then it would be
an easily winning game but the king
isn't
and right because then you could just
chase after it was annoying right like
if you already had your King on e4 you
could just play like Knight B6 and then
yeah you know it requires a little bit
of calculation but it looks like you can
just somehow take the pawn and then
obviously you're gonna be winning then
although honestly it's never going to be
that easy because you know the nights
are
um you know not the best known for
winning end games with like uh such
reduced material uh but right winning
the pond on C4 is obviously the first
step we do need to win right something I
would I would caution again so say for
instance in this type of position and
you know the poor The Rook is
attacking this said D5 Port D5 Knight
and I would kind of say don't play moves
like night to e to C3 because yes it
looks like it's really stable but
neither of the knights can move and now
you really are dependent on moving that
King to assist these nights so that they
can untangle so just be aware of this
pattern
s
this is going to be this is going to be
a really long one I think that Lee Ching
Jay is gonna I don't know whether this
is gonna be a draw or a win for white
but I think it's going to go the real
distance because we're starting to see
these ideas for black of holding on
because of the greatly simplified
material doing that so it's never going
to be easy for you in June I mean she's
playing a fantastic game but uh you know
as great as she's playing it's still
going to be really difficult right
because there's just not that much
material left right
totally but uh there we see Jew and Jen
moving the king forward she's on the
same page as me you know improve all
your pieces before you capture that pawn
on day five you can take your time and I
it just shows to me that Juan Jun is not
nervous at all she's not feeling the
tension she's just simply taking the
position as it comes and this is the
best approach
she can leave the emotion for after the
match and there we see H6 from lateing
Jay playing fast now and Latin J 10
minutes on the clock and they'll move
32.
now now I mentioned it earlier Jovi that
um in general when you've got
the one rook and your opponent's got the
two Rooks you as the better player would
prefer to keep or do you find June would
prefer to keep that raw so that you know
we can use the rook and our Knights to
attack some other weak points like let's
say you have seven and then all that
garbage I was saying about how it's
difficult to win it's going to be a long
technical battle no I mean if you start
winning other pawns other than D5 and C4
okay white will win so is there a way
that we can remove that pawn on D5
without giving you the option of trading
rocks
um that's the dream that is the dream
but uh we saw that black was being cagey
and preventing that uh but can we just
can't we just play Knight takes D5
without any Rook D3 business
um how do we how do we make that happen
I think
can she do that like first of all kind
of go like age four or age three I don't
know and then king after yeah so just
make those small improvements I I like I
do quite like H4 because at the same
time yeah your idea of like going for
other targets comes into operation maybe
G5 and you mentioned the F7 phone I'm
like oh yes I'm down with that one as
well
and yeah I mean maybe maybe she should
start with H4 if she wants to go for
this G5 idea okay she has to time it
correctly because G5 obviously can be
vulnerable to D4 so obviously
there are ideas on the board for lateing
J but
H4 King F3
King F3 immediately also makes a lot of
sense and then you know you can start
looking at going Knight takes pawn and
your idea of capturing the D5 pawn and
then going for other targets is still
game on
wow yeah I I think that I don't see away
yet Joby though to stop this like idea
of uh
of Rook D3 that's my concern that's my
um I don't I don't see it I don't see a
way to stop because black uh has a clear
eye on what White's trying to do take on
D5 and she's got a clear idea of what
she wants to do against it which is to
make sure to trade rocks
I'm just wondering like with okay sir
just because you just because I'm I'm
obsessed with it so I'm sorry how I will
kind of go King F3
okay and then okay show me and then and
then like I don't know I was thinking
could she go even go Rook D4 is that
even a possibility
but how is that the evaluation
then you can go Knight takes deep I can
go Knight takes T5 right
but I still will try to play my Rook D3
thing I'm obsessed you're obsessed with
expanding and all that and I'm obsessed
with trading off a pair of rocks because
some of those positions we were looking
with look with like two nights first
work I was like wait a second that's not
that easy like even if I hang it up even
if I lose another Pawn that is gonna be
brutal for White's win I mean uh so uh
if you play Knight D5 my idea is still
going to be to play Rook D3 and isn't
that gonna force a trade of Rooks anyway
it's always forcing a trade of rocks
teens
I figure this out but I I'm not finding
a way uh to both win the pawn and avoid
a rick trade
well Geo engine she has the time in the
world and there we see her in the
playing Hall she is thinking about all
those possibilities and in the meantime
well something special is coming your
way because the wait is over POG Champs
5 is back 16 of the world's biggest
creators will go head to head in the
greatest event in amateur chess brought
to you by chess.com and pogchamps Legend
Ludwig what's your favorite creators
like QT Cinderella and Sea Dog VA and I
did a thing fight for their share of
100K prize fund and a ticket to the live
finals in Los Angeles use exclamation
mark POG in chat for all the details and
while this exciting event will start
soon we will also have an exciting thing
going on right now will this be the
final game of the Women's World
Championship find out more after the
break
[Music]
ha
yeah yeah this one is a bit difficult
[Laughter]
so I'm going to show you some puzzles
you're going to have 10 seconds to look
at the tablet and then I'm going to take
tablet away and you're going to have to
give me the solution okay you ready sure
all right
made in five white
okay
you got it all right yeah 1006 version
57 will get yourself very nice very nice
very nice good start
okay
95.
no wait
where's
if you go 97 I go King h8
which page five
yeah that's
that's not working out
okay Queen G6 has to be the right person
yes
that's right yes very good
okay
so it's Queen takes G6
fg97 check pH 700 VHA Bishop f8
and then Bishop H3 or S5
wait Bishop H5 must be black yeah not
visual H3 Bishop H5 the Knight G5 Aha
and then 19 G6 is that iPhone uh so you
said Queen takes G6 after hd6
97 okay we have Knight F6 here oh Knight
F6 King h8 oh that's Bishop f8 yes
Bishop G7
right
let's see
um 97 King H7 Bishop f8
Bishop H5 Bishop H5 why do I have a
knight on G3 yeah F3 you do have an
iPhone
9 G6 so what if I go King h8 first
instead of King H7
oh yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
for the 12th classical game of the
women's world championship match and it
has been an intense battle it's been 17
days now moving on to the 18th day of
Chess and wow what a fight these two
competitors have brought to the table
and we see late in Jay with the black
pieces we left her with a decision how
is she gonna defend this uncomfortable
position there is some pressure on on
her and would you say Jennifer that lady
Jay has been feeling the heat throughout
this game maybe she's feeling stressed
maybe a tiny bit nervous because she's
taking decisions that haven't
necessarily suited her active Style
it's true but she's also we also thought
she had the Opera hand at some points in
the game so it's really been um
all over the place this game with who we
thought was better or whether it was
balanced there's been a lot of twists
and turns
um but now for sure he is looking at the
prospect of a very long defense uh will
she be able to do it and get her chance
uh to strike in a playoff tomorrow well
that's the big question we'll be
watching over the next hour or two right
is view in June
looks to uh to milk her her lovely
position here I mean just a strategic
lesson of the way that the night on C3
holds back both Pawns
it's really cool to see
it is super cool from uh there's been
some really lovely points from ju wanjin
in this game you know retreating the
night back to B1
at this moment when the route came to B2
that was given a question mark by the
game review and there we see Knight B1
was such a nice idea just putting a
knight on C3 blockading the pawns and
also proving that blockadas they're
great Defenders but they're also great
attackers as well very nice idea by Juan
Jun and uh Lei Ting Jay you're right I
mean this game has been very nervous
it's been very topsy-turvy and I I do
think though that late in J has been the
more nervous of the two because there
was remember right in the opening there
was a big pause where Lei teen J had a
had a long thing around about Bishop D6
and after gironjun quickly castled
stopped and had maybe a 20 minute I
think and it seemed like she couldn't
she was assassing whether to go E5 G5
and after this very long thing she just
went and calmly played castles but if
you're gonna make that move you should
have just made it at Tempo so to speak
should have made it instantly but uh yep
that was a critical moment where lady
Jay if this had been game three I'm sure
she would have gone G5
I'm sure she wouldn't have second
guessed herself but later on you're
right the nerves this time actually came
from Juwan Jun as uh after Knight B3
where Geo engine has a great position
she is on the verge of establishing
wonderful pawns there on the queen side
about to play B6 and she could have
neutralized this with Rook A2 but she
got nervous because of the consequences
of Knight takes Knight and instead
played Knight takes sorry Bishop takes
Knight and suddenly the advantage just
completely dissipated in favor of Lei
Ting Jae and
again
it all kind of swung on another critical
moment where you were on June played
Queen C3 it looked like things were
tanning and late in Jay's favor and here
without thinking too much lady Jay
simply traded off queens and but maybe
that wasn't necessary and she could have
perhaps played Bishop to C8 and tried to
round up this Pawn in a kind of in a
better way
and finally the biggest mistake of
ovulating J I would say came on move 30
the 22 was when she just couldn't hold
her nerve any longer and she decided she
was not gonna wait and maintain the
tension and dislodge the knight from E5
and this had terrible consequences on
her Pawn structure and the results of
this is here and you kind of mentioned
it deny on C3
hitting at this weak point on D5 which
no longer has any protection whatsoever
and Latin Jay
tough tough job ahead of her objectively
I think it's lost so what she has to do
in my opinion is just find the PATH and
this was a term coined by dingler and of
the most resistance
just keep playing on a move by move
basis and if you don't see a completely
winning line for your opponent make that
move that is the path you should choose
yeah
um I'm just starting to get less sure
because I I'm worried about like first
of all Essex cool move stopping my king
from getting invite at E5 but I I don't
see how it's ever going to be easily
winning if I if I have to trade off
rocks I I know you're not saying it's
easy but like how like how do you win
with the two nights
you you basically you round up the C
pawn and then you somehow round up the
f-pawn but I mean I'm gonna be doing
something in the meantime right I'm not
completely uh
like let's take a look like suppose I
play Rook takes B5 here right
I'm not saying that I wouldn't rush with
that though that's that's sure I think
I've been like I saw I'm really tempted
to go age four okay four and then King
F7
or something and
yeah what I wanted to do was root D4 and
go H5 and then just get ah okay an extra
Square for a night to potentially hop
into F5 but I can see that uh
jiwanjin wasn't happy with the idea of
capturing on D5 immediately with a rook
all the night so instead she's gone for
an alternative plan which is to relocate
The Rook to see one she wants to put a
knight onto F4 and now she's gonna go
for D5 but I think you can okay yeah
that's that's good that's good okay so
she saw a way to do what I was trying to
figure out how to do very nice but King
F7 was played
um is there a problem with this though
after Knight F4
um so King F7 Knight F4 must be the idea
right
it would appear that way unless I can
see the evaluation bars like no oh no no
no no no no
maybe there's D4 there is that a
trickier like after Knight F4 D4 upon
takes D4 or K3 does that work but yeah I
I can drop it back to you too and now I
have a past Pawn that I'm yeah right oh
this is so that can't be it that can't
be its own there's maybe there's nothing
wrong with
so why is this so this should be a
really good plan then we didn't get our
king
um to D6 in time
um I I I I I don't I don't see how this
would be
I don't see how this could be anything
but terrible for black right if we if we
don't get the Hurricanes just a little
bit too slow
right totally
yeah and uh I'm a bit confused by why
Lei teen Jay played King F7 so quickly I
mean I was expecting G5 or something
just take away the F4 Square from the
night
and Knight F4 played by Juwan Jin
mm-hmm that's like a great looks like a
really great idea I mean I I think we
probably have to play D4 it's better
than the alternative I mean if we're not
gonna lose if we're gonna lose that pawn
we might as well
um
but if you lose it you give white a pass
sorry not the king we might give the
white a past pawn and it's quite simple
to push that pawn
true but at least we get counter play in
that we're pinning your knight on C3
right that's true I guess but if it's
lost it's lost so
huh yes it has to be the path of most
resistance what is going to trouble
white the most
it could be it could be like this whole
idea of just getting that PIN
because ultimately as you mentioned if
you just lose this Pawn
the king will come forward the pawns
will come forward and
that is also a pretty straightforward
for white
well D4 upon takes D4 maybe G5 right
away
um and then F5 okay trying to make a
bunch of Trades
so T4 takes on D5 G5 you can't play
Knight D5 because of Rook takes D5
so that's already a nice trick yeah at
least there's that I like it
um and you don't want to go anywhere
besides E2 because then Rook A3 would be
super powerful and now after F5
um okay I'm trying to you know do
something this is something exactly this
is what I would kind of call the path
for most resistance I'm going to take
that one because otherwise I don't want
Lao F4 right I'll take it back
and you'll take back with a check and
then okay can you move to E3 yeah King
E3 looks good I mean this is yeah this
is looking pretty powerful okay I don't
really have anything G4 I could play G4
here but
uh
yeah it looks like I'm getting a little
play with the F coming to F3 with a
check but you're right that pawn on B4
is now
unencumbered and it's not like my
threads are winning or anything hmm
hmm well Rook F3 is a threat so I guess
I could go Knight F4 but then yeah
you're right
D5 game will come to e for oh I mean
there's just a question of building
slowly I mean Jew engine is not in a
rush at all and
yeah letting Jay thinking she's down to
two and a half minutes in the following
position unfortunately for lateing Jay
her Pawn on D5 is about to fall from the
board
oh my God 35 I didn't realize she was
down to two minutes oh my gosh two
minutes for five moves this could be it
okay because it you know it seems like
in a lot of these lines she has some
possibilities to make it interesting but
with only two minutes he's on a
tightrope and what did she play she did
play D4 she played d64 now let's see
what her follow-up is she's gonna play
Rook A3 right away
um if you're gonna try to trade some
pawns off she doesn't have that many
possible moves
and she has plain T5 so she played that
movie I mentioned earlier G5 on the
board
but there is there is a kind of a
long-term hope for 18j is if she manages
to trade her Forex and trade off all the
pawns
and her reckon sacrifice itself for the
pawn the two knights is one of the most
unfair things in jazz two nights against
a king is a draw
and if you if you if I keep myself upon
then in some positions it's a loss
because you can use that pawn to
um force me to make a
a Tempo and I can get you into a
Checkmate whereas those stalemate ideas
would often save me the draw in the two
nights versus King pure so let's see if
she can arrange anything like that and
the position we were expecting is on the
board after F5 and here we were looking
at Pawn takes F5 Rook takes F5 King E3
and thought that it looked incredibly
promising for white let's see if we see
that on the board
is there anything else though that's
better after playing F5 is there any
other move that we can play yes you
could go H3 you don't need to allow The
Rook to F5 that would be another
candidate move
that I would uh look at because yeah I
like that F4 F4 was a move that I was
briefly worried about but I guess if you
can just put your King on e4 and also
once the king is on e4 and you can get
on with the idea of going D5 moves that
you must not make a D5
D5 would be a bad move and you'd have to
start your journey all over again
because after root takes D5 oops
isn't possible because of the pin
against the Knight
yeah you want to keep that pawn that's
for sure that is your prized possession
right now
I I'm expecting H3
um yeah I like that that's also it seems
like in Her Style
preserve the Integrity of the pawn
structure and I I still remember this
interview by nihua who is the Chinese
woman's team captain and he's I
incidentally someone who's worked with
Jew one Jun for her first world
championship match in 2018 and he
described the Jew engine style is very
much like a shield her Excellence is in
possession positional chess and late in
Jay her she's a much more aggressive
player so he was like she's the sword
and it's a battle between The Sword and
the shield and at the minute The Shield
is looking like they're gonna win it
wow yes looking to capture this women's
world championship title or rather
retain it and she is the reigning world
champion but will she retain that title
for quite a while longer you know once
you have it she doesn't want to give it
away and here she is clinging to the
crown
again
it okay him down you know and it's all
coming down to this 12th and final game
and the players have entertained us with
Fighting Chess throughout and today
didn't break that formula June came in
an aggressive mood she chose a very
committal opening she born takes porn
played by Juan Jun and after Rook takes
porn I'm expecting the king to move to
E3
his way to the Santa and letting Jay
just under three and a half minutes and
they'll move 39 but it's not the clock
which is the only problem for letting J
her position is on the verge of defeat
and if this happens
well
it is been just a fabulous tournament
for June June we also have to remember
that jirenjun played some of the match
in in just trailing from behind she was
in a must-win situation and she
eventually did it in game eight and it
looked like ever since they've arrived
and started playing in zhongjing that's
Juan Jun she feels comfortable with the
surroundings she's leveled up
and yeah because she's had a lot of
opportunities hasn't she she had an
opportunity yesterday she had an
opportunity in your favorite Carol Khan
um so she's been on top in multiple
games in this leg of the match we do
have a few moves as they've seem to pass
the the 40 move mark
and uh you'll move G4 on the boards
and just a quick observation this Rook
on F5
it's not been placed correctly I
personally have no problem with such a
piece what about you Jennifer would you
have adjusted it Oh you mean to take on
Rook four and three quarters yeah that
is that is a little sloppy right
um I don't know I I might yeah I might
I might adjust that
and I guess it depends oh you know I
mean she's thinking about playing the
move Knight F4 so wow
she plays the move Knight F4 she could
kind of like push the Rook ever so
slightly right
right and uh just to say yeah I like
that but uh just this kind of reinforce
the point that she has to play Knight F4
because black is threatening to play
Rook F3 check and win the F2 Pawn
yeah deal with that if you go King E4
you let go of protection of F2 anyhow
and only move Knight to F4
well if you play Panda 4 then you've got
that beautiful and bizat roll right that
uh again you remember Yogi yesterday you
were saying yeah we don't need an
ambassad
but can you imagine
ah that would just be another way to
lock up the position I guess Knight you
do have Knight F4 so it's not so
relevant here but there are some
positions where it would make the
difference and there it is it looks like
I see that nine on F4 did she push back
the Rook at the same time no she's
getting up move 40 is done for her so
she can take a little break
she suddenly can take a break now that
she's got the bonus time of 30 minutes
on the clock and lay team Jay
well her threat has been parried and so
now she has to come up with a plan
something that will at least trouble
white because White's plan is so simple
it's just to kind of
step forward with the King you know she
can take her time over this there's
simply no access points for this Rook on
F5 it can't move to age five that night
on F4 stops everything
wow indeed indeed what are they plan
with by uh June to play Rook C1 and
Knight F4 and just in the nick of time
she was able to actually pick up that
pawn with no problems
very very well done and well well
calculated uh because I do think that if
she had traded off Rooks this would be a
heck of a task just because what you
were pointing out earlier that even the
two nights verse King you can't win so
therefore if there's too much
simplification it's going to be really
really hard
so let's see
let's see what uh liking J comes up with
here in trying to defend she looks very
frustrated a lot of people are pointing
out in the chat that she looks sad she
looks frustrated such a well-played
world championship match but it all
comes down to this
it all comes down to this and right now
it is who sees that dream of winning the
World Championship potentially
evaporating in front of her eyes but you
know what you can't think about that now
think about can I find some way to make
it tricky most resistance right she's
done a lot of that so far right
um it has very challenging task and
she's trying to keep it interesting
and uh that we see letting Jay Retreat
The Rook to B8 and now she does have
that bonus time of 30 minutes as well
and now for Jew and June is just about
consolidating and picking up this C4
Pawn if she can do that then the game is
very straightforward
coming maybe to E8 but it's just no way
for these two Rooks to harmonize with
each other they need to be singing the
same tune and that's not happening
yeah
huh yeah just
you rookie hat can always be met by 94
huh yeah those Knights next to each
other end up becoming powerful partners
I'm still thinking so maybe you can 94
94 straight away threatening Knight D6
yeah yeah
okay maybe now we can throw in a rick B3
check okay okay and uh and I know you're
reluctant so I wouldn't be reluctant to
go with C3 but maybe that would be a
mistake maybe you have to go Knight
through three again
hmm okay well then if if you have the
Rook B3 still
maybe it's not my chop choice because I
don't really want to go back
could you maybe mobilize The Rook I'm
thinking is there some kind of danger so
for so for instance so Rick I was first
of all thinking okay one but you're
simply gonna go Rook B3 and I have to go
back C1 again
yeah let's not do let's not do that
let's uh wait and see a little bit more
so I can wait and see if I put in my
reconcito
and I'm going to pass the move to you
and see
where it goes so Rick C2 just to over
protect F2
right okay and um and work
um yeah
yeah so if you pass two
um I want to keep myself these options
of playing Rook A3 check or rookie e
depending on what happens by the way I
noticed we have some comments in chat
about how the engine evaluation is so
heavily favored in white why doesn't
black resign well actually it the engine
um outputs in in games like this are a
little misleading sometimes because a
lot of times it's harder than it might
seem right so like if you have a middle
game in your upper Rock that's very
different from like this position I I
it's way way harder here because if you
mess up again don't forget those looming
end games with great simplifications
that could be draw even if white has two
extra Knights whereas in a middle game
that's coming over the case in the
middle game if you're up two nights
obviously it's a resignation at a Grand
Master Level but in end games you know
it's uh very very different
like I completely agree with you I don't
think that yeah we see the evaluation
bias say it's like 3.91 but uh I mean
just at first I thought you'd just go 94
and then you just go and Rick takes pawn
and the end but now I can see it's not
so easy because after saying Knight E4
we have that Rook B3 and then if I go
Rook C3 I was just thinking about that I
mean isn't moves like age five and with
the the idea play that you're gonna go
H4 G3 and sacrifice once you've won all
the pawns or traded off all the pawns
you could sacrifice this Rook for this
pawn and that would be a draw
and I can't play Brook takes B3 and
Knight D6 check because after Knight
takes a five there's B2 queening and if
I play Nike six check King F6 Knight F5
the C3 Knight hands so somehow I forgot
about Knight D6 but it's somehow other
but what I just wanted to say was like
maybe you know I just wanted to
highlight this point okay H5 H4
so you know even if you do wait so for
instance you go Roxy 2 and I was just
waiting and say you go age five I mean
how how is this you get ready for your
H5 H4 the big swap off
oh yeah wait where how where's the big
swap off though uh because even after
age five
my dream okay and I admit it could be
just a pipe dream it's just to go H4
and then go g3 at the right time right
G3 and then make the trade and then when
everything is traded off play Rook G5 or
something and manage yeah and then try
to just try to sacrifice The Rook for
the pawn and then and try to straight
straight off works I mean there's a big
ass you know first of all I need to
trade a bricks then I need to trade of
Pawns and then I need to suck The Rook
for the porn so those are the three
things I have to do but okay might be
possible well yeah but you're gonna try
it I mean this is your chance to win the
World Championship right like she's
going to try every trick up her sleeve
as um this is not uh not an easy
defensive one but she's gonna try
it is exactly and uh do you want it has
to find a move here
but yeah don't forget that because you
can't move she can't move an F4 Knight
because Rook F3 is happening so she and
if she moves this Knight to E4 then okay
she's come up with D5
yeah
yeah so now we've rookie eight check we
still have 94 right so no worries so far
uh MF uh
but
yeah yeah because this Knight on F4 is
not being pinned so yeah that's uh
annoying it's annoying
both
Knights protect the D5 Pawn
and so Ricky to E8
yeah and then whoops the pawn on C4 will
fall right right yeah and after Rook E5
you've got this
yeah it's almost like we want our work
to be we don't want our work to be on E8
because we want to be able to play like
Rook A3 check when you play 94.
yeah yeah or Rook B3 so we want our work
to be either in B8 or A8 so that if you
play Knight E4 we could play Rook B3 you
don't want to play Rook C3 in trade
rocks we've well I don't think you do I
think it makes it harder uh because some
of your ideas of trading everything off
and getting into one of those end games
become much more likely
um so we want to keep that Rook on B8 or
A8 so that 94 is met by her K3 check I
like your move H5
um I mentioned it earlier just
yeah exactly at least you give yourself
the opportunity that Geo and Jun might
go 94 and after Rook B3 she might just
think okay well whatever and go Ricky
Rick C3
and then
we might get that situation where the
pawns come down obviously there's a big
threat of uh Knight to D6 once you deal
with that maybe you are the idea of H5
G3
is viable so
definitely white does have the upper
hand but there are ways that Jew and
June can go wrong
yeah there are dating Jay which he's
been such a great technician in the game
so far it's hard to imagine she's not
going to continue playing great but you
know what hey I mean this is why we play
right and look at uh I gotta say she
seems a little bit more hopeful now
you know she's not completely despondent
it looks like she's got an idea and she
knows she's got to try it she's got to
try to defend it she's accepted the new
situation she's in trouble she might not
get that chance to win the World
Championship in tie break but she's
gonna do what you can right here and now
to um draw the game and get there
that's supposed well that's all she can
do objectively the game is lost for her
so all she can do is keep on fighting
keep on posing problems to do when you
keep on setting those traps and if Juan
Jun Falls okay great then she saved the
game if if Geo engine plays perfectly
Juan Jun is a great technician as you
mentioned then of course June by winning
she will be crowned women's world
champion for the fourth time she will
join the history books with some amazing
memes in women's chess but we will see
the still very much play still a lot of
play left in the position
that's right H5 where is she gonna go
now
um you know that seconds I can disappear
fast Joby it really can as Lightning Jay
now in the tank the thing though about
time years I'm not sure it's going to be
a huge Factor only because
uh there aren't even that many possible
moves for black right I'd be like what
is he thinking about here a couple moves
of course she wants to be super accurate
but there's age five maybe I like
working eight
um Rook B3 maybe but there is a limit of
how many moves you can even consider
yeah there is a limit and also you you
can't just make moves for themselves
like for instance you can't just give a
check because of course you have to
consider what white is planning what
does white want to do so again you
constantly in this position just simply
have to react and simply say what does
white want to do okay I will stop it I
will be a nuisance and we've already
seen there's one Pitfall for white you
can't just trade off Rooks and whoa
engine
if you carry on posing these problems do
engine could fall into some of these
traps she might not of course but then
again
who knows and there we see Leighton Jay
I I find Lady might be full of
Expressions but I find oh and we've just
seen a shrug of the shoulders from her
and she's just
thinking
yes I think she's coming to terms that
objectively
this match might be over for her
yeah what a deficit wait for it to
happen you know uh like oh yeah look at
those expressions oh I know people are
suffering along with her to play such a
great match and in the final game when
you're so close to getting all of those
playoff games getting that chance and
rapping in Blitz to face that Prospect
of ending it right now well you know all
I can say is that the pain of Lei Ting
Che is the joy of Jew and June who you
know I mean what greater feeling can she
have as a champion to say like hey I'm
going to
win in the last game
you know and she still has to win it she
still has to convert but that I I mean
it's just to win on demand like that to
avoid a playoff would really be
something and again just show us like
whatever the format whatever the
situation due in June is a champion
undoubtedly a champion and we see late
in Jay Retreat The Rook to F6
again asking
you and Jun just to show us all what is
her plan to win is she gonna play
between 94 is she going to fall into
that trap or is she gonna play something
else move the Knight to E2 to reinforce
protection of f4 and then use the king
to get to the middle of the board will
she be doing these things
we don't know
we don't know and do engine
unfortunately has all the Time in the
World to think about what she's going to
continue and there once again we see
late in Jay just look off to her right
as she considers and just thinks about
the consequence I am sure for letting
Jay it's all about going back to that
moment where she played E5
your brain has a nasty habit of doing
this to you you know you should be
defending but at the same time you're
thinking why did I do this why did I
make that move why did I voluntarily and
then what's even better is that your
brain often goes back and starts
analyzing that position instead of the
position you have but later if she wants
to save this game she just has to forget
what's happened focus on what the board
is now and keep on
just posing those problems and that we
see due one Jun take a sip of water
she's considering how to consolidate I'm
thinking that she will go Knight ce2
because she's played very carefully
some beautiful positional chess from the
women's world champion
that's right Knight to E2 looking to
round up the pawn on C4 stop tactics
that you might have on your mind with uh
the Knight on F4 only be being protected
by the king so okay so Knight to E2 uh
what happens if you play uh Rook to C3
to C8
yeah so my plan is so you've been
talking about
not going into
you've made me really paranoid now I
can't just go kicking E4 because maybe
C3 will happen I'll be forced to make
bad trade so I've been thinking about
him maybe I should go Rook C3 first and
stop that pawn from advancing and then
go King to D4 uh and then
yeah and then slowly improve
I don't know and then again ask you the
question how are you going to improve
what move are you going to make oh it's
black well I feel like yeah okay I
because there comes a time when you're
gonna have to make a decision right you
can't wait for too long that's true um I
might need to try to get my king to D6
here for instance like King E7 and King
D6
K7 and now the question is what am I
gonna do am I going to get King D4 I
don't I don't even know now I'm like
really paranoid I don't even know
whether I should go can you no I like
that before
I might start having some issues with
actually like mating attacks because
like suppose I play King D6 maybe you
just say hey wait a second I'm just
gonna play Rook a three I mean not
mating attacks exactly but you know
attacks with the combination of The Rook
the king and the night
um it's like you're starting to get
split apart here so all of a sudden uh
and that and that is exactly why it's
black I've been desperate to trade off
the Rocks because this type of idea
coming at me with an attack is not a
thing if I were ever able to trade those
Rooks and this is exactly why do and
June wants the opposite thing and by the
way I don't know why Jovi was so hard
for me to see Rook C1 but because I was
like how do I avoid trading Rooks and
win the Pod and for some reason this
idea that you played which looks so
simple once you see it just play yeah
earlier in the game to play Rook C1 and
Knight F4 it it didn't occur to me right
away you know it didn't it didn't occur
to me either I wasn't thinking about
that one I also was completely shocked
by D5 which is really the most logical
move on the board I mean going back to
this I mean let's let's read back rewind
back to Rook C1 so yeah because that's
very instructed so focused exactly so
she played Knight F4 so we got to this
type of position
right before yeah and then she played
oh it was right before that so let's go
yeah let's go before she played Rook C1
yeah because I I was trying to figure
out like okay we were talking about
improving with H4
um and I kept saying like but we don't
want to play Rook takes D5 and if Knight
takes D5 there's Rook D3 we tried Rook
D4 that doesn't work but yes of course
Rook C1 that's that's such a brilliantly
simple move
um well certainly once you see it it
looks simple
um because then uh Knight F4 is coming
and the King does not have enough time
to get any protection of the D5 Pawn so
you get to win it without trading rocks
which has been the obsession of Juan
June because she does not want to draw
she wants to win
uh and yeah
I I agree with you I think it takes it
takes really a level of sophistication
and talent just to kind of move that
Rook away from the attack and just go
hello let me just reinforce reinforce
this protection hang on I oh yeah so
Rick C1 and
focus on the night getting to F4 here I
do feel like late in Jay she instantly
replied to King F7 but she perhaps she
could have played G5 and resisted a
little bit longer but okay as it stands
we do see a move in the game and I see
that after Rook F6 that's uh Juan Jun
she's gone for the principle of just
overprotecting all the pieces then
instead can Rook C2 so she does not
rushing with anything she's not going
Knight to you too just yet she's
focusing on just potentially defending
the F2 point and of course this has the
consequence that the Knight on F4 gets
released from defensive duties and can
now jump into E6 if needed
right right yes nice little technical
move
um love it yeah good point
but uh this is very good very precise to
you and June here I feel like in this
type of position Jew engine is
relentless
oh yeah it's fantastic I mean if you
look at some of these moves which you
know if they were like tactics
um you know I I would see it instantly
right but it's like the little moves
night Beyond Rook C1 and that
the patterns you know they don't come as
easily to many of us and and that's why
it's so beautiful to watch this game and
I hope all of you in addition to
watching the drama are getting getting a
little take away yourself because there
is something so elegant about this
positional Artistry but it's both hard
to learn but and that's why when you see
things like this like I know you know
the chess punks community on Twitter
I I noticed that uh there's this
movement
um that the founder of it really started
where they put like memorable positions
on flash cards you know old school uh I
mentioned Mark doveretsky earlier you
know the Polgar sisters this is
something that I think a lot of great
trainers and chess improvers have done
over the years but I mean I would really
consider putting like the Knight B1 move
on a card or putting the Rook to see one
move on a card because it it's really
one of those moments it seems so simple
once you've seen it but when you're in
the game a lot of the time people don't
see it
right because you're looking forward all
the time and you're always thinking what
do I want from the position and instead
you know June was thinking what does
lateing Jay want how is she hoping to
pose me problems and she just stops it
she says well you know Rook C1 Knight B1
I love those moves then and here I'm
gonna add Roxy too as well to that flash
card you know she chooses not to go
Knight to you too she instead chooses
just to reinforce the protection of
these pawns just in case she has the
time she's just simply enjoying the
position she's made sure all of this has
been backed up by calculation because
she's made sure that any Rook to E8 can
be backed up with Knight to E4 attacking
this rook and again
she's uh made sure that this Knight is
now released from his defensive duties
because the F2 Pawn
is defended and now it's just a case of
nurturing that pawn on D5 to the
destination of d8
oh well that's where it wants to go
that is it the pawn I mean she did play
D4 in this game it's not the same
partner right I think it's the e-pawn
now
let the record say that it was Yvonne as
an E4 player but of course uh when you
look at this game I do engine you can
certainly understand why she's a queen
Pawn player these types of structural
ideas and this type of precision it's
it's so perfect you mentioned earlier
the sword versus The Shield and when we
see that E4 versus D4 dichotomy I mean
what what better examples
um of it than these two players right
with Lei ting tang and her fiery tactics
being one E4 and um Jew and June's
positional Mastery I yeah you just
couldn't imagine in in any other way
yeah and it all comes down to this game
game 12 the final classical game we see
June with white pieces
can she win this winning position or
will late in J just pull off a miracle
safe well we will find out because we
are going to take a quick break and
catch you in a few minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby McGuire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
Play Bright is good right yeah then yeah
instant swipe right okay super into that
right I'm into it you're ready probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
around Tinder oh I get that I in fact
that checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
yeah no not gonna Anna Taylor Joy
Capital boy name another one oh Casper
of Casper if you name five other world
champions in the next 15 seconds I'm
Gonna Give You fifty dollars spasky
Polgar
oh my God we just lost 50 whose idea was
that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hello
hello everyone and we are back in
Chongqing for the 12th and final
classical game in the women's world
championship and we can see June when
June with the white pieces she has an
excellent position with fantastic
winning chances against Lei Ting J
letting Jay is in complete survival mode
she must defend this very difficult
ending if she has any hopes of staying
alive in the match and of course taking
it to tie breaks tomorrow and during the
break we did see two moves played we saw
juwanjun move the Rook up to C2 showing
some excellent positional understanding
just defunding the F2 Pawn whereas Lei
Ting Jay she seems to have gotten a new
kind of spring in her step as she
realizes that she is now fighting to
stay alive in this match she moved her
Rook to A8
hoping that any Knight to e4s will be
met by Rook A3 check and
Jan
it's a big ask but do you think that
letting Jake can save this position
I don't think so but I think she's gotta
keep fighting because it's an end game
there's not that many pawns left on the
board and as you've pointed out two
nights versus King isn't even a win for
the two nights so you must keep fighting
till the end I mean and for everybody
watching at home that applies to you
even more because Jew one June of course
knows the end games he's a master
positional player and theoretician
Grandmaster World Championship looking
for her fourth world championship in
fact but the people that you know a lot
of us are playing whether it's Blitz
Rapid or classical they make more
mistakes in the end game so you have to
keep fighting and that's what Lei Ting
Che is doing here she will not give up
until it's completely over because when
it's completely over that is the end of
her world championship matches world
championship chances in this match and
you know I noticed that in the chat that
some people are making fun of me because
at the beginning of the day I seem so
confident that you and I would be back
to call a playoff tomorrow but you know
what I mean could you really blame me I
mean there have been uh nine draws
before this game Right Toby so it was an
easy prediction to make
right and you know what I was thinking
that this has been a super long match
you know let's not forget that these two
players have been preparing for this
match as well for months and months the
tiredness has got to start creeping in
and we anticipated I am guilty of this
as well I thought that Jew and June
would come to the game you know thinking
okay she will try her luck she will just
play a solid system see how lateing Jay
handles that and if she handles it well
great that it will be an easy draw and
we will return tomorrow for that play
playoffs and those tie breaks but
instead Juan Jun she completely rewrote
the script she came and with seemingly
an innocuous opening which quickly
sharpened into one of the most complex
Moodle games I've seen and from there
it really has been a full-fledged battle
with the advantage swinging from Juan
Jun to late in Jay and eventually it was
going to be a draw and now we see that
after lateing Jay made that critical
mistake on move 22 where she succumbed
and pushed the e-born now it is just a
one-way traffic for Juwan Jun and well
what a competitor that's all I can say
this match has had it all
it sure has I mean it's been so dramatic
such high level chess being played you
know I think these two are really an
inspiration to players everywhere all
genders all ages all nationalities and
in particular for people looking to play
better positional chess you know we can
learn a lot from June I learned a lot
from her today and I I feel like
um just you mentioned her
um you know writing rewriting writing
the script
um but I mean really you're writing the
script four times right I mean just
rewriting uh finding every way she can
to win the women's world championship
she's playing for her fourth right now
and it looks like she's gonna do it and
I mean that's something that really is
something because her rating
um it you know there's other women who
have comparable ratings but for the
level of dominance she's had in the
world championship it doesn't really
matter rating right with hoyifan it did
with very menchik it did because they
were like way way higher than anyone
else playing at the same time but with
June June with nona also but with you
and June it's kind of an anomaly in that
having such World Championship dominance
but it not being matched in the ratings
she just knows how to win matches Yobe
it's kind of amazing yeah no I mean Juan
Jones remarkable story actually is very
impressive I mean first of all you know
she became women's world champion 2018
and then almost immediately she had to
defend her title in the world
championship knockout format and she
managed that she became the only person
in history to successfully to find her
title in two types of formats and then
then you know she had to defend her
title against Alexander goryashkina that
one also went to the Y I went to tie
breaks but Drew and Jun managed that and
this match as well you know we've seen
Leighton Jay come she's been determined
she's been exceptionally well prepared
she's aggressive she has a very
combative style and Juan Jun let's not
forget from games five to eight you know
she had to play with a point deficit and
only when she equalized
it did could she kind of like relax and
her shoulders could sink a bit because
her job was done but even then we still
saw Jew and journey you know she found a
really effective strategy of just simply
changing up the openings getting these
unusual games or unusual positions and
making late in Jay think and it's been
an absolute treasure to watch I have to
say this battle between them has been
epic and you know what I think we are
seeing the start of a rivalry
and wow that's that's a bold prediction
I love it I mean because there are so
many other great women players nipping
at their heels but gosh I mean the thing
about playing a match like this is you
learn so much from it which then puts
you ahead of your competitors right it's
kind of they call it like the Matthew
effect right so you're
um you're great she's the Women's World
Champion but then her chances of
becoming the Women's World Champion it
might even get higher because she has
all the knowledge of what it takes and
she's showing that but but I I do have
to ask about this move that we just saw
on the board
um Knight to B5 right we just saw um
Knight B5 be played uh so what's the
idea there well obviously we want to
take the pawn on C4 so that's not that
hard to figure out but after Rook to ca
uh what's the follow-up
um or is she trying to play for D6 um
what's going on what do you think yeah
let's have a have a look and let's see
this could be just juban Jr wanted to
finish the game once and raw so yeah one
of the advantages of the night being on
B5 is that the A3 square has been taken
away so no check for lateing Jay but
after Rook C8 that is a natural move now
defending the sea for born I'm wondering
whether you could push through that pawn
as you mentioned D6 would that be a
mistake
um that would actually be a mistake oh
my God wait it's sick significant
mistakes
and yeah
there's that no Knight E6 anymore so
that's a pitfall to fall into so it's
not about playing D6
and instead I guess it's to do with
I thought maybe Knight to E6 or maybe
moving the Knight to D4 no in June it's
probably like some Knight to E4 and
Knight to E6 hang on yeah yeah okay yeah
I like everything pretty perfect
let you do like rookie six checks Pawnee
six King E6 and some lines I feel like
that gives you more opportunities than
you've had for a long time you know what
I mean
I I don't you think it's like I don't
know I don't know I'm feeling like I I
want to try and avoid that I mean is
there chances in that type of line Jovi
where it would be like Rick and three
versus Rook Knight in two uh maybe not
but I
if you also can't do Rook C5 and Rook H5
and bring one more pot off the board
suddenly you've only got one Pawn it's a
bit annoying
uh let's not forget let's not forget
that a rig versus a Rick and Knight is a
easy draw right right so there are some
kind of things that uh Lei Ting Jay can
hold on to for inspiration so yeah what
to play though I after Knight to D4
um the big question is what next could
you go no you can't I was thinking could
you go H5
I like 94 though I like it better than
96. oh I actually what I was saying Joby
was that uh if uh I like your remove
Knight D4 uh but the earlier move that I
think we were attempting to try instead
of 94
um 96. I like that last because I'm a
little concerned about rookie 6 Pawnee 6
King E6 or are you or do you think
that's just really easy to win for Wyatt
is that trivial I mean you I'm just
worried that you only have two pawns
left and maybe I can get it no I think
this is a this is definitely something
to be thinking about like Rook C5 Rook
comes exactly five as well making those
trades no no I I agree with you 96 might
be winning but definitely would give a
new lease of life to late in Jay but uh
there we saw no no uh none of that move
and instead Rook to be six played and
Knight to D4
94. that's it something is coming and uh
Rook a three check
Rook a three check okay we can we can
step up right I mean
yeah there's no reason not to step up
with the King
yeah after all I mean just there's
nights you know there's a great
defensive principle which is like a
knight is a king's best friend and there
we see June up and look at that these
nights they're not only shelter the king
but they also Stop The Rook coming to H3
that puts like a really attacking Pawn
that's a really nice image in my head of
like the king with like two beautiful
dots just kind of like nestled there
just hanging out enjoying life and
certainly that the king is enjoying life
here because in this end game uh the
king is just beautifully centralized and
finally it's kind of hard to get any
counter play against it right a lot of
the counter play blackhead was kind of
destabilizing that King but not there
anymore C3 player though okay okay
uh she has not been able to play C3 for
some time first time in quite a while
that it's been on the menu at all
yeah it's it's not been on the menu
and unfortunately for black there is
existence of the D5 pawn and the D5 Pawn
I feel is way more important than the C3
Pawn which can easily be Complicated by
this Rick on C2 and also the night on D4
keeps a closed Garden nuts so the
question is how to continue for white I
mean how do you rearrange the knights so
as to an ideals world would be pick off
the C3 Pawn or promote this one right or
both uh I think that I mean a couple
moves come to mind here like just trying
to pick up the seat Pawn 92 but then you
do have to move Rook B2 which again
we've been trying to avoid trading off
rocks but of course in this particular
case uh that d-pawn is an absolute
nightmare
um with a k
uh and so I think we'll be okay there
but if we want to be extra careful uh we
could do something
um else and avoid the work trade right
yes so I guess if you want to avoid The
Rook trade you know Rook B2 is the plan
I guess you could be like really
mercenary about it and just go no you're
not gonna you're not gonna get a rook
there the end
I like that I like that although I don't
know at this point I mean maybe it's
time to just cash in the chips and take
that uh Pawn on C3 and that's exactly
what I do when June is thinking about
here is a time to just cash out and go
for the gold go for the trophy
um it and this is what great players are
so good at knowing when it's time to
cash out a lot of a lot of us we cash
out too early or too late right like uh
but finding that exact right moment I
mean in a way that's the definition of
technique of being a good technical
player converting your advantages and
what converting your advantages mean
don't try to convert it too fast and
well if you convert it too slow then you
know you're not going to win either so
in your case Jovi where did you feel
like you fell on that did you try to
convert too quickly or like
how how did you feel on that continuum
well usually I was on the too quickly
scale and it was a constant weakness
that I had that I got over excited and
then I just impulsively played a move
and then thought why why did I do this
why did I not consider what my opponent
wanted and this is uh something that
I've been trying to work on this last
few years just to kind of calm that
impulse because it's quite is manifests
itself in Middle games and the openings
and the end game as well and when I'm on
form I like I once had a game which I'm
really proud of where I resisted this
urge on every level and I I was just and
I I somehow either I got myself into a
really calm mindset mindset where I was
just like okay you know I'm probably
winning but okay it doesn't really
matter
let me just play let me not think about
the result let me just keep on improving
the position and I was so focused on
this mindset of just constant
improvements that when my opponent
resigned I was shocked and then I
realized like what I had done and I was
like oh okay I just beat a Grandmaster
with black pieces oh okay
that's beautiful that was great what a
great story what a great inspiration to
uh to find that technical Mastery and
not rush you know but it's just about
the mindset to be honest with you I mean
it wasn't anything other than that it
was just being calm and it was just
again not thinking about the result and
it was just constantly okay how can I
improve my pieces how can I do this what
do I want to do I came up with all weird
ideas like I triangulated my king and
there we see yomu Jennifer on the board
the night takes a step back Jew and Jun
wants to round up the C3 pawn and uh now
the big question is for late in Jae will
she just tried to go Rook to B2 and make
those trades remember there is still
some salvation in this position if due
and June sorry if lateing Jay can get
into a position where it's two nights
against the king that is a draw if it's
a Rooker Knight Against The Rook that is
a draw as well
so still hope
oh yeah hope does spring Eternal
especially for such great fighting
players No Doubt
um so we're expecting Rook B2 and you
know as this is such a critical game in
the world championship I got to take you
back in a little history to one of my
favorite world championships which was
the World Chess Championship in Buenos
Aires in 1939 it was actually the
outbreak of World War II coincided with
that world championship which meant that
a lot of Jewish players a lot of
anti-fascists were able to relocate to
Argentina and avoid getting slaughtered
by the Nazis one of those players was
vice World women's Chess Championship
Sonia Graf one of my favorite players
she was up against barramencik
eight-time Champion as we see Rook V2 on
the board and she was about to win but
she did convert too fast lost the game
and forever regretted this moment where
she um you know liquidated too quickly
and lost the win of course women's chess
has grown by Leaps and Bounds since and
now these players are an extraordinary
level in All Phases of the game and I
don't think we're going to see that
happen right here to do in June but hey
it's not over until the score sheets are
signed
totally and we see Juan Jun with that
King Retreat precise as ever you know
she's anticipating that she can simply
if there is a rick trade she can either
step back with a knight or capture with
the King it doesn't quite matter
probably the night and then harder is
just simply to overprotect the D5 pawn
and Round Up This Pawn on C3
and with the remaining pieces on her
Army shoe is just simply going to push
forward this D5 Pawn excellent technique
from Juan Jin and yeah it's interesting
that Dan you mentioned that Sonia Graf
was one of your favorite players because
I know that you like her very much but
like for me it's always been about
veroman check I always feel like we
haven't appreciated her and what we've
what she did for Chaz
in a nice way and especially I feel in
the UK you know only now like I'll be
having very romantic memorials and she
was the first English women's world
champion and we haven't had the like
since
I do feel that she should be honored
in a way that she isn't being at the
minute completely agree with you I mean
she died way too young I mean that was
one of the things and not only it when
unfortunately she died in such a sad way
um in World War II and uh in a bombing
attack when the war was almost over it
was just so sad uh you know a horrible
casualty at the hands of the Nazis and
unfortunately she also lost a lot of her
papers and games so we actually have
less records from her than we should uh
which you know losing history and it's
just
losing her so early is so terrible and
also losing history
um is a tragic loss so I I just uh
you know we're making history right now
and uh it's uh it's important to
remember those from the past as well and
I couldn't agree with you more as a time
world champion very minchik really is
looking on as you know this is her
Legacy of the world championship she was
the first world champion the one who won
the most titles despite dying at the age
of 38 I mean that's insane right you win
the most titles in history and you die
at 38 like if she had lived she had
lived a long life how many would she
want 20.
totally totally and and the worst thing
is you know she wasn't even a chess
professional so to speak she had to make
ends meet she had to teach she had to do
other things at times you know her
husband was a lot older than her she had
to look after her husband her husband
passed away and also she faced a lot of
opposition from the UK from people in
the UK they were like well you know
she's she wasn't born here so she
therefore she's not English and it's
like um yes she is
so I I really do admire all the
obstacles that she had to face and all
of our women players themselves you know
as you mentioned this is a historic
match I'm talking about obstacles you
know I'm really impressed by
both Jew and Jun and lei teen Jay how
they've approached this match all the
obstacles that they've overcome you know
they've played the match in two
locations first of all in Shanghai that
didn't really go uh Juan jun's way she
lost in game five and then it shifted to
Chongqing and it was like this change
rejuvenated her and well she came back
fighting and fighting is the only thing
that lateing Jake can do in this
position
objectively she's lost but she can still
Salvage this game by a miracle yeah
that's right and if I were I just take
that Rook off on C2 I've been dying to
do it all game let's go
take it off it's time it's time for
those fantasy lines in which you know
everything comes off the board and we
get our chances right
let's let's do it rick see you too let's
go by the way this game's not I don't
think this game's ending very soon uh no
I know it seems like it might because
they've only got you know sometime in
the clock and you know it looks like uh
June June is crashing but no It's Going
the Distance because this is still a
fight still fight we're fixing too fine
exactly and uh whilst the players are
thinking let's have a look at a move
like Rooks takes C2 so Rick takes C2 and
then the big question is which way to
capture The Rook now personally I don't
don't think I would catch up with the
King because the king takes one step
away from the Santa and also at the same
time
allows The Rook to get to A1 to H1 or
even to F1 and start nibbling on some
pawns and remember that if all the pawns
leave the board and even if you
sacrifice The Rook for the D5 Pawn then
the position
two nights against the king is
insufficient for the win so that's
something that lady and Jay will be
thinking about so I don't suspect that
uh King takes C2 will be played I
suspect the move like Knight takes you
to unfortunately taking away the A1
Square for uh from The Rook will be
played it's very much in G1 June style
but you know maybe she can work the
magic with a long range powers of the
rook and go Rook A6 and try to come in
this way
yeah it's funny you know I wish that
pawn wasn't on A6 because if it was on
H7 Rook B6 would come with a much bigger
punch because you could just play Rook
H6 ah those little pawn moves we were
mentioning yesterday that David Howe was
always so reluctant to make any kind of
Han move
um that was committal and and right now
I'm hearing him and like be like oh why
did you eat this earlier
yeah that's true actually like small
porn moves it was unnecessary to go H6
wasn't it she's gonna just G5 and put
the Rook on age six and maybe that could
have been a source of counter Play It's
the butterfly effect in motion those
small moves have an unintended larger
consequences
um yeah that's a that's something that
Lei teen Jay can go for another option
is maybe she's deciding to keep both
Rooks on the board and go Rick B1 is
that something that she can do
with the same idea
of Rick H1
um yeah you could do that sure I just
you know I've been dying to get rid of
that thing uh yeah
um I I it's turning into it I'm Sasha
because you know my the reason is just
because I'm I'm worried that like
suppose Knight T3 Rook H1 Rook B2 I
haven't analyzed a single move but I'm
like it just looks so much more
um easy in a way than uh having to do
this without a rock uh you know being
able to Usher my Pawn in with rook and
knights as opposed to just the knights
so and that's why I would just take the
opportunity you know like just get those
Rooks out of here I mean we'll get
White's Rook out of there and whites
Rook out of there because this this guy
come on it's got to be winning right
Rook B2 or something or rookie two
cutting off the king maybe even better
right it's just take the pawn on H2
um and yeah I'm just gonna close my eyes
and win somehow no I don't think be one
Rigby one played okay so she did both
for this though she disagreed and I mean
I and I can't argue with her I'm sure
that if she's played Rook B1
um she really did think that Rook C2 was
totally lost
um but you see what I'm saying right
like Knight C3 it just feels like one of
those lines
um with either rookie two or Rook B2
will be winning
that said I just noticed something
Knight T3 maybe her ideas for D1 Jack
because of the PIN right so you can't
take on D1 is and so Bibi it's more to
hassles if you can step forward but uh
the thing is that these damn nights
C3 takes away The Rook the square on A4
it's like
you can't you can't coordinate them and
if you just keep on checking I guess and
keep on running right up the board
yeah yeah this just looks uh delicious
for Wyatt absolutely
it looks very nice
I mean I I think that uh we're gonna
have to see what Lei Ting Che had in
mind because
um it the that line with Rook D1 doesn't
seem like anything special so we're just
we're predicting Knight C3 here and then
after
um Rook H1 looked a little bit more
um compelling
um I I was thinking that there's got to
be some easy win here with like rookie
two and queening the pond but maybe I'm
wrong maybe there's not an easy win uh
it could be and that could be exactly
that could be exactly what Lei Ting Che
analyzed that you thought you know Rook
H1 like if I play Rook E2 or something
like that trying to uh play D6 and
and then say I Let You Usher up the port
and there and there we can see already
like the the oh right actually the
evaluation is saying that Rick H3 checks
so that's that's easily one way how you
can go wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah good
point good point and tonight
Knight Knight C3
is played and which one is on the board
the cage one on the boards do you think
yeah and you know that's June that's a
great point though I think this is it
that Rook H2 Rook H3 check gives like a
lot more counter play than I would have
thought optically I thought like oh easy
I'm just gonna like play D6 and queen
the pawn but you know not so easy
because like let's just say I run with
the pawn right now with D6 to start
um you can play King E8 right
or do you have something else in mind
can you not do the same idea like
rotates because I'm just oh yeah the
king will catch the just go root takes
H2 so start with work H2 yeah and now
um
surprised that I don't have some kind of
way to fork and you know extract your
king somehow
but okay I'm sure you do I'm sure Knight
F5 or something okay and what we see a
move from uh June she's not giving
anything away Jen she's simply playing
for protection and protection only and
she's saying F3 I love it gotta love it
just keep that age pawn and also
remember that wasn't just taking the age
point it was also the counter play that
you were getting on that third rank that
was quite irritating
um you know kind of stifling me and some
of these variations so I like this okay
but you know something
if late in Jay manages by a miracle to
swap off Rooks
then she is getting closer and closer to
that draw right absolutely yeah you're
totally right about that although the
age points aren't off the board right so
that's true and it's gonna be harder to
trade than now because yeah well it's
not easy to trade those bonds are stuck
right
yeah
they are stuck and there we see Rook F1
played
attacking the night
yeah you mean she we could see something
but it does require a lot of help so
what I'm thinking is that if the Rook
found its way on H3 then you could have
some ideas of Rook text night but yeah
again I'm asking for too much from the
position because you need this Pawn on
D5 to also go away and the pawn on H2
and for the time being that is one step
too far
Still Still you know
fighting possibilities for letting Jay
and she moves her Knight to D4
everything is protected
route to day one Jack
can simply be met by moving the king up
to C4
right and we can see you later teen Jay
she's normally a very precise player
with how she centers the pieces and you
can see in this game she's put her Rook
on F5 of Santa and now I'm just looking
at the camera and you can see that the
king
there on F7 is also not precisely in the
middle of the square
yeah is that a towel it probably is huh
looks like a towel
the word tala is something that we use
in Poker it's supposed to indicate
something that you're subconsciously
doing
that uh gives an indication about your
mental state and about in poker what
hands you have in this case latinches
position
um this one is a bit more egregious than
the one before your bank and I don't
mean that in that like latent case doing
it on purpose or to be rude absolutely
not I think it is subconscious but I
think if I were white I'd be tempted
here to make a little adjustment
I was going to ask you on the subject
you know you've commented on a lot of
chess games and obviously your your
amazing poker player and you're used to
looking at those tiles have you noticed
any particular towel from any of the top
players
oh wow uh you know I I think that one
thing I always noticed about Nakamura is
that uh a lot of times nakamura's
um facial expressions don't always match
like the quality of the position so
especially you know years before when he
was doing now that he's doing streaming
of course professional streaming has
changed a little bit but I think like
you know eight ten years ago when I did
commentary on his games he used to be so
upset when he was totally winning
because I think it was like oh he wanted
to win faster or like you know something
like that right it's just like all the
it was almost like all the tension like
showed itself not in the way that you
would expect right you would expect the
tension to resolve itself with happiness
but it doesn't always happen that way
you know and in fact I think there was a
press conference with these two women
the first game that you and June won and
it was late he was smiling and it was
like Jew and June who looked really
stressed and upset it it's weird how
sometimes it's like this delayed
happiness or this delayed gratification
it doesn't always match your feelings
right away
that's a that's a really good point
actually I remember seeing this press
conference between these two and it did
look like Juan Jun was the one suffering
even though jiu and Jin had the most
comfortable game but uh late in jail
always attending the press conferences
with a smile and the speaking about
press conferences once this game is
finished
we will if there's been a decisive
result we will head there as well and
now the king moves to C4
to 1 June playing very careful accurate
chess the King on C4 cannot be checked
but the plan is very clear she just
wants to move the king forward it is the
Deep Pawn on
that square that wants to make itself
into a new Queen
there we go King to C4 and see the power
of this uh construction here that Drew
and June is just making it so the the
Rooks are not powerful right it's like
it's hard to to get through this
I mean we've seen these Rooks be super
annoying
um foreign to win quickly right there's
always a little nagging Rook check here
and there and I find it interesting that
there's literally no Rook checks it's
actually hard to even threaten a rook
Jack I think you have to drop your route
back to A8 but we saw The Rook come to
F4 instead
yeah work at four okay cool
that is I mean I guess the idea is just
to drop the other route back to A8 and
then just uh start checking the king
from in front
yeah just continue to be annoying right
that's all you can do
you know that's a good thing in chess
right yeah keep the game alive that's
the only thing to do
because I I think I just saw there in
chat that someone said no you never won
a game by resigning I always had this
quote it was like as a cold hard fact
until I was corrected by one of my
friends and he said actually there is a
story about someone trying to resign and
the other person wouldn't accept it and
said no I'm gonna resign because I
actually took back a move earlier on and
I felt really I feel really really
guilty that I did that wow
you have won a game there is someone who
has won a game by
someone else's opponent resigning I
don't accept your resignation I love
that oh wow I mean you know I think
that's pretty admirable because
correcting it while the game is still
going on is much better than trying to
correct it later so of course I'm sure
you know you wish you had done at a time
the player your wishes he had maybe
um corrected the move right away uh but
the fact that he gave
um that honest truth at the end of the
game is heck of a sportsmanship show and
I think these two women are also being
great Sports as well as I don't imagine
that we're going to seeing
um
much gloating there are good friends off
the board right and I wouldn't be
surprised if June June is is very not
that it would be bad for her to be
extremely joyous and ambulent after
winning this but I have a feeling she's
going to be a little understated what do
you think Jovi if she wins this game the
moment of resignation is she going to
break out into Smiles or is she going to
be pretty chill
to be honest I think that she's going to
be quite chill about it I think she's
gonna be very reserved and I think
you're going to see the emotion perhaps
in private when it will all come out but
they're certainly in public I think both
these women are definitely gonna be
outwardly the same
and then inwardly you know when you see
them with the team perhaps with their
with their supporters their parents
their family then it will their real
emotion the real you know you'll see the
amount of effort that they have put in
and they all just all come flooding out
because it has to escape somehow right I
just don't think it will be at the press
conference but you know I could be
mistaken
and this is a dream right I've always
wanted to use my one my soul Rook
um in conjunction with all my other
pieces here and uh she's getting that
dream as uh Rook to B2 has just played
you know she's she's won this three
times before
um just an historic accomplishment but
you know also there's that feeling you
know my friend it would have been her
first title and at the game she's not
thinking about that at all she's a
champion she wants to win but after the
game I think you can't help but think
about it right so it's a it's it's
difficult sometimes emotionally
um for for both players
true true and I remember reading a
passage by Max erva although when he
became world champion I mean everyone
was congratulating him and you know it
was a big emotion but inside he just
felt numb because he he was like oh
right like how how am I meant to be
feeling like I'm now the world champion
but what do I do next and maybe there is
that element of that as well
but if you've been training for this for
so long because I uh you know you all
have those moments where we've been
training for something for so long and
then when it happens we just sat there
just like rabbits in the spotlight and
we're just like oh
my God Rick H4 is on the board yeah
still there's some hope for lateing Jay
and is based on the fact that if she can
swap off Rooks if all the pawns leave
the board then those two nights alone
will not be enough to win the game
and if Jude wanjun does not win the game
then tomorrow we'll be back here
commenting on tie breaks
now don't forget though even if we get
all your pawns but we're left with a
pawn uh from the black side that can end
up making us lose against the two nights
because in a critical position that
would normally be an escape by stalemate
we're forced to move our pawn and we get
checkmated so wow can you imagine the
world championship ending like that
um that would be really good for endgame
Mastery tonight's first king because
everybody would be forced to study it as
as we watched it but I don't think it's
gonna happen just because I drew and
June isn't going to trade rocks here I
think we've passed the moment where that
trade was in the offing at this point
she's determined I mean why would you
trade a pair of Rooks here your Rook is
finally poised to go
totally I don't think we are going to
see that trade and I'm
looking at ways that
geoengine can possibly go wrong and I'm
I'm thinking I mean maybe
but it all seems quite secure right
because I was thinking maybe she can put
her Knight on B5 and
and have these two nights supporting
each other and use the Rook to check on
E2 and the king is still coming forward
I don't know I feel like it
I feel like it might be wrong
I feel like yeah I feel like it might be
finally time to just go because uh
because we're we're ready Rook B7
checked you can't even play King D6
because it might be five check winning
your Rook on A3 you're forced to go
backwards it looks like or go to F6
allowing me to play D6
um yeah this might just be the end
with the uh uh you see what I mean let's
Rook B7 check right I mean let's put
that one on the boards and that step
forces the king to step backwards and
the question is where to step backwards
somehow you you don't want to but you
feel like you might get checkmated if
the king comes to
d
8 I feel like there might be some mates
like for instance this is what I'm
looking at and then the 196 and then a
night comes to E6 and it will be like a
double night Checkmate so just to kind
of oh boy oh boy
in case there's something like this oh
no I've blundered okay but okay you get
the drift and the Knight comes into E6
and uh C6 oh nice nice yeah the problem
I think wait why is this why did well
because we came for check Ricky this is
the way that you could go wrong you get
really over excited and Ricky forchak
and whoops if you play Rick's King to C5
The Rook will come to C3 and you the
loose pieces do drop off oh my god wow
that's something yeah okay gotta be
careful to the end
because uh these things could happen
these but night nightmares in this case
um not with a K
so let's see Rook B7 check um
King V8 uh
I guess you can go go for the principle
very protection it works beautifully for
yeah engine so far everyone is protected
and still you've got this idea of Knight
C6 check or Knight E6 check and then
Knight D6 maybe yeah maybe D6 is Gonna
Come
yeah we just need to play C5 King C5
right we just need to get our King out
of out of Dodge and like suppose you put
your King on F6 instead of um da
can we just run with the pawn with D6
that's the question because finally it's
like really well supported right so D6
there's no Rook A4 I mean everything's
protected
um what do you do and actually we're
threatening D7 and you can't even step
back to E7 because I'm Knight F5 Jack oh
well maybe maybe you can go for the one
hope in this position good I'm not pink
anymore okay now D7 now D7 and now Rick
A8 and like hope and pray that the Ricks
are traded off
no I don't think it's gonna happen I
don't think it's gonna happen either no
Knight C6 or something like that right I
mean oh but you know Knight C6 this
could be a way that you could go wrong
and for instance your queen
oh that immediately would be a draw
[Laughter]
I just wanted to highlight them
I know I know I know I just I just
joking but like I was thinking 95 check
I'll do understand just yeah
we're 94. oh my God they're both fully
crushing yeah we're done we're done all
right but what did you do did she did
she did your work B7 chat she did do
Rook B7 check absolutely and the King
does come to F6 so maybe we're gonna see
your D6 move
that looked really convincing
time to go baby I mean this is a 1d4 as
the move that you went through and
selected in this game after playing
Knight F3 for a few games in a row you
know would you play D4 earlier in the
match it wasn't successful she wasn't
able to draw blood but here look at that
deep on it's actually an epon but yeah
don't worry about that detail that
d-pawn is ready the crown itself a queen
and for June June to Crown herself again
for the fourth time in a row wow
is indeed wow
and uh lay Ting Jay she's been fighting
this game she really has put up superb
resistance but in the end she could not
undo that blunder or move 22 when she
weakened her Pawn structure it's such
devastating effect and we see Juan Jun
she's now ticking to under four minutes
will she find the courage
to pick up the d-pawn and push it to D6
it does take courage because you have to
let go of this Pawn on H2
it's Unstoppable that deep on is a
Crusher
and I think she's ready to do it
it's her Championship dreams extend
and I see something happen there I don't
think it was a deep one
too she's played Rook to B2 but don't
worry the dreams of the d-pawn I do not
die
um in fact uh you know if she just wants
to play D6 without even giving up the
pawn on H2
this is this is very typical from this
game that we've seen by Juan June win
without giving your opponent any chance
at all
and one of the I'm wondering whether
Layton Jay will just simply stop the
king back to where it came from
and silently back for that repetition of
moves of course which Jew and June will
not accept
what a game
yeah that's a good idea
now
and now let's ticking to under three
minutes and 40 seconds and she drops The
Rook back to A8 getting ready to check
the king from the front
work to AAA on the board that's right
okay so what now
should we
check it on B6 should we check on F2
she's moved tensions forward
I'm getting ready exactly I'm pinning
and this unpinning allows her to Shield
the king from any checks
with 96 that's right 96 and what a
beautiful move Knight C6 is because
notice how the knight in the pawn are
actually
creating a force field and the king is
not able to return to help with
defending against the d-pawn right so
Knight T6 would be quite a nice move
all right let's see what is she gonna do
to try to
um ward off disaster from a move or two
more because don't forget now that that
King is unpinned you also have to worry
about just the basic geometric effects
in the position like Rook F2 check and
you can't play speaking of force field
you can't play King E7 or King E5
because I'll hit you with a knight F5 or
an idf3 check forking you
um you'd have to go to one of the light
squares
um and there's only one light squared
that you can go to G6
so Rook F2 check actually cuts that King
off and this is the technical
um point I think of June June if if you
can cut that King off to G6 then it's
just party time I mean you can close
your eyes and uh play pin the pawn on d8
because there's no stop in it there's no
stopping her
and that's why CJ attacks the night but
your idea is still very much in
operation you can throw in a check with
Rick F2 you can also move the Knight
towards the center you can even play
like a very calm defensive move Rook C2
anything I mean G1 June cannot go wrong
here
yeah I mean it is true now that if I
check I guess you can go back to E7 or
something because and that's why she put
the Rook on a light square right
she put the work on a light Square so
that there would be fewer night Forex
for those of us who get night forked all
the time and Blitz chess I feel like
this is very instructive right so the
Knight always switches colors so when it
goes from a dark Square on D4 to a light
Square it means that if you are on a
light Square you can't get eaten
totally yeah if you put them in opposite
squares like you say there will be no
fork and I just love your description of
the force field and the force field is
around White's King you know anytime
black tries to check with Rook C8 it's
just gonna be met with that Shield
overnight coming to C6 and blocking it
and you still have the problems of this
Pawn marching forward to these Sykes The
Rook is going to drive away the king I
mean wide's position is working in
beautiful Harmony and there we can see
Latin Jay she's coming to the two minute
Mark and wow
in big and big trouble position is lost
by the way we have a lot of East
Coasters in America waking up right now
it's Saturday morning it's almost 8 A.M
the Sun is up and Welcome to our
Christmas World Championship thank you
for joining us I mean you missed most of
the game if you're just waking up now
but we're still really happy to have you
you can catch it later but to recap June
playing a masterful positional
performance and now is poised to capture
her fourth title and avoid the tie
breaks that many of us have been
anticipating all together
um and can she do it well you're gonna
be strapped in
watch these final moments as she grabs
for that fourth crown
mm-hmm
and talk about final moments late in Jay
is under one and a half minutes
and such an impossible situation for her
she puts the Rook on E3 she is praying
for June to make a mistake and will it
arrive Junction I'm anticipating her
playing Knight C6 getting ready to
advance the d-pawn to D6 that's right
Knight to C6 or D6 right away so um okay
so you can't again that King is cut off
because you can't play your king to E6
or E7 and uh
Rook F2 check
Cuts them off even further
meanwhile uh we're ready uh to March
upon forward
with the help of the king in the Heights
I mean this phone has plenty of amazing
body car the guards around it you know
the night will come to C6 the king can
walk over to B6 if checked and go to C7
and in the meantime these two Rooks and
the King they just cannot withstand this
Pawn's advances
Rick C a check are we going to play
Knight C6 or are we gonna play King B6
so we got a couple different options
there oh my God oh my God children on
the board Rook CA check King D5 oh for
Lei Ting Che one for relating Chase okay
okay so this is a big Pitfall do not put
your king in the middle of the board a
nice spot there Jennifer and don't worry
and that would be Checkmate so still
that's why you don't want us to be
careful
that's why you don't resign but that
didn't happen
um so E5 was played instead of attack
Knight C6 check on the board
mm-hmm
yeah that's right eye King has to move
never resign guys though that that check
made out of nowhere if that didn't
convince you to never resign then I
don't know what we are
okay you can resign once in a while if
it's like queen and king and you know
your opponent can do it but don't resign
in position like this and don't let the
analyzing with the engine in situations
like this to to make you uh to make you
do that because remember these end games
are very complicated and things can turn
around
um but here we are Knight C6 check I
where where is he gonna go King E6
to under 20 seconds on the clock but it
is Mission Impossible for Lei Ting Jay
moves the king up the board perhaps she
has the plan
yeah maybe she's just banking on
sacrificing her work for the D pawn and
then hoping somehow or other that this
king and the Rook can coordinate to eat
this H2 Pawn
so D7 you're saying D7 you think is
going to happen D7 d7's on the board
there it is D7 is on the board I mean
it's either you resign
or you've tried to fight in any way
possible
but so you're saying you're saying Rook
D3 here maybe King F3 I was thinking
Rook D3 the reason
Rook D3 there's there's a knight D6 chat
it's gonna happen
well she's done it she's done Rook D3
let's
be the end of the world championship
you've been with us the entire two weeks
Jovi I mean we're three weeks really
and it comes downstairs
and it does it came down to the 12th and
final game
so Tan's full of Fighting Chess and in
the end
it was all down to nerves in the final
game
but here it is something we could stick
something on B8 and we're just gonna
make a queen for nothing
you stick a Rooker a night on B8 and
and what do you do it's it's a queen
not only a new chess Queen there it is
Rook to B8
and
there that's it the handshake that says
that Jew engine is a women's world
champion again
wow amazing congratulations to you when
June four-time women's world champion
she is now there in the history books
alongside some of the women's greatest
chess players in history very romantic
nonica printers ready Maya tibetanitza
fan and now we have juwen June what a
performance what an absolute star it's
been incredible hasn't it Jennifer what
a game Jovi I mean that was Sensational
so many people predicted a draw going
into tie breaks but instead June June
won a positional Masterpiece reminding
everyone this is what I do this is what
I do I come in and I win the Women's
World Championship now she's done it
four times
yeah it was an amazing amazing game and
she proved us all wrong I have to say it
because I expected Juan Jun to come to
this game just thinking well she's just
gonna play a very solid very stable
opening and I thought that was going to
be what's gonna happen and just ask a
few questions and then agree a draw and
just roll up the sleeves for tie breaks
tomorrow and we were all proved wrong
because Julian Jun came in with an
aggressive opening a very very combative
style and in the complications it was a
fatal error on move 22 from late in J
and that was it and after that June
played it to perfection
it's like you say Jennifer she did what
she came to do and she showed us why she
is one of the best
absolutely and I mean a game like that
drove me I mean that want to make me
switch to 1d4 because that uh that keep
on and that pressure with her Queen side
initiative I mean just ended up deciding
the game I mean it was just a
beautifully executed it's funny because
if at one point you had these terrifying
pawns on A4 and B5 and you know they
they went away but they were placed by
more terror on D4 it it just an
incredible positional Masterpiece that I
think will be enjoyed for generations to
come
definitely and it all happened in the
final the 12th classical game in the
Women's World Championship in Chongqing
we saw late in Jay she was such a worthy
competitor she came to every single game
determined well prepared with the right
frame of mind and we saw that because
she absolutely dominated in Shanghai you
know she even drew first blood in game
five and Jun she had to react with
absolutely everything in order to
equalize the match and what a match this
is just historical for me
it really was it's a game worthy of
winning the Women's World Championship
it's a it's the drama the story uh just
beautiful to see it of course if before
the game I was like winning tie breaks
because I wanted to you know call the
another date with you Jovi it's been
such a pleasure but after seeing that
game oh my God I mean what a perfect
ending to the world championship it
couldn't have been more beautiful and
more of a reminder to everyone that you
know chess is not just about tactics and
openings like this is about
understanding the game and doing gave us
a positional Master Class
absolutely and I I must admit that when
that handshake appeared on the board my
heart literally went up to my mouth and
I got very emotional there because it
really is history in the making and
maybe we're seeing the start of a new
rivalry
but what can we say about letting Jay
such a worthy competitor it's been
absolutely brilliant
yeah and by the way don't go anywhere we
are going to be coming up with the press
conference from the scene as due in June
accepts both congratulations and
questions
um as well as late
as you mentioned the really admirable
runner-up who has gained so many new
fans with her beautiful play and her
incredible expressiveness and her spirit
definitely
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no no
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
come on
thank you
[Music]
born in 1991 in Shanghai world champion
Jew and Jun has won the fide Women's
World Championship three times now she
attempts to become the sixth four-time
champion in that time she has
established herself as one of the
strongest women to ever play chess as a
teenager Jew was already one of China's
best players at age 13 she finished
second in the Asian women's Chess
Championship at 18 she earned fide's
official woman Grand Master title and at
just 19 she won the Chinese women's
Chess Championship
the next year she had already fulfilled
all the requirements to become a
Grandmaster by 2016 Jew found an even
higher gear she won two of the three
events she entered in that Year's v-day
women's Grand Prix the latter by a full
point easily winning the entire series
Jew earned a world championship match in
2018 against tanjong Yi Zhu proved that
her Stellar consistency in the Grand
Prix was no fluke in the early part of
the match Jew went on a hot streak
winning three or four games after 10
total games she was world champion but
there was not much time for Drew to
enjoy her accomplishment viday had
scheduled a large field world
championship tournament just six months
later with no special privileges for the
champion in the end however The Knockout
event was simply another opportunity for
Jews star to shine not only did she win
the tournament to state champion she
coasted through most of it in the first
four rounds Jude didn't need so much as
a tie break when it came time to face
Katarina lagno in the final resilience
was also called for Jew fell behind with
one game left needing a win on demand to
force a playoff and she did just that
then she won the tiebreaker as well
proving that her Excellence extended to
Rapid chess Zhu had now won the World
Championship not once but twice in the
same year in 2018. she joined
viramanchik as the only woman to win two
in a single year in nearly unprecedented
fashion Jew had proved she was no
one-off in her career to date including
a third world championship in January
2020. Jew has shown the ability to
dominate several formats large matches
small matches knockout tournaments even
the round robin of the Grand Prix all
have gone her way a Jew on June she's
too strong to experience to freak out
and make a mistake whether enjoying a
3-1 run against the world champion or
nearly going undefeated in a large field
knockout she is simply one of the best
the Challenger lateing Jay will have to
be at her best too otherwise the world
champion will once again be due when
June
[Music]
thank you
um
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
thank you welcome to the final press
conference of the video women's world
champion
managed to defend her title
congratulations thank you thank you to
both players for joining us
uh
and juvention you must be really happy
to have defended your title so can you
tell us how are you feeling right now
and what was the first thought when the
game was over
actually I'm very okay uh excited and
also uh because it's finally uh finished
so it's excited and the relief in the
same time but most likely it's a very
emotional now and for the game actually
I I didn't I was very focused until the
very end so when the finish I thought
okay it's uh it's a white white Queens
that's it
thank you after the first game that you
won during this match I asked you in the
scale from 1 to 10 how happy were you
and your answer was eight are you is it
more now uh no okay I feel it's nice
because it's finished
okay thank you so much and how would you
compare it to the previous World
Championship uh is is the excitement
level now that you won the same as
before is it bigger or the first time
was was somehow more special can you
compare it
actually I think each time is very uh
special for me and I feel in this time I
feel uh okay uh it's uh really really
good I mean good quality the chess game
and I think both players are playing
very well this time and
I feel okay it's a lot lucky for me
thank you and late in GM thank you so
much for joining us again I know it's a
difficult moment but you both played
Grace throughout the whole match that's
the fact that the match was so close
make the disappoint make the
disappointment a bit smaller or or maybe
because it was so close it's even more
painful to lose this one can you tell us
your feeling
hmm I mean just right now I just think
that okay finally the match finished
then
like you know
no more pressure and there are so many
things look forward to do it so for me
it's like
kind of release
and what are you looking forward to the
most now
Maybe
some eat some
tasty food
okay hopefully hopefully you will get
that very soon thank you so much for the
answer and yeah let's start juvenile
view what made the difference today how
would you describe today was the
critical moment of the match for sure do
you think it was experience preparation
or maybe ability to handle the pressure
okay I feel maybe when when she played
Knight B3 I take some like some time and
decided to play Bishop F6 but after that
I feel it's complicated and in the end
game I feel black is fine but maybe she
didn't see this Knight B1 and after that
so white is better
and then it's very difficult to defend
and so in general you think it was
strictly chest connected or or something
more like experience helped you or
ability to handle this emotional I feel
maybe
um okay maybe it's uh just I was just
more lucky and also
I feel that some
some prep is helped me yeah
okay thank you late in GM
how do how do you feel what made the
difference today
I think just like the last question like
for me
okay I lost the game I lost a match
but
yeah there are a lot of things look
forward
and yeah I mean I I will still play
chess I mean I will try my best to play
chess
so
and also I mean actually I'm very happy
to play with her in this match and I
learned a lot so
I mean
yes probably I will come back in the
future but it's hard to say
thank you and what do you think are the
biggest lessons that you can take from
this match for the future
I think
the biggest part is like
the first thing I think is uh how can
you control yourself under such pressure
and also I learned like some Spirits
from my opponent like just a
fight for the every game and fight until
the end so such things like this
thank you and juvenile any any lessons
any any things that this three almost
three weeks have taught you uh yes yes I
mean this tournament means a lot for me
also I learned some from my opponent I
feel she is really
of has some fighting experience and the
place nice and uh for for me it is uh uh
I mean it is a very long tournament and
there it really means a lot for me
thank you
do you think the fact that you played
previously two matches because the match
format is very specific very long as you
mentioned they think it has helped you
oh yes I guess I was more experienced
for this match but I feel when we were
in the game then we're just focusing
again
thank you and let's talk for a moment
about today's game are you willing to
share how How deep the preparation was
today and also
from the opening perspective there were
some ideas with G5
did you know them or were you
considering them
well yes I know them but
let's say there are many choices for
black and I just read it to
uh to play in this any any positions in
this this line
I don't want to ask this question too
much but I believe since it was a
critical moment it would be good to know
when you played E5
and then Knight F5 you lost the pawn on
E5 afterwards can you tell a bit more
about this decision where you're
evaluating it's fine or or was it a
mistake can you tell about this moment
yeah I mean I think
um 91 was a good idea for a good good
idea for white but before I play E5 I
think I already concerned about it but I
didn't take it seriously so I think
um yeah overall I think if I was a big
mistake for this game but
yeah at that point probably I
I should
play carefully
thank you
John you mentioned the moment when you
took Bishop F6
can you tell uh
yeah can you tell about it because there
was for example engine really preferred
to choose something else so did you want
to simplify or like of course this is
totally different when I go what was
your strategy at this point okay I I I I
think maybe I can try okay too but at
that moment I was confused that uh maybe
I'm flying after Bishop F6 or after Rook
A2 I'm not sure if it's good for me so I
decided to take that
did you want to simplify or uh
um I I just think it's more like
complicated but okay like rookie 2 is
also a good move
okay thank you and moving on from the
game now that the match is over can you
tell us a little more about the team
that was here with you about the
preparation maybe about your time here
okay for chess I I want to think that my
coach Wei and also harakrishnan and also
for a company I want to thank Miss
swamping because uh
um okay uh who works from the Shanghai
chess Center and she
accompanying with me in the Drone chain
hotel
can you tell how long you were working
together to prepare for this match
oh okay actually uh it's about
not very long I actually actually for
uh for way it's about a half year and
for Hare Krishna it's even less but they
really helped me a lot and appreciated
thank you late Ninja
any words about your team can you reveal
who was here with you and how was the
preparation to the match
okay my coach is
and also my boyfriend the Raymond song
also goes with me and
I mean I think overall
our preparation
was not so bad and I was very happy to
work with him and
we have like a
good I mean good time together
and how does it look like when you work
with your team do you work on chess can
you give us some background of course if
not that's okay or do you do also or not
just related activities together
yeah I also I also have a psychologist
and
and also you know
um spare time you also need to go to the
gym or something like this
but
um
you know so I have like a good team not
a
not only like a chest stuff like I have
like harshada
I think it's a transgenius Association
or like chaunting just Center they help
him a lot and also
there are so many people support me like
my parents and my family
so yeah there are a lot of people yeah
yeah actually my next question was about
that because
you of course the outcome is different
than what you would have wanted but you
gained many fans all over the world and
you have for sure many supporters close
to you so they have any any message
anything you would like to say to them
okay let's just say thank you guys
follow me and follow our
um torment and
hopefully
um
you can enjoy playing chess in the
future and also look forward to play
better chess in the future
thanks and yeah I wanted still to ask
you what are the next steps for you you
mentioned that probably you will be back
so so yeah can you tell about the next
plans and also maybe something about
preparation for the candidates
I think I will tap I will take I will
take a long rest after this match
because I want to spend more time with
my family
and
I mean the candidates okay I think you
still have like
I don't even know what's the schedule
for the candidates so for me I think I
just focus on probably next tournament
and
yeah yeah so
it's hard to say that you have exactly
the plan for the
chess
okay thank you thank you so much
is there anybody you would like to
dedicate this Victory to
I want to sing to Shanghai uh
chess Center Shanghai uh
okay
Sports Bureau
and also I want to thank
uh
helped me to have a good team to prepare
and also
in chess and also in the life and also I
want to think to miss swamping who's a
company and also coach Wei and Har
Krishna
okay thank you and are you are you going
to celebrate somehow tonight or maybe
better maybe no celebrate just
relax and also just
to it's just just think about these days
game yeah
okay and the last the last question a
few days ago you were laughing during
the game and you promised oh yes kind of
promised of course if you don't want you
don't have to say but would you feel
comfortable telling us what were you
thinking about okay it's about some
shanghai's uh some some more dialect
okay it's funny for me but it's uh
how did it come to your mind during the
game
somehow it's suddenly but after that I
realized that I should not smile or
laugh okay during the game then I
control myself you know then it's not
happen again
you managed to control yourself okay
thank you thank you so much to both
players for joining us that concludes
our press conference congratulations
juvenile once again for defending your
title thank you
good
and
and I'm sure everyone at home will also
join us in giving Jew and Jun a round of
applause as well I mean what a champion
four-time women's world champion joining
the history books I mean
such an extraordinary match
and this press conference as well both
players revealing their character you
could almost see the relief just in June
June's face it's over has been so much
emotion and uh late in Jay of course
entertaining us with her quips and for
me the biggest surprise was uh learning
who the seconds were
ah yeah what was surprising to you
surprising to me was um where Yi was
working with uh Juan Jun and of course
the way yeah he was the youngest person
ever to become 2700 Grandma's I think he
got that when he was 15 years old also
remarkably strong chess player Terry
Christian we did know and uh June oh
sorry late in Jay also telling us that
she was working with rajabov and her
boyfriend Taiwan grab number one
Grandmaster from Taiwan a Raymond song
I didn't know these the details oh yeah
and then and also you and June mentioned
Wang pin who's quite a strong player in
her own right she gave her uh a lot of
kudos for accompanying her during the
tournament um 2500 Peak rating uh won
the Chinese women's Chess Championship
represented China many time in the
Olympiad so she just had a phenomenal
team behind her and you know Joe I mean
you've done an incredible job this
entire tournament I mean I've seen so
many kudos for you in the chat for the
last three weeks and I I gotta give you
extra Kudos today because you uh did see
that night be one move you saw how
strong it was and it's interesting to me
that June and June also pinpointed that
as a moment like to go backwards was a
way to go for her or to her forefrown
and and sometimes you have to take that
step back as you mentioned to go two
steps forward and yeah I did feel
slightly stuck but I look very sorry for
letting Jay there in the press
conference as everyone hammered down on
that E5 move as being the game that
completely spoiled her chances for the
Women's World Championship Crown but
what can we say about letting Jay just a
worthy competitor and she of course she
has the candidates coming up next and
she will be in preparation mode for that
because one thing that has shown us very
clearly is that she is a very worthy
competitor and it went right down to the
wire here it was Game 12 just a blunder
I'll move 22 deciding absolutely
everything and for do wanjun we know
that well she will not rest either
because she might have uh one the
women's world championship title for the
fourth time in a row but she will be off
to the World Cup which is starting I
think you know almost a few days No Rest
for this four-time champion and yes I
completely agree waiting chair just um
really inspiring she's gained so many
new fans I mean uh just kind of
hilarious with her expressions and uh uh
well let's have a she's ex even though
of course she's disappointed to lose the
match I mean you don't need to to ask
the question even to know uh because she
was so close she could smell it but uh
just pointing out the relief and the
pride I think you could tell that she
was she was proud of how she performed
here she knew that she she brought
everything and she almost got it gone
and now she gets to enjoy some tasty
food I mean who can't relate to that
Toby
I certainly can relate to that I can
smell lunch cooking as well in the
background so I'm also looking forward
to tasty food and I I have to say late
in Jay and Juan Jun both of these
players playing such accurate such
precise Jazz and entertaining us every
move of the way there has never been a
dull moment with these two just uh
locking heads over the chessboard what a
performance what a match it's been
memorable for me I have to say and for
you what was your biggest takeaway Jan
well I am so privileged to get this
front row seat and I think my biggest
takeaway was that I just assumed that uh
the tie break was going to happen and
that it was going to be super exciting
and I was right about it being super
exciting but I was wrong about the tie
break and I just think that I've always
been a tactical player an E4 player and
today we got a front row seat to a
beautiful 1d4 positional Masterpiece and
it's a different completely different
way of approaching chess than my own and
a lot of the games I look at aren't that
approach so I'm sure some of the people
in the chat relate to that because a lot
of amateur players new players they also
focus on the Tactical and I hope that
maybe more people today were inspired by
June June do you know let's work on our
positional chops I'm with you let's do
it
let's do it and certainly this women's
world championship match has been
extraordinary it's been absolutely
wonderful and I'm sure you can all join
us once again in giving a hearty
congratulations to you and Jun worthy
four-time women's world champion and
it's been an honor to commentate
alongside you and also to be also a
bystander commentating on this
absolutely historic man moment and this
match and with that we are gonna leave
you all with the best moments of the
final game of the Women's World
Championship and Jennifer it's been a
privilege and for everyone at home my
name is Ivanka houska and thank you
everyone for joining us and we'll be
back with some more awesome chess
content right here on chess.com so thank
you
a decisive result today we'll see dreams
being made and broken and look at that
book there's a question mark on the move
and you're oh no and there it is a tea
please instantly she's still in she's
still in her prep oh no no later in
strategical trouble because A5 is coming
and there we see Knight to C5 oh oh this
just looks devastatingly beautiful
position for white
okay but something else happened I think
it's 85. I thought it was a bad move it
is a bad move
[Music]
95.91 nice beautiful well spotted but
right now I just see pure stress but to
do when June looks very calm oh yeah
look at those expressions oh I know
people are suffering along with her not
only a new chest Queen there it is Rook
to B8
there that's it the handshake wow
amazing congratulations to you when June
four-time women's world champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]